Ooh,
wait,
hey everybody.
If you never had one of these podcasts before,
it's supposed to be us watching the fights.
We're definitely gonna watch the fights because Jamila is right about to fight
Joe Lozan Holla Ho Shit.
But we're also,
I'm intoxicated and we will be talking shit about completely unrelated subjects.
Uh,
so don't totally expect people get mad when we were at fort brick tome,
Bro.
Where's,
you know,
says it doesn't always happen folks.
Disclaimer,
bitch,
we don't have a producer.
This is as close.
I mean we have Jamie,
but we don't have a like an executive that's telling us how the show goes.
So we just talk.
Um,
but the fight is going to be awesome for sure.
It's a rematch.
Remember that?
Fight the first fight.
[inaudible] remember any fights?
Crazy blind magnitude.
Really close fight.
It was a war.
What happened?
I believe Miller wanted decision.
Jamie,
see if,
see if I'm correct.
You don't even remember if you know,
how am I supposed to remember?
Super,
super close fight.
I'm pretty sure that Miller wanted decision.
Uh,
but I remember it being really tightly matched.
Like if you look at these guys like skill wise,
you think about them like both guys are like at this point in their career,
like super consummate pros.
You know both.
There's real similar in that regard.
Almost mirror images and the fact that these bolts guys are so competent and
they have some amazing victories like Miller,
when he tapped out all the vera Lozan just knocked out Diego Sanchez.
I mean come on.
I was like probably one of his best victories ever.
How about when he was 19 I think it was when he knocked out Jens Pulver.
Remember that Shit Dude?
Lozano is a beast.
Oh Shit.
All shed.
Good defense.
Hold guys.
You're super legit on the ground.
Fuck yeah.
Miller one.
The first one in the a decision.
Yeah.
See my members had that bad but I remember it being a fucking war.
Right.
Was this split decision?
Jamie?
Unanimous,
unanimous decision.
These are the kind of fighters that fight to their full potential.
They have so much confidence.
They've done it so much,
so much experience that you could trust them no matter what crowd you put them
in front of,
no matter who you put in front of them,
they're going to do.
They're going to perform like they do at the gym at their best.
Yeah.
That's a great way of describing it.
Seasoned as fuck that doc sees.
Chipolte lay fried chicken and shit.
Three minutes and 50 seconds.
(484) 074-0640 five if you want to sync up in the first round.
Yeah,
there's a I.
This whole card is fucking bang up man.
I was real excited about this card.
They're both really good strikers that both really good wrestlers.
They're both really good at Jujitsu.
I mean Jim Miller is a wrestler who's legit black belt that has really good
office back.
He tap memory,
tap for ratio.
Kimonti's captain in an arm bar from the guard.
I don't remember.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
It was legit as fuck dude.
His Jujitsu is no joke and that was on as well
as top shell.
Fasting transitions.
He finished.
He's a finisher.
He puts you in a triangle.
It's a probably 98% rap city,
you know,
you know what I like about Lowe's on too.
It's like he goes from zero to a hundred miles an hour.
Like instantly he hits hard as fuck.
He's game.
He's a true savage.
You'd put them in the and the coliseum against lions and shit.
Did you know what I mean?
And you know what's interesting,
Super Nice Super Smart Guy.
When you talked to him,
he's like a tech wizard,
you know,
you talked to them about video games and you used to work on computers and when
he dives on shit man,
I mean he like completely fully commence on things.
This is a little serious shit.
Pepino Cuevas versus a um,
Tommy Hearns or some shit.
Yeah.
This is classic shit really going on.
We're watching some classic MMA guys like,
can't you look at like top level professionals?
These guys were in,
you know,
for sure that the top of their class,
I would put either one of these guys up against a lot of the 155 pounders in
the,
you know,
the top eight,
top nine,
you know,
did they get thrown down with anybody?
They could go right there with Conor McGregor.
He can throw down key.
Imagine Joe Lowe's on Conor Mcgregor.
That would be amazing.
So God damn fast dude got hit so goddamn hard.
Holy Shit.
It's not just hard man.
It's the accuracy is a big part of it.
I mean it's definitely hard.
He hits hard as fuck,
but it's the speed and the accuracy combined like his f eating.
You know what people give him a hard time about doing that.
Uh,
Edo Port Dow Movement Shit.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
Because his movement is outstanding.
Like his ability to move his body.
I think people joke about that.
They know it's the chin,
but it's just the way he has called the touch.
You know what I mean?
I think people know what's the jet and his movement is great.
Like to know how much of an effect it really has had.
It's basically like a Kata.
Your mood,
you know,
you're even more crazy.
Oh,
look at this fight dude.
This,
oh,
these guys are going after it.
Good body shots.
Yeah man.
I just,
I was so impressed with the way,
first of all is timing on that left leg kick there.
Nice touch,
but touch,
touch.
But
have you seen that?
Have you seen the parody of Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor?
There's,
there's dudes that,
he's like a,
he uses a Nate Diaz type a snapchat filter on my Instagram.
There's a video of it.
Uh,
dude,
it's fucking hysterical.
It's a parody climate.
Gregor and Diaz.
I getting a intimate,
getting like slightly gay.
Have you seen this?
No,
I have not.
Oh dude,
it's so fucking,
that's hilarious.
The guy who does Nate Diaz is,
is perfect.
That could be a cartoon.
Do just Nate Diaz and Conor Mcgregor,
like the odd couple just hanging out that,
that,
that'll be an easy hit.
Easy sensation
to the pace in which those guys fought that five round fight.
I don't think I've ever screened as much during that fight.
I was actually screaming going,
ah,
like Alton was a fight.
It was so intense.
That was a fight where I felt like,
man,
I would've rather done a fight companion for this then call it.
Cause I wanted to swear a bunch of times.
Think I've ever got as excited for any fight ever.
Seriously.
Maybe the only other one was Nogueira Bob Sapp.
That's the only other one.
God damn crazy.
That was such an amazing fight.
Holy Shit.
Connor muck.
Fucking Gregor man.
Holy.
And they're both awesome.
They're both awesome.
That was a great fight.
You mean?
I,
I honestly,
I haven't gone back and watched it again and tried to score it and uh,
I stopped a long time ago trying to score fights while I'm watching them,
but I don't know what the fuck is.
I mean,
the fact that he went five rounds and Nate Diaz,
he kept up with them.
I thought for sure if it went past three,
Nate was just going to completely dominate and he fucking hung in there.
Man survived that fourth round,
kind of seemed like he kind of caught a second wind somewhere around the fourth
round and he started a punching like looser and more relaxed,
like sort of fell into a different pace.
Yeah.
You know that fight prove that Connor has,
um,
he proved that he has legit heart,
she was in trouble.
There are a couple of rounds and Nate was messing them up and I had him against
the fucking cage.
It looked like he was slowing down and he fucking regrouped.
He got an second wind or whatever you want to call it.
He came back and,
and fuck.
It was an important fight to watch,
you know,
cause that was a guy that had just decided that he was not going to be defined
by this one fight and then what?
It was not going to be defined by his past result and that he's better than
that.
And he's going to come in,
he's going to show everybody.
And Dude,
if he could keep that pace up that he fought in that first round,
you know,
it's like he's so explosive and dominant cruisers talking about it.
And I was a really got me thinking,
man.
He said,
I don't know if you could fight in a style like Connor does for five rounds.
And I thought about it,
I was like,
wow,
man.
Dominick Cruz,
first of all would know,
right?
If anybody's gonna know Dominic is kind of super high fight Iq.
So I considered it at a respect and then I thought about it,
I was like,
well,
there's only one way to move that fast when we,
when Connor closes the gap and blasts Nate with those left hands,
the fucking,
the speed and explosiveness of it,
that's a very tense movement.
Like that takes a lot of energy to do.
I think it takes way more energy than what Nate does because what Nate and nick
do,
the overwhelming you with volume and they're overwhelming ability to maintain a
certain level,
like a certain level of activity.
Like especially nick,
he's the master at it.
Like maintaining a level of activity that you can keep up for it and then turn
it on once they smell blood.
Yeah,
like the frank shamrock fight.
Great example of that.
Um,
the Paul daily fight is a great example of that.
There was a war.
Imagine fighting a guy that that's your,
that's their style.
And they said,
where are you now?
And as soon as they smell blood,
that's when they turn it on.
You don't want a guy like that.
You want a guy that uh,
know
talking shit the whole time he's punching you.
Yeah.
The whole time he's punching you,
he was talking shit.
You never get to relax.
Yeah.
He's like,
what bitch?
What bitch?
He's hitting you.
I think there was a referee,
I'm trying to remember who was fighting,
but there was a referee once.
We're two guys were fighting.
I want to say it's Nick Diaz,
but it might not have been with the referee was telling them to stop talking.
And I was like,
don't tell him to stop talking.
Why would you tell them to stop talking as if it's somehow or another?
It's worse to beat someone's ass and talk shit,
then it is to just beat their ass.
That's so bizarre.
You know,
why can't you talk shit
and Nate Diaz is,
he's,
he's beyond a rockstar.
I mean he's,
he's as famous as a rock star.
I mean,
right now,
dude on Instagram,
he's already over a million followers.
I mean,
he is,
he's got it.
That attitude that they'll never be another Nate Diaz.
No.
He know what I mean.
You,
there'll be,
I mean,
can you imagine a guy trying to emulate his personality?
You know,
they'll never be anybody like Nate.
And uh,
the one thing that impressed me,
one thing that impressed me a lot about Nate Diaz is his ability to track,
talk,
trash talk in the media pack.
I mean,
that touched that stuff.
some people thought he was going to get trout and he got real real quick.
Yeah,
no,
he's good at that.
He,
first of all,
he doesn't get rattled and that was a big problem in the first fight,
I think too with Connor did,
he had to overcome,
this is the first guy that not only did he not get rattled,
he got back at him and he made them flinch at the weigh ins.
I think that was big.
Yeah.
Bunch of people talked about that.
Red Band was one of the first people that pointed out to me.
He sent me a thing.
It was,
dude,
look,
he flinched.
I went,
Oh shit.
He flinched.
That seems so stupid.
Yeah,
it seems so fourth grade,
but there might be something to do.
It was that the greatest UFC fight ever.
God Damn it,
man.
It's so hard to tell.
There's so many good ones these days,
but it was a swap meet
flashlights.
The fact that the Connor's considered,
oh Ratti,
he's considered one of the greatest.
Some people might say he's the greatest of all time.
Some people might say that just based on what they've seen.
It is a,
it is amazing,
but then there's condit Robbie Lawler
and the Nate Diaz as well.
Nate Diaz,
the guy that people consider this,
the new unstoppable force made dia stopped him.
He choked him out.
Now,
second fight.
It could've went either way and I had an ideas winning,
but when looking back at it again,
I'm like,
shit,
that second round,
that's a hard one to score.
I see how it could've gone either way.
I really do.
It's almost a shame in a fight that's that close.
Like I would like to see what the results are.
I think the majority of people thought that Conor one,
and this is what I think you have to consider those knockdowns and that,
that Connor was staggering him with those straight laughs and,
and cracking them with those leg kicks.
You look,
you're like decisive moments in the fight.
I feel like those decisive moments of super crisp punching,
where knocks him down.
We used repeatedly landing that leg kick that's kind of worth a lot.
Like he was lighting him up barley at first round.
But if it meant that much,
you could look at it in another way.
If it made that much.
Maybe it didn't mean that much because if it did,
how,
how was he on his back when the fight ended and Nate Diaz is on top grounded and
pounded,
like if all that meant so much maybe didn't mean that much after all.
Well,
I don't know man.
You know,
that's just another way of looking at it.
Cause it pride didn't,
don't,
I mean it's,
everybody knows that they uh,
judge fights based on how the fight looks at the end.
So how would it,
how would the Japanese look at that?
Well that moment where Nate's on top is huge.
When it finally takes him down.
That's huge.
I thought that's it.
That's what I thought at that.
Okay.
He got this round.
Boom.
That's,
that's pretty huge because also it's at the end of the fight,
which I agree with you.
I think it should matter more like,
or like the Japanese had it for where the last round was like the most
important,
right?
The judge the fight as a whole.
But how does it look at the end?
Who's getting their ass beat at the end?
Which is a real a point,
right?
Because the whole idea about what a fight supposed to be,
it's supposed to be like high level problem solving,
right?
Yeah.
And there's some guys that present like real scary problems and you've got to
figure those problems out.
And whoever's winning towards the end is the guy that really figured that
problem out the best.
Cause the guy who was on the ground,
it's not,
you shouldn't really be thinking in a fight.
Um,
just I've already ahead.
I'm just gonna let this guy get on top of me.
Like you don't,
nobody's thinking that.
Yeah.
So if the guy does take you down late in the fight is because he's starting to
overwhelm you.
Yeah.
That should be worth a lot.
It should be worth a lot.
I don't know how much though.
I mean,
how much should a a knock down like the ones that kind of event.
This is a slobber knocker Oh my God.
These guys are going after it.
Oh Shit.
Throwing some bombs.
Holy Shit.
This is outstanding.
Oh street,
right by Lozano.
Lozano.
Oh my God.
That was on.
Got That Good Jab.
He's got real good boxing man.
Very good.
Fundamentals
and heart.
Both of these guys got some hard.
Um,
it's interesting man.
Deciding how fight should be scored cause I don't,
I don't think they've got it down yet.
I think it still needs work as a system because I think we had a bad head start
in MMA.
I'm starting off with the 10 point must system.
I just don't think it's adequate for all the aspects of MMA.
Boxing is only judging one dimension.
They're only judging one style of striking.
It's just with the hands.
That's it.
There's a clear rule set.
You could teach somebody yet.
I don't think a lot of people totally understand who's even winning fights
sometimes.
You know,
I don't think people understand who's who's in a bad position and who's totally
safe.
I just think there has to be a level of competency in martial arts themselves to
truly grasp it at the highest level.
That's why I think like former fighters would be like Ricardo Almeida I know is
doing it in new New Jersey,
which is awesome.
And he's a brilliant guy and it was a great fighter too.
Um,
and a black belt in Jujitsu completely understand the ground.
Like that's the kind of guy you want being a judge.
Like that's perfect.
You want a guy who really understands the sport and it's,
we have to make some sort of consensus as to what's most important.
Like,
if you're gonna,
if you're gonna judge the fight the way we're doing it right now,
round by round,
and a guy could just be overwhelming the guy towards the end of the fight and it
looks like he's winning and he loses a decision,
which I think we all agree,
he's like,
it just doesn't make any sense.
See right here,
here's a,
here's a good example.
The first half of this round,
Jim Miller is all over.
Joe Lozan landing the bigger shots.
But now the rounds ending with Joseph,
Joe Lowe's on getting the takedown and as an over his half guard right now maybe
not doing it the same kind of damage that Jim Miller was doing on him on their
feet.
So if the round ends here,
you know,
some people would give it to Jim,
some people to give it to Joe.
Yeah,
well this is an awesome round because there's still,
unless it's like a rule,
if in that situation,
Mike,
they have those situations written out,
all the situations,
how do you score it in this situation,
you know?
Uh,
but then,
you know,
you basically take the judges out of it and then it's more like a,
judging system is,
is it,
uh,
it's,
it's supposed to be an exact science or do you want,
hmm.
It's weird man,
because you and I might disagree.
Oh,
look at that elbow.
I mean w we would,
we,
it's very possible that we might disagree about certain aspects of scoring
or maybe it's good that you can trust the judges then that,
that forces the fighters to at not leaving in the hands of the judges.
Like everyone else says,
look man,
I don't know.
It just doesn't make any sense.
There's so many MMA fans out there that would make amazing judges.
How people do you think to post
on the underground would be incredible judges.
So many man,
there's so many experts.
Like think of these guys that are doing these youtube clips now.
You know where there are breaking down fights and talking about technique.
Have you ever seen a lot of those?
Like Lawrence Kenshin?
Do you ever seen his stuff?
No Man,
there's a lot of stuff on Muy Thai and kickboxing and stuff and man,
he knows his shit.
Beautiful videos.
He's got them all over youtube.
Well you any breaks down all these uh,
different aspects of striking and it shows what good,
what great fighters.
Uh,
look at this beautiful fucking fight,
man.
Joe Lozan staying on top where he shows like where they,
uh,
errored and a where guys capitalized on certain things and like certain traits
of guys had like,
he had this breakdown about custom motto and uh,
and Mike Tyson and his footwork and a bunch of stuff on Moyie Thai and Jim is
Jack Slack to add the custom auto one?
Does it bother you?
Oh,
oh,
oh fuck.
What a great ending.
Wow.
Did he went right for that arm?
Oh my God.
He aunt.
So that was the end of the round.
It's the end of the fight.
I know,
but like that was a,
that was a nice Harmar shit.
I thought you were scanning,
tapped,
escape.
What a fight.
Unless I didn't hear the bell.
No,
I think you're right.
I'm pretty sure because they're not showing the,
uh,
they would be showing the finish if that,
what's that?
That was in around God damn.
Oof.
Powerful Joe Lowe's on what?
The takedown.
Yeah,
take towns are huge,
man.
Guys don't want to be taken down.
It's like how much of a big deal is it?
It's gotta be worth a lot,
man.
Cause someone's doing something to you that you don't want them to do and it's
hard to do it.
It's gotta be worth a lot.
And I know a lot of people say yeah,
but you know,
sometimes you've got to take you down and get right back up.
It's no big deal,
but it's still kind of a big deal.
It's still kind of a big deal.
Like I took you down,
you do monitor me,
take you down,
and he took you down.
So,
and how long did it holds you there?
That's gotta be worth something.
It's just a question.
I agree with that.
But what's worth more control or damage?
That's the big question,
right?
Like how do you define,
I don't think you can.
I mean,
I don't think everybody's going to agree.
Striker's going to thank [inaudible] important is a worse than being controlled.
You got,
if it comes down between,
oh yeah dude took him down and held on but didn't do any damage.
But earlier in the round he got hit with like three good shots.
Kind of snubbed them and rock them.
You go with the guy that landed the punches,
right?
You got to have damage,
Yeah.
Damage is huge because if you get rocked that means you almost lost the fight
right there.
Yeah.
If you get taken down and end up in some dude's full guard or even
side control doesn't mean the fire is almost over.
I mean if you,
if you get all the fights that had side controlling them or full garden them and
factor in how many times the fight ended from that position,
it's,
it's super low 0.0,
zero 2%
yeah.
You know,
this is,
I think there should be a possibility of having long arounds.
I think it would be interesting.
I've always wondered like when you're watching a five minute round and the guy
takes a guy down at like three minutes and 50 seconds and then for the next,
uh,
you know,
minute is just completely dominating on the ground and uh,
and you want to see where this plays out.
And then the bell rings.
Like that was one of the interesting things about pride as he would see this,
this arc and those 10 minute rounds.
And I know as far as like athletes performance,
it's not the best thing cause it's too hard to do like chill son and thinks five
minutes is too hard and he might be right.
You know?
And now that everyone is all you cited,
they're a,
they're forced to do this all completely on the natural and it's,
it's gotta be hard to fight for five minutes,
but
is five rounds.
You got to have five minutes.
I'm sorry,
five minutes.
Anything shorter than five minutes is ridiculous.
It seems ridiculous for Grammar for sure.
I think,
uh,
organizations like the UFC or Bellator should have the option to do fights where
we're going to this special finds him.
He one 10 minute round or something like that or one five minute round and then
a 10 minute round or 10 minute and then a five minute like pride used to do.
Why the fuck not,
there's no reason why,
why you shouldn't be allowed to do that.
Oh,
Jim Miller wins.
Split Decision Slobber knocker um,
it was perfect example,
right?
Yeah.
He ended the fight ended with him on his back mounted,
uh,
escaped that arm bar right at the buzzer and he wins.
So,
uh,
but based on the point system,
he must have won the first and second round.
I just,
yeah,
I do not think the point system is diverse enough.
I don't think you can have a 10% like the,
the margin is always going to be in these 10% bumps.
You know what I'm saying?
Like 10,
nine,
10,
eight,
seven that seems crazy to me.
Like why,
why these big jumps?
Why these big chunks?
Like 10 point why?
Why is one ten nine round where guy totally kicks guy's ass and it's a ten nine
round and another one a ten nine round where they're just barely squeaking by
each other.
You can't figure out who won.
You have no idea who won who.
How do you score that round?
And you look at the numbers like equal number of punches and kicks,
landed equal number of take downs attempted and defended it.
What the fuck do you do with that?
You do?
You just pick a guy,
you know that's what a lot of guys do,
right?
Yeah.
That shouldn't be.
I said I didn't do that.
No you didn't know that.
If the first round was too close to call,
I'm like I'm not going to call that one.
I now cause if the second
one is too close to call,
I'm going to give them around each and then we're going to decide it and the
third,
well that's,
I'll just know that you used to do it for the UFC cause it was so long ago.
A lot of people are not officially,
it was like just the way I scored it in my you,
you weren't a judge for the UFC,
but what you would do was like Harold Letterman on Hbo,
which I always loved.
I loved that aspect when Harold Letterman would come on,
how,
tell you how I see it gym and he would go over the score.
You do you remember that guy?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I mean he's the best and the spot was based like rip that off.
Yes,
I know but it was,
but I liked that.
I think MMA could benefit from something like that.
Yeah.
Got To get a real fighter in that.
And I never found you have San never find them in Mesa.
I was the wrong guy.
You weren't the wrong guy.
Cause you know a lot about fighting and you had a really good system.
Like your system is probably like one of the best systems.
Plus,
uh,
if you're,
if you also analyze the other aspects of the fight,
like if you look at your system,
like you would have like take down from one column and then you would have like
submissions and kicks and punches and you just mark make marks for each guy
whenever you did it.
And then you'd look at it at all,
think about it in your head and then decide like what was important.
But I think that is like the,
the,
the big catalyst is like,
you know those subjective calls that you have.
But towards the end of the round,
even though he only landed four or five punches,
he had his opponent really badly hurt.
So I'm going to give him the round,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
The only reason I did that is because I had to go on air and I didn't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
And when you're watching a fight,
you forget.
So I would write any,
anything significant I would write down and I have the shorthand for it,
like left hook himself.
I went on air,
I could look down at that and go,
well,
early in the round he had to take down,
but he did get knocked down and he'd landed a couple leg kicks and I'm going to
give the roundup boom,
you know,
that way I sounded like I actually remembered what I was watching,
but that's cheating.
But it would make um,
scoring easier when I could go back in the round and go,
Oh shit,
oh,
can we get it to this dude?
Boom.
It's easier to go back and review it around instead of going on pure memory
because sometimes you forget it's a five minute round.
Something happens in the first 45 seconds and then a bunch of other shit happens
in the middle.
Now there's 15 seconds left,
some shit's going down.
You might have forgotten that shit in the beginning.
Huh?
You know why?
I think too,
when you're really involved in a fight,
you're in the moment in a lot of ways.
You know,
you're watching it.
You're like,
what's going to happen?
What's going to happen?
You'll locked in the moment and I don't know about you,
but when I'm in that spot I don't have like the best memory.
No,
I know.
The more I'm enjoying a fight,
like I'll remember it after the fight,
but like while it's going on I'm,
I'm thinking about what's happening only and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that did happen.
Oh that's right.
He took him down off the choke.
I forgot.
How did I forget the choke?
I'm thinking,
damn,
I don't remember any of this shit.
Well you get so locked up in them over a course of five rounds.
I know that Robby versus Carlos
condit was one of my favorite fights ever.
But I couldn't tell you what happened.
God dammit
conduit Maya is right now.
It's so exciting.
I love this fight.
You know there is hope that these,
these conversations that we have in podcasts about the scoring system,
it should be this or it should be that.
It is nice to know.
I thought they were,
to tell you the truth.
There was a couple times he got into it when I'm like,
why the fuck are we talking about this shit?
This shit's never going to change this.
It's like forget it.
You know what I mean?
Let's just drop it.
Um,
but there is hope because there have been changing.
Yeah.
They made the new changes to the touching and the ground,
right?
Yes.
Explain.
You probably know you,
I think you told me so can you refresh my memory?
Yeah.
This is,
I don't want to screw this up and I'm not exactly sure it goes when it goes into
play.
I probably should know this year.
First of the year.
Yeah.
That's what I look at Jamie.
Powerful
way into where you are in the UFC.
Big Time.
When you first started working with chuck,
that really someone looked at me,
look this up during the fights last weekend.
So you were just a Joe Rogan Fan,
but you're like,
when he would talk about MMA,
you'd be like,
ah,
right.
Can we turn it off and shit.
It still doesn't stick very much for some reason.
I don't know why.
But you do enjoy the shows.
Now write down 100%.
Would you consider yourself a fan?
Like he'd go on [inaudible] website and ship.
Awesome.
I love watching like the embedded stuff,
like getting pumped up for fan.
Then you're pretty cool.
Check.
Jamie's a fan of a lot of sports though.
And a man only has so much fucking free time in the day.
When you talked to Jamie,
he knows his shit when he knows college basketball.
He's one of those mother fuckers.
He's one of them college football motherfuckers who
he watched him.
You just,
I'm just,
I'm trying to,
I'm just like,
okay.
I'm always check with the sometimes,
um,
this girl's fight now,
Paige vanzant and Beck Rawlings.
This is a good fight,
man.
This is going to be a crazy fight.
Shit.
Back Rawlings is bad ass.
And so his page,
that page girl goes straight from dancing with the stars and was like,
get me a fight.
Get right.
But she's 23 years old,
dude.
Game is fuck both of those girls.
This is going to be an awesome fight,
man.
This is a good one for Fox.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's always good to have it.
Isn't it crazy that MMA is the sport where girls,
women found a fucking hole out of now they can just blossom and explode through
the galaxy.
Now they can't do that with women's basketball.
No one's watching that shit.
Women's baseball.
There's no women's baseball.
They've got women's softball and they show the college,
but there's no future.
There's no money in any of that shit.
They'll show women's fucking volleyball,
but there's no pro women's volleyball leagues.
That's a good idea.
Uh,
but you know,
you're watching the Olympics,
right?
You're watching the Olympics and I'm like,
there,
they barely show,
when they show men's volleyball,
it's like for three
minutes,
it's like,
okay,
what's the least amount of time we can get away with showing the men's
volleyball so they could focus on the women?
The women volleyball players are superstars,
but like the men,
they're like,
okay,
two minutes.
Okay,
no one's paying attention to the men's volleyball.
Nobody watches has got the lowest ratings ever.
But for some reason people are interested in women's volleyball or the beach.
But how did beach volleyball become an Olympic sport?
Jujitsu dude.
Seeing what they're wearing.
Fantastic.
Holy Shit.
Areas that we think,
look no,
they have to be almost naked.
Oh,
it's falling.
Oh it's volleyball.
Volleyball is such a sophisticated sport.
Oh my God.
I love,
it's a lot to it,
man.
First of all,
you can't play it in shorts.
Can't be done.
You,
you must wear,
it's the best.
Trust me.
You'll get better vertical loose shorts or anything.
Baggies.
Not Good.
Yeah.
They'll put sun lamps on you.
Bitch,
take your clothes off.
It's that hot enough.
Could someone make a fire?
I think volleyball and then the gymnastic
trying to find men's gymnastics.
It's on for three minutes.
They go,
they go to Bob Costas.
He gives you a quick review and then they go to the seven hours straight.
They do the curls all day.
The guys,
they want to see them do the rings or they want to see him break a leg.
Yeah.
Real quick.
Just in and out.
We'll fit them in digital little dead time cause they got it.
They can't make it that obvious.
Come on.
They came us women's gymnastics and volleyball and soccer and all that shit you
can't do that is when they got a fucking bar.
Is Women's volleyball like the most sexist sport ever?
Like look,
come on.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with it if they want to dress like that,
but the fact that they make them all just like that is that real picture fucking
crazy.
Like this isn't like,
it's not like to stay alive or something.
Do you need to wear like as little clothing as possible?
Like that doesn't make any sense why they're in their underwear.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Why the fuck?
What am I picks?
Are they going to be allowed to wear thongs or is it written somewhere that they
can't actually wear a thong?
Is that,
why did they have to dress like with that?
That's a ridiculous,
and they're in
very hot on the beach.
It's so stupid.
Beach Volleyball's in an Olympics poured
out on the beach.
Yeah,
dude,
I go to the beach too.
I don't wear underwear like that.
Like that same fucking beach.
I wear shorts.
It's incredible.
Team,
Egypt was,
oh my God,
Egypt's than just like mummies.
Three people watch men's volleyball.
Come on,
think about that.
Who's watching men's volleyball?
Why does Egypt have to wear so much clothes?
That a religious thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
I would like to see that game.
Are there highlights of that one?
I want to see the think that there would be a benefit in wearing that as far as
like not getting your skin scratched up by the sand look.
Does that make sense?
But that would make you,
that's brutal man.
Religions that make you wear certain clothes.
Like you're only allowed to wear certain clothes.
How bout and everyone's like,
you will kill you,
but if you cut your dick off you can cause a,
apparently it's okay.
It doesn't say that you can't be a transvestite or a transgender,
but you can't be gay if you're gay.
A lot of gay people in the Middle East,
they got to become transgenders or they'll die.
I read something about that's on vice news.
Bullshit is vice real.
I saw that on vice news.
Well,
you know it's a whole episode of vice covers.
A lot of different subjects from what?
A lot of different authors,
but they,
if they're saying it so well,
it's Shane Smith is a friend of mine,
the guy who owns it.
But Fox that show as a matter of how much it's happening in my bs and might be
insignificant.
Olympics,
Mongolian wrestling coaches strip and protest of loss.
What they started,
they started throwing their clothes at the judges.
Oh my God.
Was it a decision that bad?
Pretty bad about the guys that got robbed and real right there.
Did that happen a lot?
Oh,
it didn't happen.
Like I made that story.
That was bullshit.
Nobody got rob.
No,
he didn't get robbed.
Man.
Don't even hear about this.
I wonder if that's a lie.
Well,
they have video cameras.
That's why he had to tell the real story.
They had security cameras from the place you might go to jail for it.
Oh,
so nobody got robbed?
No,
not,
not only did you get robbed,
but he changed his story and a,
he sponsors dumped him.
He had a like a,
a massive sponsored dump.
He was drunk.
I guess he fucked up.
I mean a guy did apparently pull a gun on them,
right?
Didn't the guy,
apparently the vandalized a gas station.
Right.
And the security guard was making them pay for it and you didn't.
And whether or not they wanted to do or not,
but did the security guard to make them pay?
Did okay?
Yeah.
But see man,
okay.
Even that alone,
like that story alone,
if they just told the truth,
that's pretty sketchy.
You know what was the truth?
A gun pulled on you in Brazil.
So the gun did get pulled on them.
Apparently they vandalize a door.
Julie say Ryan Lochte,
the Heisei.
So the guide that's claiming they got robbed,
he was doing some bet vandalizing.
Now he,
I just think they were drunk apparently.
And um,
I like to say apparently,
look,
I'm a lawyer or some shit.
Um,
and they,
they,
they broke a bathroom door or something.
Is that the story?
Jamie?
We're going to give you the whole story folks.
I know.
How frustrating is if you listen to this shit,
how bout are going after it about backpacking pay job?
She's a very good striker.
Has been backing her up.
She's a very good striker man.
Maybe pages is a,
that's a strategy is to make her come to her.
Maybe page.
Ooh,
that's a nice knee to deliver back.
Rawlings
is no joke man.
Her striking is very legit.
Super aggressive with it too.
And you see a girl with Dominique tattoos like that chick is not scared.
Gotcha.
She's not scared.
She's not scared of pain.
She's not scared to fuck you.
Oh Jesus.
What a combination.
Raleigh going off like nice knee to the body.
Good striking dude.
I'm telling you.
She ain't say Jill bows.
Yes.
Very nice.
You know she takes like two months and she goes down to alliance and she trains.
It's a Eric,
Eric del Faro
who is one of the most unheralded guys.
Added all the top guys.
He doesn't get talked about enough.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Eric is very,
very wise when it comes to MMA knowledge.
Very wise man.
I like his corner work.
I,
I've seen videos of him coaching guys.
Oh Shit.
She puts on dancing with the stars.
She went Capo era.
She tutored a tornado kick.
My friends,
she does not want to be in the inside with Rawlings Rawlings was hitting her
with too many different things.
She was hitting her with punches up top and then knees to the body and the niece
of the body,
two or three of them look real good.
And also like her distance is real good.
Like see how she's like sliding outside of pages stuff too but constantly
pressuring her so she's making page explode forward and then she,
it's nowhere near her and then she's constantly keeping up that pace on see I
paid takes that chance,
throws that Kik would then comes up empty and she gets popped.
Popped.
Yeah.
That's not a good feeling.
That is not a good feeling.
You can see like when one person is just,
I'm starting to catch fire,
starting to find it and feel it and then you see like uh,
their skill levels play out too.
Like vanzant like super scrappy on the ground,
really tough.
But Rawlings is just a seasoned striker man.
Really Crisp.
Like,
look at those mu the movement right there.
Like though she sets up and then she doesn't like it.
She's not there.
See Ya.
Like if you hit her,
you're catching her on the end to shit.
She's sliding away from it.
Very interesting cause you're seeing like the level of skill and women's MMA
like continue to go up and up.
These girls are having fucking dog fights man.
Some of the fights we've seen
and more and more of them are developing power.
Yeah.
Ooh,
Paige vanzant with US jumping round kick to the body.
That one.
See that?
Yeah.
Okay.
That and that other spinning kick that she missed by a mile but was awesome
looking.
She's going to be on slowmo highlight reel.
What?
Someone caught that someone got shot in the truck.
Did you save that?
It's so true.
Isn't that a good shot of that?
Which is just up there spinning
like that.
Yeah.
In the middle of a fight.
It doesn't matter if we landed,
we just need a couple of just one per round.
Just give me something crazy.
But they told her to do it.
Do it.
Just do some crazy dancing with thinking about a Nike commercial or something.
Well Reebok,
I'm sorry.
Oh,
nice combination.
Right leg kick and then a right hand by page.
Okay,
Paige starting to find our rhythm man.
Maybe page,
this is,
this is a strategy.
Just go backwards for a while.
Well she so scrappy man and she's so fit and she's constantly thrown down with
bad ass dudes.
Well,
so is Beck Rawlings,
but like Paige is one of those Alpha male athletes.
So she's at a team Alpha male with Uriah Faber and Chad Mendez and Cody
Garbrandt and there's a ton of savages and Justin Buchholz who's the the trainer
there now who's one of the trainers there now.
And I think Justin is still fighting to keep,
imagine how big pages a MMA and fitness academy would be.
Good Lord.
Alpha female.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just have a bunch of bad ass bitches smacking people and that then brings him
the dude's and then that brings in the dude's and it's like a,
it's like a nightclub after awhile.
Soon as you walk in,
there's no light,
just strobe light working out to a strobe light.
Can you imagine?
No one.
Oh,
and there's mirrors everywhere and strobes going off.
Go go dancers.
A shot girl.
Maybe that's what she imagined.
That's what Bellah toward.
Does they just go,
did you go straight strip club?
What do you mean Bela Tarr.
If Bella door decided to,
oh my God.
The shows.
Yeah,
in the dark.
Yeah.
Without the fighter's got a fight with like flashing lights and competing with
them May.
It's just too hard to catch up to the UFC.
So what we're gonna do is obscure the lighting.
We're going to make it a,
everyone's going to wear neon.
You're going to be hard.
They do have to do like neon around the risks so that you know we're going to do
a special no.
Oh,
jumping roundhouse kicked in the face.
Oh Shit.
Oh my goodness.
What a kick.
Okay,
Dang God.
Out of nowhere.
Damn.
That was incredible.
And then she just fucking swarmed on.
She's a tough girl,
man.
That was a tough girl.
That's the one that's going to make the highlight.
Oh,
for sure,
dude.
She jumping in roundhouse kicked her in the face.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
That was sensational.
Maybe that was the plan to get her to come in,
get her,
just keep her coming in.
Coming in,
coming in.
Well,
it looked like,
you know,
she was having her moments,
but it looked like back Rawlings was having an advantage over her and the
striking,
didn't you agree?
Yes,
absolutely.
But look at this.
Oh,
are you kidding me?
I don't think it has one other lenders like that before.
That's not the first one is a guy here.
Rodriguez landed on Andrew feeling exactly like,
Ooh.
Yeah,
real similar.
I think it was the same leg too.
God Damn,
that was amazing.
That's a sweet DDC.
See how she was holding her scrub right here with their left hand up so she
couldn't run away?
Yes.
Look at this shit.
Oh Shit.
Oh my goodness.
Check out the end where she's punching her at the end.
How she's holding her or her hand.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Look at,
that's beautiful man.
Man.
That is beautiful.
Great.
What technique?
Very nice.
And when you're an athlete like her,
like a dancer like that,
that girl can spring.
Wow.
People are going to start doing salsa now.
Damn.
That's a tough girl.
It's crazy.
There she is.
Holy Shit.
She's a day or the never bigger than ever.
Boom.
Bam.
Well,
I mean,
come on man.
She's,
it's like 23 years old.
Shit.
25 year old professional ass kicker.
Slash.
Dancer.
Was she a dancer before?
Yeah,
they're dancing with the stars.
Here's Yoyo Rodriguez.
Damn Jamie.
Jamie's a,
you're looking at this.
There it is.
Same exact kit.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the Jackie Chan realm.
That's taekwondo.
People get mad.
I say it wrong.
That's almost like a one,
two,
right?
It's almost like a wow.
Yeah.
Well it's um,
except it's round instead of like that front snap kick.
Right.
But some Kyokushin guys,
you still like that?
It's just basically a traditional sort of a karate style.
One's ones around kick,
right.
It could be that or it could be double round kick.
You could like throw the first one just trying to touch.
You're not really trying to get all the power and it just trying to just touch
it so you could brace off of it and then switch the hips over and throw that
second one.
You see me doing a bag before you got to do a DVD of her.
You're fucking kicks to come home with a w
and then just put it away for free and just give it away for a dollar.
The only thing that I think that shouldn't be an instructional online is uh,
how to correctly throw that turning sidekick to get power in it.
There's this almost should be like an instruction on that.
You should make it.
Yeah.
Well you know,
I wish there was this guy,
I don't think,
well you kind of did that GSP kick.
I mean that helped a little was an instructional yeah.
He basically got all your points out.
It was five minutes or something,
right?
Yeah,
there could be,
you could do it the way you would teach him and GSP you would do it the way you
would teach someone.
You would break it down.
So,
cause I think like a lot of it is that people are missing,
they're missing like one aspect of it did.
They just don't.
Right.
And they
put the other stuff together and it just doesn't work correctly because of it.
And that,
that aspect is that sidekick is like getting the knee out for the regular side
kick and then extending the body.
That's where all the,
like the efficiency and the torque and the power is.
Isn't it crazy that something as simple as the turning side kick or just the
regular sidekick?
It's so simple.
Everybody knows what it is.
It's sidekick is like probably one of the most popular kicking,
kicking names,
you know,
and yet very few people on the planet and know how to throw it.
Right.
Especially like an MMA and the UFC.
How many guys throw it right?
Would you say?
Ten five.
It's hard.
It's hard to say because a lot of them don't do it when they're fighting.
It's not a common technique,
but Wonderboy does it perfect.
Really with power and everywhere.
Yeah.
I wonder what kind of power.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well wonder boy when he fights he keeps you at the very end cause he's real tall
and long.
He's got a very specific sort of style and that style is like this.
Like he's like he's got you and when you're moving in on him he's like angles
and shots.
He,
he's angles and counters.
He'll catch you with that front,
right front leg side kick.
And then if you respond to it he'll go like he's going to do to it and then hit
you in the face with a roundhouse kick instead.
He did that to Johnny Hendricks.
He front leg side kicked him in the body and like hard indeed.
You see Hendricks gets jarred just a little boom.
It was a jab,
it was a fucking,
he thrusted in there,
a powerful front leg side kick and you see Hendrix try to move forward again,
like to settle in again and boom,
he pops in with the same leg,
hits him with the front leg round kick in the face.
Yeah,
it was like boosh and then there was like a little bit of a movement and then
boom,
the round kick him.
See that you can find that.
It was like a,
when Hendrix stopped,
uh,
or excuse me,
when I'm a,
Wonderboy stopped Hendricks and he stomped him the first round,
which was insane.
You know,
you think that how fucking durable Hendricks is Hendrick's is an animal.
You could stop that guy in the first round.
That's something that's something incredibly impressive.
You know what I mean?
You think of the Hendrix that went five fucking crazy rounds with Robbie Lawler,
former Bachelorette.
Fuck is that,
oh,
it's a bachelorette.
I don't know how to show what's going on here.
Former bachelor at Vancouver Canucks to take their hockey seriously up there.
How about that?
They're allowed to punch each other.
Their sport.
They're allowed to beat the fuck out of each other.
They just dropped it.
They dropped their gloves and they go knuckle the knuckle.
It's the only time you're allowed to go knuckle to knuckle with somebody on TV.
You can't go knuckle to knuckle with anybody in the UFC fight.
They make you take your gloves.
They,
you have your hand wraps,
you put your gloves on,
you have to have gloves on.
Did you know you don't have to have hand wraps.
I want to see ultimate knockouts in hockey.
There's gotta be a highlight video here.
It is back up before this cause he does is before this.
He catches him.
I was this the,
the,
the combination and ends the fight now.
It was it,
I'm sorry it was before earlier in the round.
It was like when they were feeling each other out,
like Thompson just starts putting it to him.
Do that turn in psychic.
He threw right there with five.
Jet Does is legit.
He does everything perfect.
Is He the best striker?
Another may right now.
Maybe Michael Page is up there too.
I want to see Michael Page fight a higher caliber.
A fighter.
But that guys,
look man,
he broke cyborgs head.
Yeah.
Cyborg evangelists.
Sta who's a longtime veteran and a guy's been fighting forever.
Tough,
tough guy and venom page broke his head with a flying knee.
He's a high level striker.
We just don't know how high level,
you know,
I want to see him.
But uh,
as far as the UFC Wonderboy,
he's one of the best for sure.
But you know,
it's hard to say.
Anybody is scarier right now than rumble.
Who's scary than Rumble Johnson?
Nobody.
Grumbled.
Johnson is like,
oh,
here it is.
You got it.
Jamie found it.
No,
back it up.
That's the same exact combination.
But he did.
He land that turned inside kick right there.
Uh,
he hit him like in the chest,
but he was,
you know,
that's,
he's here.
It is.
I think he catches him with some weird stuff coming in,
man.
It's really interesting.
Like they have this little combination.
He throws that round cake out of nowhere too.
He's real good at the ending.
Those combinations with round cakes where people don't expect it.
It comes in fast.
See tags him there.
Oh Shit.
So I must've been before that.
This is the follow up.
This is the final combination.
What round did he stop him?
Stop Him in the first.
Wow.
Yeah.
We go watch the whole first round man.
Let's watch the whole first round.
See if he could find it.
He overwhelmed him.
Yeah.
This is a how it sets up.
Why is it all like weird?
Eh,
it's not supposed to be on youtube here to,
so like he also gets away with keeping his hands down like that.
Okay.
He tried that shit right there,
that jumping roundhouse kick.
He gets away with shit because of his distance and his understanding of like
space is so high level.
He's understanding of like striking space.
So God damn good.
And he was really smart.
He went right to Chris Weidman would use like I got to learn how to wrestle.
I'm just going to fucking become buddies with one of the toughest wrestlers and
MMA and I'm going to train like an animal with a guy who could beat my ass.
That's the move.
You know,
look what happened.
He's the top contender.
We'll get a say what I,
what would you recommend till UFC fighter or like a new guy on the ultimate
fighter show when you got these young guys coming in,
would you ever recommend they take a taekwondo classes?
It's not a bad thing to do,
but the problem is if you're in the middle of learning how to fight,
you might want to concentrate on,
I mean if you're going to compete,
it's almost like you might want to concentrate on those other aspects before you
really attempt it.
You hope you might want to concentrate,
you'd have to talk to like a guy who was tragically training guys and is really
aware of how much resources you actually have as far as like how hard you can
train and stuff.
You know,
because if you're training two or three times a day,
which a lot of these guys are,
you know,
you're probably already dedicated to like strength and conditioning,
Jujitsu class,
you're seeing like maybe the style that Wonderboy has,
maybe that's a glimpse of the future.
Like everybody got to get on this eventually.
So if you tell a guy who was just getting in to it,
you know what,
stick to the basic stick to Moitai or you could do that later.
He won't get into it later.
You know,
you gotta do it like yesterday.
You want to get right on it.
But here's the deal.
When someone's not good at that stuff,
it's easy to exploit.
So there's,
there's a learning curve where you have to go,
you have to cross over a certain level of expertise.
We understand striking when you understand like what errors to make and like
where to put momentum into things.
And when you're learning like certain kinds of kicks,
like they're awkward,
especially if you're not that flexible.
You're not used to it.
You haven't done it before.
You tried it in an MMA fight,
it could be a problem.
But if you're a guy like Wonderboy,
he's learned how to do it since he was a kid.
I mean Wonderboy has been doing karate with his dad since he was a kid.
Yeah.
So like he's,
he's a goddamn wizard.
I mean he was,
he had some insane record of 50 something wins and kickboxing with no losses.
You know,
he used to fight on that Chuck Norris World Combat League.
You remember that?
Didn't we go to see him live once,
man?
Yeah.
We saw it was like Atlantic city or something.
I don't remember where it was.
Where the hell was it?
I don't know.
But we went to see it.
I hugged Chuck Norris for the first time.
I've hugged him since,
but remember that,
uh,
the greatest moments in my life,
man,
it was a UFC fighter on that show.
I'm not bullshitting either.
Remember there was a UFC fighter on that show.
A black guy who fought in the UFC.
Who did,
who did that Shell as well?
He's from Texas.
I forget his name.
Damn it.
Uh,
he's a rapper too.
He's a rapper.
Fought in the UFC.
I think he got into rap after the UFC and then he followed that show.
Fuck.
I forget his name.
Dammit.
From Texas.
Shit.
See Jamie,
you'll find them.
What is it?
I didn't give him moral combat league.
Yeah,
you fucked it up.
God Damn it was his name.
That world combat league was dope.
I enjoyed it.
It's not,
you know,
um,
it's not a bad idea to,
have a,
a surface,
almost like a mini swimming pool type thing.
The way they had it,
where there's an outside edge.
There's nothing wrong with having a tournament based on just kicking,
which is,
it's going to be just the best kickers.
That's it.
We're not going to really bring in striking.
You can't strike well,
you can kick anywhere you want or
something like that or like whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like soccer,
something just to spend it with Tyco.
It's like of wrestling is just one tiny aspect of MMA.
The take down in the,
you know the base.
It's not tiny.
Let me rephrase that.
It's a big part of that in the May,
but it's just one of the big three,
the big three being striking,
a wrestling and Jujitsu.
But then there's also samba with Jujitsu and ins takedowns there's judo with
wrestling and then in striking there's Moyie,
Thai boxing,
traditional martial arts,
you know,
but it's generally the big three.
And then there's like sisters and shit.
But here's my thoughts on the taekwondo and Moy Tai thing.
I'm like,
you cannot get taekwondo off.
It's not going to work if you don't know Moitai.
That's what I believe.
I believe that most Moitai cancels taekwondo and this is from me doing taekwondo
most of my younger life and then doing Muay Thai and then seeing like the holes
in it.
Like if you don't know it,
like if you ever watched like a taekwondo guy,
there's a few of them online.
What were no guys fight Muay Thai guys took,
it will get lit up.
It's like it's like a Molly tie his leg locks and boxing is a Brazilian Jujitsu.
Boxing is very important and an inanimate very important,
but if you don't know [inaudible],
you don't know how to check kicks,
you're going to get exposed.
They're going to kick your leg.
Same thing if you know Bjj and you don't know leg locks,
I see it all the time.
If you're going,
if you're a traditional Brazilian Jujitsu guy who didn't get heavy on leg locks
and you go against a guy who's heavy on leg lots,
you could take a guy that's been doing leg locks for one year,
maybe two years,
and he just focuses on leg locks.
He see when you're really good at leg locks,
you don't have to pass the guard.
You don't have to sweep ever with pro tradition,
traditional Jujitsu,
just straight chokes and armbars.
You have to pass the guy.
That goddamn guard.
Generally if you're on top to get any close to any submissions or you've got to
sweep,
but we'd leg locks.
You don't have to do shit.
Oh,
you know,
you can go right into leg locks from anywhere.
You know?
That's the beautiful thing about leg locks.
When you add that to Jujitsu combined sambo catch wrestling and Brazilian
Jujitsu,
boom.
That right there is huge.
It's just like combining Moyie Thai and boxing.
That's fucking huge.
Combining Muay Thai and boxing.
Boxing by itself an MMA,
you're going to get your legs kicked.
Well
he does.
Do you think that it is important,
like if you were trying to develop a perfect fighter,
do you think that it's important to start out with one discipline and get really
good at it?
Like Damien Maia or do you think you should be a guy or a gal who learns
everything
from scratch?
Like it all depends.
When you start and what your,
is,
is your goal to becoming UFC champion?
You want to be the name.
How old is van Zandt and how old are you?
Ah,
that's a good question,
right?
There's no one answer,
Yeah.
If there,
if someone's,
it's a big difference
between that and you're a kid.
I would say we've talked to this,
we've talked about this before.
I would say get into break dancing and wrestling.
Uh,
Ma,
put do that together,
break dance,
can rest and get into that heart and do Jujitsu on Sundays or whatever,
you know,
submissions here,
they'll pass the car here.
But make sure you,
you're putting enough time in that wrestling and that breakdancing combining
both cause we all know wrestling translates beautiful beautifully into Jujitsu
and now we know breakdancing translates even better and to Jujitsu.
And uh,
because you know,
when you're doing break dancing,
you're doing way more crazy things and you are in wrestling.
Wrestling's nice,
simple,
basic,
stay on top,
balanced base.
Stay on top,
boom,
drive through,
stay on top.
Don't let a guide,
you know,
get on top of you poem.
You're not asking your body to do these crazy maneuvers.
I can break dancing and,
and when,
when you're used to doing,
when you're used to doing crazy shit like spinning on your head in slow motion
and shit like that,
the amount of control you have to have on your core and the strength to do all
that shit.
It's like,
it's a crazy yoga Valera touch,
but all that shit,
all that shit combined into one cause break dancing is fucking everything.
It's like,
Gee,
it's gymnastics,
it's,
it's wrestling.
It's,
it's everything.
It's yoga,
it's policies,
it's flexibility.
Anything you can put,
there's Graham bees in it,
there's rubber guard in it.
There's all sorts of shit.
Breakdancing is endless,
so it just makes sense on paper.
It makes sense that that would be the best thing to get your kids into a few,
you know,
um,
to develop the ultimate base balance core strength that will translate into
anything.
I've seen it over and over again with,
with GL and Boogie and all his guys.
And uh,
we got to shut off the break dancers.
Good.
It's for,
for sure.
It's a good base for Jujitsu.
I got another time.
The question becomes though,
like what?
How much emphasis should be put on striking?
If you're developing a guy,
you're going to take it from the beginning.
I would say,
uh,
there's a lot of time,
I would say focus on the wrestling and the breakdancing,
Anglo striking here on the side.
Just get 'em moving.
Maybe taekwondo on Saturday,
Jujitsu ons,
taekwondo,
Saturday,
Jujitsu Sunday,
Monday through Friday,
wrestling during the day,
break dancing at night,
right?
Five days a week.
Saturday,
God,
go to Mcdonald's and get a little hot fudge Sundae after taekwondo.
Do all that shit.
Boom.
And you're good.
Yeah,
man.
You know,
the only thing that I would wonder about,
I mean if you run into a guy like Wonderboy,
I'd wonder about it.
Get it.
When you look at a guy like wonder,
boy,
if you can't take that guy down,
you're kind of fucked.
Unless you're a better striker,
unless you're to wind off.
Yeah.
You have to be.
What's going to happen with him and to banal question,
it's a real good question.
[inaudible] he throws straight.
Powerful shit certainly does.
He's super fluid,
very technical.
What does angles and the way boxes his kicks are good too.
Could good leg kicks.
It's an insane sport,
man.
So there's so many guys.
Look at the one 55 division,
even just kill.
Imagine the shit talking.
Uh,
leading up to the fight,
the countdown show,
Tony Ferguson and Connor like even that,
that's another,
that's another dimension on its own.
Its own fuckings.
He will match that gives Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor almost didn't fucking
happen.
This all this shed,
this historic shit of all time and history almost didn't happen if,
if dos Anjos didn't get hurt,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
If he didn't get hurt,
we wouldn't have any of this shit.
Dude.
Imagine Tony Ferguson,
Conor Mcgregor.
Imagine Dat Shit Cause Tony,
he's going to talk shit as well and he's intelligent and
he's a full can total barbarian.
He's holy Shit Dude.
Dwayne's way to win the way he put what the,
the beating he put on Edson Barboza.
Holy Goddamn Shit.
Everybody's scared of Edson heads is one of the scariest guys in UFC history at
the scary opponent.
That's one guy who like,
you know what,
can we go around that motherfucker?
Let someone else find them.
You know?
That's what deep down everyone's thinking that.
Cause that guy,
if he lands a super fast,
crazy spinning wheel kicks it.
He lands that shit.
You might not be the same person for the rest of your life.
There might be a slight change.
He's a perfect example.
Example
of a guy who was outstanding,
Moy Tai and nasty traditional kicks has perfect example.
Do you ever see him throw a spinning back kick?
Yes.
Perfect.
Yeah.
This fucking fast as fuck.
And the wheel kick that he knocked out.
Terry Adam,
do you know that was the first wheel kit Kao ever in the history of the UFC.
Really?
That was the first one.
Edson Barboza knocking out.
Terry Edelman does the first one up and there's an animated Gif Posa going
Barboza spinning landing on Edom.
He goes down to in the background,
Ari should fear it goes like this.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Or is like,
can we see that it's see the credible.
That's incredible.
Like as the wheel kick lands,
you see Ari Freak out background.
Did someone make a special video on zoom in on him and shit and make a meme out
of it?
No.
I'm sure someone asked someone.
Someone's definitely,
I've seen it.
I've definitely seen the meme.
But um,
that technique,
like the way he throws it is perfect.
Everything he does is perfect.
His switch kick is the best switch kick I've ever seen in my life.
I've never seen anybody throw a better switch.
Kick Dude.
Anthony Pettis,
Charles,
all of that shit.
Holy God.
Who Watches?
Look in the background.
See right there.
He,
his hands go up to his head.
Is that what this video is about?
Look at this.
Boom.
Yeah,
exactly.
Watch he lands in.
Now look in the background and you watch Ari's hands come up.
Is that him right there behind me?
Watch this one more time.
Joe Silva right
here.
Silva.
Now Joe Silva's there an Arby's,
Arby's right behind him.
You can enlarge that screen.
It was really small.
I might a baker.
But what do you mean smaller?
What happened?
UFC history in MMA history.
Really,
and we're looking at Ra,
we're focusing like scientifically,
forensically an Ari.
That's funny.
Um,
but Barboza like as far as like technique,
like his zero holes in his technique.
Zero.
He's the one of the best kickers I've ever seen because he does everything he
does the traditional kicks.
He does like a lot of,
a lot of Moyie Thai techniques.
He's the first guy to ever stopped to opponents with leg kicks.
Hot Phala Olivera and um,
Mike Lulac Lulo that's right.
Nasty fucking leg.
Almost go,
go plot that.
I mean he was in danger for a little bit.
That was legit.
Gogo on him.
Well,
he went after cowboy,
remember that fight and then cowboy,
uh,
caught him with a jab and then took him down and got his back.
Barboza Barboza in cowboy.
You remember that fight was crazy ass fight.
Cow Boy.
He's on fire.
Do Cowboy Mcgregor would be fucking insane.
God,
please make it happen in fucking so,
I mean,
the biggest fight of all the shit we might have to stop fighting after that
fight.
Conor is going to have $700 billion.
When he retires,
he's going to be richer than that guy.
Nobody.
When he found,
when he buys his first fucking g five or whatever,
you don't think he's going to put that shit on Instagram every day.
What is that going to happen?
He's going to live in a castle.
Legitimate check castle.
A castle with the chair.
He needs that picture.
That needs,
that's the ultimate picture.
He needs to get that.
Look at this child Olvera closing in on pedes.
We're watching the Charles all Avera Anthony Pettis fight.
I've been looking forward to for awhile.
All Avara moved it on pedes.
He's trying to take him to the ground.
He's wrestled fucking him.
One strike that.
Do a lot of guys have done,
he's got all that taekwondo shall we were talking about.
That's true.
But Holly Vera's pretty fucking good on his feet too.
Um,
I'm interested in this because I was wondering how Oliveira would approach this
fight.
His,
his technique,
his stand up is very good man.
There's approaches.
I'm taking this guy down.
That's it seems like fuck that striking shit is good defense by Pedis though.
Good take down defense so far.
All it varies.
A good grappler man.
He submitted guys with a bunch of different shit too.
Weird chokes.
You know,
like he knows lot of Jim Miller.
I know Jim Miller.
Jim Miller minibar barred him.
Yo Shit.
That's how retarded he got someone in a calf slicer.
I think it was one of the first ever calf slicers in the UFC.
I don't know the,
the uh,
the stats on that.
I can't remember another one.
Maybe somebody out there can correct me.
I don't remember another one.
Wonder people don't believe me about tower sovereign.
I can't remember shit.
Damn.
Olivera sticking to them like glue here.
Mm.
Yeah.
He's one he beat Efrain.
Escadera would that standing rear naked?
Remember that fight?
Yeah.
There's the calf slicer.
Look at that thing.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody's ever tapped anybody with that before.
Did people call that the all of the Ark cab crank
and rightfully so.
Rightfully so.
Do it in the UFC.
If you're the first one that's yours,
that you own that money.
Yeah.
There's a lot of techniques like that.
All right.
Look it.
This Olive Harris got pedis is back.
Oh,
Shit.
Injure danger.
Oh Shit.
What is going to happen here,
my friend?
Not good to have Pettis on top of you.
Oh,
he got up in the horse.
Interesting.
Huh?
No.
Slippery,
slippery,
slippery.
Oh,
here's a little punch for your troubles.
Great Triangle defense by pet pedis right there.
Here's the question.
How much,
which all of Airlands around kick first,
how much of a toll did the weight cut take on pedes?
I mean,
he lost a lot of weight to get down to one 40 to get that balance in bay.
Very nice.
You know,
uh,
you know,
at first he strikers,
they were getting taken down pretty easily,
but they have oh shit to the bottle.
Shit to the bunny.
He's hurting bad.
Oh,
look at that.
Look at that balance.
And Base Pedis is professional with the digits,
right?
They're like,
oh them up.
Oh you can't.
Oh God,
like that.
You can't have your guard up and you've got to close that shit.
Oh,
he's got pulls out.
Oh that swap walk base.
Vera's got hard dude.
Pedis is all.
Oh,
oh look at that shit too greasy.
Look at all that shit.
The site control that they got pass.
Very nice.
Crucifix coming is pedes of black belt.
I don't know man,
cause he's looking like a black belt.
I want to say he's at least a brown belt dude.
He's looking at like a black belt because all of our is a black belt,
right?
Well Damn.
He's looking great.
It says submitted some.
Oh Shit.
Grapple grapple.
It's nice to see.
It's nice to see what high level Jujitsu guys like Charles Oliver doing in spots
like this because you're not hiding technique here.
You're going to your a game.
You're a,
what are you thinking when you're listening to this?
I was great.
That's some great shit and tried.
He got too aggressive in going for the croup.
Madec crucifix.
He gave up a z.
She gave up eyes.
Ain't no
shit.
Dude.
If he could pull this off.
Oh Wow.
What a fight.
Spect pet has got good defenses to speak of that these officers,
any tags,
all he had his back and now he's on his back again.
Oh,
kick.
Good Keck.
Damn.
This is a real fight here.
Look at this shit.
Oh fuck.
He keeps going after it,
but it's not in there.
This is to do two are they only go forward?
I don't know.
Don't know how to style.
They just go forward after each other.
Look at that.
He's got them in Delhi,
Delhi,
Hema for a second.
Oh.
She canceled.
Throw things up man.
He's constantly throwing things up at damn tennis.
Who opened?
Keeps cracking him.
Yeah Nigga that Ah yeah.
Look out for that up.
Kick me.
I gotta throw up kicks.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
if your pet is,
don't you let him stand up here.
Don't you let them stand up here.
I think a part of you says that there's no way he could knock me out here.
So kind of see of the round and if they,
if he let,
a lot of times people you'd Think,
oh,
why doesn't he let him up to fuck him up?
And that's usually the best advice.
But I,
uh,
assume that they're thinking,
okay,
if I let him up,
I'm beating him up.
He still can throw,
he may be,
he recovers and he throws a big fucking shot or knocks me out.
That happens a lot.
So there's no way he can knock me out on his back except for that upkick Weiland
I'm just stay right here.
You know what I mean?
I think that's what they're thinking.
But it could be also,
I mean that was a hard fought first round.
You let a guy stand up,
he's,
he's got four limbs where he can knock you out,
you would keep him on his back.
You just got to watch that up kick and that shit's so low percentage.
That's happened three times in history.
Yeah.
And he also knows that it's probably the end of the round has happened a few
times in the UFC.
What's the greatest upkick ever?
I say Henzel Gracie versus Ole Tech Tar off and then there's a Marilla
Bustamante on Jerry Bolander.
Oh,
that's right.
I remember that.
Which one was first or was that fabulous?
Your Gel on boat?
No,
no,
it wasn't Fabio.
It was Morella booster McGuinness.
Boom Pedis with the body kick Oliver in deep shit.
Can you find Marillo Bustamante Jerry Boland who go up kick around.
That would be awesome.
Jamie.
I don't mean to be like,
uh,
I like I own the show or anything like that,
so if I stepped over my bounds,
no worries to Joe because he's got my back.
Ooh.
On the,
unlike all the various technique,
man.
So he looks so smooth like that front kick to the body,
Olvera it looks very smooth on the feet,
man.
Very smooth.
Good rhythm.
Yeti was trying to take him down right away.
Yeah.
Well I think he wants to just show them.
You can beat him both ways.
It's taking them down again,
look at this,
spins around,
gets the back.
God Damn Petty.
No joke on course.
Look at that.
And he's going to let him out.
Now he's going to let him,
I was going to let him stand out.
He told me his timeline coaching in the corner.
They were probably saying,
you,
you going to fuck this guy up at that left kick?
Look at Bolunda right there.
Oh,
head kick.
Look at Dad.
He went over the top.
Oh,
look at that.
That's it
too.
Oh,
Olivera with a right hand.
All the Avera has got a bad swelling on the left eye.
Oh,
and he just got tagged there too,
probably from some of that.
Oh,
look at that beautiful jab pedis is targeting it.
Okay.
Oh,
he's going to let him up.
I think all of our struggling,
man,
he can't see very good out of that iron man.
He's really badly swollen up and when it,
when it starts swelling up that quick,
you gotta wonder like how bad that injury is,
how bad it is.
Man keeps coming forward.
Looking down.
What does an animal,
he's throwing heavy shit too.
Oh,
he's that fucker.
He just going forward like a Goddamn Cyborg.
Yeah.
Look at that one too.
I liked the way all of Eric Leeds with that front kick to that Chow.
He throws a lot of that left leg front kick.
It's nice.
Very Crisp.
He like really?
He fucks with you with
Polish.
Oh Shit.
Right.
Hug all of that pressure.
God Damn.
What a fight.
He's won a fight.
Beasts.
Oh.
Oh,
right hand by pennys.
Right hand by Oliveira.
Okay.
Pedis.
Got some sweet boxing man.
He's like countering beautifully.
He's taken a lot of shit,
but you know he's landing a lot of rights.
This is amazing.
Oh,
is that an elbowed?
Yeah,
you don't,
it seems like people are thriving right hand.
Oh,
but it throws elbows.
Alverez very clean with his Muay Thai man.
He does a lot of real good tactics right hand.
No,
he's not.
Oh,
right in over the top.
I don't think.
Yeah,
I forget where.
Find out were Charles Olivera trains.
Okay.
I don't think it's a Novo and y'all though.
I'm almost positive it's not.
Oh look at this.
He's,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
This is,
this is why you need to be razor sharp on the back right here.
This is your opportunity to win.
You have an opportunity to just going to just let it slip through your fingers.
Look at this man,
look at this.
No Pun intended.
Hennessy's back.
And he can just controlling them to see that bike.
Rarely good here.
You gotta be really good on the back.
You got the back.
You should take advantage of it.
What else do you need?
You've got the back,
both leg hooks.
You've gotta add fucking low.
Look at body triangle.
What else do you mean?
Is there something in capable?
What should he be doing here?
Man,
he should,
uh,
elder people.
I mean,
there's a,
there's a risk.
There's a hand fight and it's just the catered and complicated and you got to
win.
There's a battle going on.
Anthony Pettis is used in both his hands to defend his neck.
And uh,
and he's got good angle at that defense too.
So it's really difficult because even though Anthony Pettis has his back taken
the way he would defend that choke,
he,
it's like doing a pull up like this.
Very strong.
It's very,
it becomes very sophisticated.
Ooh,
he's broken through.
He's on top now.
A lot of grease,
a lot of grease.
You got to keep that,
uh,
that the body lock triangle on as as much as you can when there's too much
grease.
And by Greece I mean sweat.
I don't,
I don't mean Brevile accuses people of greasing.
No,
no,
no.
I meant sweat are damn good technique.
Oh,
nice knee to the body on the brake and a right hand by Avera.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Austin in Houston.
Tranes in Houston and I can't find the gym,
but just keep saying Houston everywhere.
Oh,
well he's,
I know he started out at some place in Brazil because they were showing it on
television.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
Right?
Didn't they have like a whole pile of,
but yeah,
I think they went to his original gym.
Oh,
pedes or the kings of the body.
Pedis is another one who was pretty flawless.
Traditional taekwondo style techniques.
Right hand.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
Oliver gets it.
Pedis taking some big deep breaths.
It's what is called a video training.
That's his jam.
Gold.
I don't know.
I think I,
that's not the video that I saw.
There was a,
in preparation for this fight,
so I'm not quite sure,
but whatever it is,
he's super well trained.
We should find out what,
what does a camp is?
Just give him a shout out.
If that was three girls rain,
if there was three rules are two or whatever you can think of.
You can make the change right now.
Not The scoring system.
Just rules in the game.
What would they be if you had all the power of this head,
the commissioner of the Nevada State Athletic Commission came to you and said,
Joe,
whatever you want,
let's fix this sport.
What are the three major things you think we trust you?
You're so knowledgeable.
You fucking her.
Amazing man.
Well,
I'm tired of getting blown here.
Said no guy,
ever,
no guy over.
Um,
what would I tell them to do?
First of all,
I don't think it needs to be fixed.
I think we could all,
um,
I think the best way.
Yeah,
the best way to find out what the best rule changes would be is to talk to all
the experts,
talk to all the most respected trainers,
the Duke Roufus is in the for Rasa hobbies in the Matt Humes and all those guys.
Talk to them and then talk to a former fighters that are really smart guys like
Brian Stan talk to guys like Dominick Cruz talked to guys who are added right
now,
like John Jones who were in their prime talk to everybody could talk to George
Saint Pierre and then get sort of an understanding of what everybody would like
to see change to what they think would be changed if they had their way.
I think that's probably the best way to do it,
to do it as a a community because I think a,
there's not going to be a total agreement on things,
but I think we can come to like some reasonable reasonable agreements if we all
just sat down and explored what would be the best options for rules for safety
lead.
Throw it up at our,
that was slick.
Yeah,
he just snapped on it.
Mm.
Let's see if he could pull it off.
But I'm talking about in a fast and in a fantasy world,
in a fantasy world,
I know you're talking about,
it's like the movement in the fantasy world.
That's what I would do.
Uh,
I would,
uh,
I would definitely,
if it was up to me,
that's what I would do.
I would put it up to,
and what would you be included?
Would you be included in that group of people?
Okay,
so,
so you,
everyone would have to vote on their top three and you put it all together and
then from there you decide,
yeah,
pat is on top again.
Tim is a great fight.
Um,
I would think number one,
much more comprehensive rule system.
Let's find out,
um,
what's fine out.
What rules make sense,
what rules are like the 12 to six elbow that's gone,
that,
that makes it illegal.
It's really from the mountain only word that comes into play,
right?
It's totally,
it's a legit technique.
And then I think you and I had a point and I think it should be discussed.
Why can't you elbow someone in the back of the head when you can kick him in the
back of the head when you can you in transitions guys get kicked.
We this.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
and he's not a black belt.
He's getting it tomorrow morning.
Oh my goodness.
He caught him with a fucking good teen and tapped him shit.
Guillotine Woo entity.
It's got some finishing power on the ground,
man.
Wow,
that's fantastic.
Look at that beautiful display right there to went over and hugged him.
Olivera kissed him on the cheek.
That's beautiful.
I don't know why that's touching to me for real.
Like,
uh,
it sounds like a bullshit thing to say.
You know,
like,
ah,
look at that.
They made friends.
How cute.
But like really it,
um,
that means a lot man.
When you see these two guys trained for each other for months at a time,
talk shit about how the fights going to go down.
Talk about,
you know,
beating each other's asses
and damn all that beautiful hold heat.
A full transition.
Look at this.
He's going for the single,
he misses it.
And the transition to the double catches a guillotine and gets that perfect over
the top.
That is nasty as fuck.
That is locked down.
He got 'em in the chat that with that grip right under the chin,
right that pill and he can't get it out and you know what?
Oh yeah,
I could follow the ride in the morning.
Yeah.
And he's pushing against it.
The fence is weird man.
I think it helps things and I think it makes it way easy to take people down.
Like there's a lot of wrestlers,
like if it,
if the fence didn't exist,
good fucking luck.
Good luck trying to take them down.
But it's,
the fence also makes it harder to take people down and in another sense where
you're leaning against the fence,
you could put all,
it's an art totally to use all your weight into the fence and just to use a
fence as a,
as in your favor when you're working on your take down the fence,
there truly is a difference between MMA,
wrestling and wrestling.
There should be a tournament would call fence wrestling where you start and you
have a guy against the fence and as soon as he gets
circle out now you switch and you go back and forth.
See who gets the most takedowns off the fence.
That would be a great skill.
Like you know how you say taekwondo is a good skill to have.
If you're like a Wonderboy and you can throw those perfect kind of kicks.
If you had a sport,
a separate sport fence wrestling,
that was just fence wrestling.
That is actually a really good idea.
That'd be for MMA.
It would prepare you better for him and that's a big difference.
Do you think with fencing,
without fence difference?
Fuck yeah.
He couldn't run away either.
So you think parents will let their kids wrestle in a cage if they had school
meets the parents?
I know.
Hell yeah.
I got parents that they want their kids to fight in the UFC more than the kids
do their down his book,
Cajun Rubber Guard show it to all that shit.
We was doing ballet.
He's doing swimming.
That's hilarious.
He's doing water polo for that explosion.
You imagine if like all wrestling meets turned into the cage wrestling meets.
I know Russell and attendance is down.
I've got good news and I've got bad news.
Good news is we got a solution to bad news is involves your little angels
wrestling in a cage.
How about you have instead of instead of a six mats out there,
like in a high school,
you have six cages out there and it's just cage wrestling.
You'd have to get six fucking cages.
Yeah,
but you can't have cages run simultaneously as you can just like a regular
wrestling tournament or just get a tournament.
There's it at the world as 12 matches going on at the same time.
You just put a little cages in each map.
No,
but doesn't it seem like,
dude,
this is a fantasy world.
Jesus Christ,
I'm not trying to fund this like,
dude,
he was $30,000 to get the cages,
clothings optional.
Who's going to bring the cages?
We got a cage.
Oils,
oils,
optional.
You guys are going to oil it or are you guys going to go dry today?
Turkish oil wrestling,
you know they have that shit,
the oil each other up.
You ever seen that dude?
They reach into each other's pants or grabbed their boulevard.
Greatest photoshops ever of all time back when Photoshop was first invented,
they took one of them Turkish oil wrestling.
Was it like they look like they're in leather pants,
topless leather pants.
It looks like a Chippendale's outfit,
but it's actually serious sports going on without wrestling and they're
completely covered in oil and you can reach part of the sport is reaching inside
the man's pants to grip around his balls.
That is part of the game.
I want to note,
there it is.
I want to know,
uh,
where the schools for this.
I'm like,
what does that,
what do the schools look like?
How do you train for this dude?
They oil each other up.
They were really tight leather pants like during Judas priest and you're going
to get each other's dicks and ball bags and they wrestle really brown.
The balls are like handles.
It's totally legal to grab balls.
Think there's any rules at all.
I just think you can't look at this.
He's got his hand,
his fucking pants,
bro.
Can You the coaching grab his Dick.
That is so insane.
Says Whoa.
You guys are all standing around.
You know there's at least one guy with watching that going,
please don't get hard.
Please don't get hard.
Not yet.
Yeah,
if you get hard,
it's bad for the game.
You can play hard and it's like,
yeah,
it was cool.
I was all over most up six points and then I got a hard on and I was trying to
think of Margaret Thatcher naked on a cold day.
It didn't work.
And you know what?
I'm not going to make any excuses.
My Dick got hardware,
whatever.
I should have jerked off.
I fucked up.
I knew I fucked up
Olympic swimming water polo.
Ken,
how come they can play beach volleyball but chickson literally in thongs and
super slow mo like,
like the championship has decided that he was winning until that dude's slipped
his hand or his pants off in slow motion.
They got so super slow motion and you could tell right here where he grabs his
dick.
You can tell by his hips.
If you see the quiver on the hips,
that's an indication of full chap low.
You want you,
when you revved up,
you want to go below the helmet line.
As long as you're below the helmet line and you've got it all depends on the
grip.
Some guys like the Monkey Grip,
the shaft right there at the base.
You do it all depends on size of his penis,
but you want a among,
you can monkey grip it.
You got all these cribs.
Can imagine the interview.
You know I had to wait two weeks of training.
It was last minute.
My,
my tick was not in good shape.
Jerked off in two weeks this time to like do things your dick to toughen it up.
I've been,
you know this,
this time I had a tall,
a full camp to prepare,
been jerking off three times a day.
So this time it can be a little different and I'm going to come with my head
game.
My Dick is he gained,
hey,
game strong dude.
We seen the Kakapo fucking checking the oil.
You know what I mean?
You know they could,
that's illegal.
You could grab the tick and the balls but you can't,
you can't check out.
You can't stick your thumb in the rules on checking the oil because guys have
gotten like in trouble for that.
Like didn't guys get arrested for um,
for assault,
for checking some kids oil.
Didn't some two dudes wrestling and one kid check the kids oil and he got
arrested for assault.
I'm pretty sure that really happened or I drink,
you need to explain or checking the oil and gas.
I do.
Checking your oil means when you are grappling with a gentleman and you are
behind him,
you shoved with your fingers inside his bum hole in wrestling.
We're not sure if that's or not,
but they do it.
They do it all the time.
This is a really radical,
it's a woman and she's like going full Tarzan on this girl's asshole and she's
not even flinching.
Look at that.
She's like,
bitch,
this is not the,
she likes it.
Um,
I think,
uh,
the woman on top is definitely doing something questionable.
Uh,
who am to judge legal though in Turkish oil.
I want to know the rules of Turkish.
Can someone
who kills someone,
someone tweet me please.
If you could find the rules to Turkish oil,
Chippendale's,
wrestling.
I'm curious.
Yeah.
Right.
What a great sport.
So how come they can't have that in the Olympics,
but they can have that women's volleyball bullshit.
It's a sexist,
total sexism.
It's all we need.
This is what we need.
We need one flamboyantly gay star who wants to compete and they won't let him
in.
And it becomes like a global worldwide cause where people,
uh,
you know,
they'd demand diversity and um,
what are the quality
it would have?
It's shooting to be gay.
So they got a lie.
They're saying they're straight friends,
girlfriends.
It's been proven that when you wrestle a gay man and he starts to,
when your testosterone drops significantly.
Yes.
It's been proven in science,
in the labs.
So it's almost like cheating because it's like anti steroids.
Cause when you getting whooped on by gay dude,
you start getting so meek.
It's like the nature's preparing you to be as bitch.
Yeah.
And there's no one true and there's no way you could.
Okay.
Guy Can even be,
he looked at me like it's real question.
What does this,
Jamie,
are these the rules?
wrestling.com and check out number three.
These are alternatives.
Can you read that Joe,
for the audience?
This is very bizarre.
It says,
uh,
the crush of fighter may maneuver his opponent onto his stomach.
What?
Jamie,
can you make that bigger and then trap himself?
Why is it all so blurry?
It's not that blurry spa.
You get your glasses.
I don't have,
I don't even have my glasses on and I could read that.
I'm shocked myself.
You can keep him down.
Well,
what are the,
what are the rules against it?
Submission.
Occasionally the match under a hot summer sun so long and arduous that one
fightable simply signal his submission to the referee and it's a pin.
Since the wrestlers not restricted from placing his hands inside his opponents
kiss bit,
he may not grab his balls or invade his rectum.
However,
however he may yacht grab his balls or invade his rectum,
however he can.
Oh,
he can also use to waistband band over the other man to get to,
to hold the other man in place.
Okay,
so you can't grab their balls in there and Dick in their ass hole right there.
If you lose your trunks,
you lose the match.
Oh,
if a guy takes her pants off,
dude,
can you imagine?
It's even worse than not on and grab the balls.
It's even worse because the cheaters,
dude,
the cheaters in the sport are always going to be the guys.
And how are you going to prove it?
There must be a guy in the sport,
the worst cheater ever.
There's got to be,
listen,
listen to the actual rule.
Occasionally the Kismet is yanked.
So the carpet,
what is the thing that he wears?
Leather
restup pass is dropped so far below his hips that the fighter being held cannot
rise without exposing himself,
having lost his trunks.
He also loses the match.
Oh,
you could pull down the trunks,
you lose the match.
Maybe this is like,
you're always like,
you could reach inside but you can't touch the asshole or the Dick and I'm sure
no one breaks that rule ever,
ever,
ever.
It's better that they're there,
but they're not allowed to pulls your pants off.
He wins.
Can you imagine the discussions?
A podcast,
there must be podcasts about this sport,
like dudes that are seriously into it and they're talking about like,
you know,
we're talking about like no need a down opponent,
all that.
They're talking about that the elephant in the room is the fact that everyone's
sticking fingers and everyone's an asshole and everyone's grabbing balls.
But no one's complaining because everyone just does it.
And so there's no complaints like in football,
like the defensive cornerback when there,
there's a receiver going out,
you're not supposed to hit him outside of five yards,
but they're hitting him all the time and running into them.
And when they throw passes,
they're all over.
Right.
So they're like,
and they call it sometimes and sometimes they don't.
And there's a,
there's big controversy,
you know,
like,
there's a panist pass interference,
but no one's calling it.
It's a weird thing.
They call it every now and then when it's,
when it's playing,
when it's really obvious.
So there must be like tips of fingers going into the rectum,
but they don't call that,
they never call the tips and it's got to be full knuckle deep to call it.
And that's a problem line.
You have to cross 10 like a finger line.
Nobody puts the tip in.
Tip is fine,
dude,
there's,
there's gotta be world championships.
I want to see like a super fight,
like the baddest dudes and do like a countdown show on these guys and how they
train.
I don't want to see that.
I would watch that shit.
Well,
don't,
there's one thing that you have to think about when you do like,
yeah,
it's a little weird that the grab each other and the pants and it's a little
weird.
They're covered in oil,
but you gotta be,
you must have to be really fucking good at wrestling to control a dude is
greased up.
We need to get the best motherfucker and that sport and bring them over to the
UFC and see what's up.
How good do you think they are?
I mean,
are there any real legit like oil wrestler athletes who people like this guy is
like the bad motherfucker of oil restaurant is like,
who's that guy?
Who's those?
He's got soccer gasoline,
the messy.
He's the Rinaldo.
Who's the,
who's the [inaudible]?
What is his name was Leah and I,
what is it?
Just Leo Messi.
Leo Messi.
That Leo Messi Guy who's the baddest motherfucker in soccer.
If there's one of those dudes for oil restaurant,
he's just just raining down.
There's got to be,
who is the Hixon Gracie of all Turkish oil,
uh,
wrestling.
Well,
Turkish people are tough people.
You know.
It's a tough part of the world.
So you've got to think it's a long heritage of having like fighting from Turkey.
They're like known for being like,
like rugged people.
So you gotta think if they know how to like,
like that style of wrestling that they do.
I wonder if it's just one of those things where it's just you invented something
I'll long fucking time ago and it never sort of like caught up.
I want to know who the Ronda Rousey of hot oil,
Turkish wrestling is.
I'd watch that right now.
I paid 49 99 paper view for that shit.
The male Turkish lot oil wrestling.
That'd be insane.
It's gotta be a little,
there's gotta be girls doing it.
There's a market there.
Probably ugliest.
They don't have to be,
I'd probably be like,
no,
no.
They don't have to be man.
Oh you just need this one.
So right promoter commencement ship.
Just picking because I think the object of the game is to get that hip lock and
get some kind of ball and socket in between their legs right next to their nuts
and lift him up.
And I think if you lift them up for yeah,
for sure you can't.
Um,
there's gotta be a Joanna how judge a chick a of that sport.
You can't take a dude's pants off if he's beating your ass.
Right.
So maybe that's like your pants off.
He's Kinda got,
yeah.
Do you think you could flip a million?
Maybe it's like,
uh,
maybe it's like a,
like an ENT,
like in case there's a war against the gays,
like whoever gets a pants taken down first,
I don't know.
I'm just speculating.
It could be,
hey,
you know what?
Whoever wins,
whoever is the baddest motherfucker at that sport,
right?
They have no fear of getting a gang raped by sure.
Vicious gay dudes especially cause there's just,
you never get that oil off the street gang of gay Jujitsu,
black belt.
We can imagine that.
And they taught,
they teach Jujitsu to have sex with men.
Okay.
What would be scarier that or
go to [inaudible] in West Hollywood.
That was of Greece,
dup,
Melvin man.
Hoofs greased up with good takedown defense.
Ooh.
Completely greased up in West Hollywood.
Where ever he wants to go.
He'll go wherever the fuck he want.
One dude or a bunch of dudes,
seven of them.
They look just like Melvin man.
They're looking for dudes to Caltrain man have clones.
Yeah.
That's where he scaring the Mexican gang bangers.
I'll make a beeline for east la any time this got to east La.
Fuck that.
Greasy rest live is one thing,
but greasy Melvin Manhoef throwing bombs on you.
Yes.
I didn't want any once your juicy,
precious the rectum,
that's their goal.
They got big patches of rectums on their,
their their denim jackets and you can't keep him off you.
Yeah.
He was one of those guys where I met him at the UFC like as a kickboxing fan.
I was.
I was giddy man.
I come up to him and shake his hand.
It was good too.
I'm a huge
fan.
I'm a huge fan.
Isn't it weird that he never got into the UFC?
That's strange.
Well,
it got to the strike force and Robbie Lawler had that ridiculously insane Kale
of him.
You remember that Robby Lawler there isn't that condit fight.
Um,
but Melvin Manhoef highlight reel is ridiculous.
Kickboxing and MMA highlight reel.
The hardest one to watch for me with a soccer raba.
Remember that one?
What happened?
He beat the shit out of soccer,
Robert.
It was soccer,
but late in his career and soccer,
I have a loss.
I was a horrible law.
It was soccer kicks,
soccer kicks and hammer fist.
They take soccer kicks out of one FC.
Didn't you hear about that day?
When was this?
They changed it.
They took it out.
When did they do this?
Unless it's some hoax.
But I think I read that,
that one of,
see the thing that separated them from the UFC,
like at least in one fc was kind of pride ish.
But they had that weird rule where they had to call it.
I,
you know,
I feel like Tate had this point first and uh,
I've,
I've never heard anybody accurately refuted that the problem with stomps and
soccer kicks in a ring
or in a cage rather,
is that you can't get out away from them like you do in a ring.
Like the cage becomes a problem.
Like you get trapped,
you get caught in a couple spots in the ring,
but you should be able to move your head out of the way enough to compensate for
wherever the ring the ring posts are.
Look.
But the idea of getting stuck in the cage,
we can't move.
And then getting need to that where the,
the environment becomes too big of a factor.
And I thought about what he said and I said,
that makes a lot of sense.
A skull could crush,
could be just squashed thinking about like what Michael Page did to Cyborg and
think of someone doing that to someone's face in the UFC,
which again,
when the faith see someone's face caved in and what if they cheat?
What if someone cheats in the heat of the battle?
Maybe don't even realize they did it,
but they grabbed that fence and it helps them drive that knee down.
You know that's happened before.
If you could,
if you got a guy who was almost unconscious and he's on his way out and you grab
the fence and you some mash your knee down with all your body,
you get your hips up in the air.
Like George Saint Pierre when he fought Matt Serra and the rematch and Montreal,
remember that those knees to the body from side control,
just go deep with those knees.
Boom.
If a guy does that to a guy on the ground and he's actually holding the fence,
that's,
that's a terrible place to be as a terror.
There's like nowhere to go.
It's like everything's just getting absorbed.
It's the worst way ever to get hit.
It's almost like,
uh,
an argument for not having a cage.
I've said this before and people think I'm an idiot and it probably right some
of the time,
but I think that MMA should be in like basketball size place.
Like you know,
you have a basketball court and you're watching the game.
I really think MMA should be a flat,
padded area with no fence and they should go at it and a large area.
So there's plenty of room to move around.
There's no excuse to go into the crowd like that.
That's how they should do it.
So take downs,
defense submissions,
there's no getting off the fence and pushing off of it and flipping over and
getting out of positions.
Everything will take place on a flat neutral ground.
And I think you're going to find a lot of fucking people going to have a real
hard time with wrestlers.
Real hard time with wrestlers like real elite wrestlers when they keep driving
forward and you can only go back so much,
you know there's no cage anymore.
You can't push off the cage.
How bout this again,
this is all fantasy.
How about somebody,
maybe you maybe someone else with a um,
the could financially but to put it together but go to some God damn Indian
reservation when you could do anything you want put together,
show,
put together a show,
one show.
It doesn't have to be elite fighters.
You don't put that much put together show.
You got to show them how it's done because one thing I learned with Ebi is when
I was presenting the overtime rules and all that to everybody,
nobody even thought it was cool for a second.
I talked to them.
Explain Ebi for people to know what we're talking about.
Ebi Is Eddie Bravo.
Invitationals.
Eddie Bravo's probably got the greatest Jujitsu tournament in the world as far
as professional Jujitsu because of these rules that you implemented.
September 11th is our next show.
Gordon Ryan,
September 11th on UFC fight pass or you could see it live at the,
at the Orpheum.
Get your tickets@ebiofficial.com but anyways Donaher just send me a text that
Keenan,
Cornelius and Ryan Gordon went 90 minutes and Ryan Gordon submitted him with a
heel off.
He's been doing Jujitsu like four and a half years going Ryan.
Yes,
I think it's about five something.
Something Riddick say.
It's say yes.
Get Gordon Ryan.
It's crazy.
Gordon Ryan,
he won the absolutely.
He could be the best Jujitsu fighter pound for pound in the world right now.
That could be one.
The absolute,
he beat Uri Sibos.
Uh,
he beat 'em,
uh,
rust them chizzy of who's a fucking Russian assassin.
That guys of gorilla,
literally a gorilla is crazy.
Yes.
In the finals,
the kid,
the kid has been trained in five years.
The whiz kid,
Gordon Ryan versus the Russian bear,
Russian bear taking it out.
Everybody on one side,
Gordon,
Ryan,
the kid taken out,
everybody on this side and then they met in the finals and Ebi six.
Well,
the next show,
Ebi Seven Gordon Ryan is going,
we're doing the one 85.
That was absolute.
This is the middleweight Gorn Ryan.
That's his true wait one 85.
And um,
but anyways,
enough with that show,
uh,
the rules though,
when I presented the overtime rules,
I have special overtime rules that are based on submission and not based on take
downs.
Uh,
it's all about the submission at Ebi.
But when I first pres presented that like two different promoters,
nobody wanted to hear it.
No,
they didn't even entertain it.
They thought it was too crazy.
But now that we put together seven shows,
now the show people are going,
oh shit,
it's legit.
So everyone jumped on board and people agree that it's the best way to do
tournaments.
It really is because it forces action.
You can't stall.
You're starting out in a bad position at the end when you go into,
when you go into the overtime,
um,
the fights about start and I don't want to interrupt this fight,
this fight we'll talk about,
we'll talk about Dbi afterwards.
We'll hold please Carlos Condon.
When he came out the Maya shed,
I have no fuck and I god Damn Dia.
For me it's all about whether Damien Maia this Duh,
but it's all about whether or not Damien Maia,
I can get ahold of him if Damien Maia and get ahold of him.
He's so big at one 70.
Dude.
He's so strong in his Jujitsu.
He's so good.
His Jujitsu,
so pretty.
When he choked out,
Neil Magni,
I remember watching his transition.
I'm like,
this guy is a fucking master.
He's a master.
But he's the way he's getting the back.
Like,
remember when he choked out Rick Story?
He just cleans to him like glue,
drags them in the deep water and sink their boat like that.
Yeah,
he keeps getting better with his Jujitsu.
It.
Uh,
do you see what dot Donna her wrote about on this week?
Yeah,
I'll accurate.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
I'm in lab,
probably has in the UFC.
He's probably the best Jujitsu player.
He has the best MMA,
Jujitsu,
totally different MMA digit two and a Nogi.
Jujitsu is just as different as Nogi Jiu Jitsu and gauge Jujitsu.
It's just as different.
It's so different when someone is trying to punch you an elbow,
Lou and everything's all greasy and slippery and slidey.
It's so different.
If you think that's the same as training and the gay,
you're just a man.
You're a,
I don't know what,
what to say.
Maybe you're just misinformed.
But Damian Maia has made that transition,
not it,
you know,
right away.
He was really good at MMA,
Jujitsu right away.
He was doing some half guard,
that stuff and,
and the UFC,
that was very,
very effective back in the day,
years and years ago.
But even as good as he was,
he was one of the top guys to make the transition.
Initially even as good as he was,
he continued to evolve.
And as Jujitsu now is better than ever on the ground.
But that being said,
Carlos condit is very good on the ground.
Even a Damien Maia does take him down.
He might not be able to pass Carlos Condit his card.
He might not be able to pass it.
The big dangers in the standup because Carlos throw some nasty elbows and you
gotta think he stopped Tiago Alvarez recently looked real good and that fight
stopped him with that stepping in elbow.
He's nasty dude.
Very dangerous striker.
So Damien Maia has got to close that distance.
I think Damien Maia at one 70 is a different beast.
He's so God damn big.
And his striking has got himself to a point where he's not trying to be a
striker but he's good enough.
It's tracking that is distance is good.
See right there.
His comfort level and his distance are very high.
So because of that and he's not taking any big chances.
He's really just kinda like,
yeah,
that's what he's doing.
Right.
They're closing that distance like a fucking
cat.
Look at that dragon conduct to the ground.
Let's see what he does here though and he's been able to do this to everybody.
He fights Matt Brown who is a beast on the ground.
He did it to him.
He crushed Neil Magni this way.
He's a totally different animal when it comes to like his level of pressure and
Jujitsu.
He's on another planet mean and he is really better at 38 then he's ever been
before including with is like submissions in his transitions striking you said
like not just as distance but he could,
he could get in there and take some fire,
take some shots and it's no big deal.
That pass beautiful.
But he's not trying to,
so far so good.
Now he's in top half.
He Palsy.
That's a 50 yard pass right there.
He got into top half.
He's not totally passed,
but this is,
look at this as three quarter mount.
He's,
he's,
he's in the third now.
He's got the whole perfect position there to get the back.
God,
he's so good that the understanding of top half right there,
that that position as opposed to just regular half guard man.
When you really understand how important mastering that position is,
that's why he's where he's at right now.
He had just just have top how he's doing it.
He's going forward right here.
He's going for right here.
It's done.
He's got a condo.
He's done.
He's going to choke them out right over his face.
Man.
He's already asleep.
He's out.
Wow.
Damn.
Holy Shit.
Goddamn Carlos Condit.
He went right through them like Marcello Garcia would have to Damien Maia is
something special.
He's special.
Holy Shit.
A Jujitsu is on a completely different level.
That's some Hixon Gracie shit right there.
That's what we always wanted to see from Hixson.
I think I've finally,
after all these years,
he's so adjusted.
He made the transition 100% from the gay to MMA,
Jujitsu,
MMA.
He understands that.
The key was we took a bit by bit,
bit by bit.
He takes him down and he's in his guard.
He's in his guard right here.
You know he's in his regular guard right here.
There's no top half yet,
but all he was fighting for here.
What's top half?
They aren't,
they're not showing it here.
All that in between shit that made this possible.
So just listen to it,
keeps tightening it up and once he's,
he knows he's good at school and he's developed,
he's developed that world class Marcello squeeze right there.
That takes time to God.
But when I say barely there while he's tapping,
but the way he got his back was all based on his knowledge of that top half
position.
It was all based on that because he didn't try to pass all at once he passed
halfway,
his leg was still stuck and then he never passed.
Totally.
He never passed the fucking guard.
He went from top half and he realized that if you've got a good top hat
position,
you could turn while you're facing the,
it can be.
It gives up his back.
Well,
he did,
right?
Well,
yes.
Well exactly.
But he never passed his guard in the sense where he was in regular half guard or
get the little shield and that he fought for that inside position,
top half and then from top half as long as that leg that's caught as long as the
knees free,
you don't even have to pass the guard.
You dry the down.
Now you're in the three quarter amount and once you're in three quarter mount in
MMA,
it wouldn't happen as easily in in grappling without punches,
but when he's in three quarter amount,
as soon as you start punching,
he turns to his back.
You never pass the guard.
You never got inside control.
You went from top half to three quarter mount to the back.
That's what the punches do so that that pathway becomes so important.
MMA,
Jujitsu guys,
that is so huge to understand that.
Let me ask you this because we've talked about this before.
If they did make the back of the head legal like they used to in the old days,
like when Henzel Gracie fought that guy,
Ben strikers,
remember that you thought that judo guy took his bass and just blast them with
elbows to the back of the head.
Early battle cage shows where John Lewis would get a guy's back.
He would just,
he would just put his leg hooks and the guy would be in like in a turtle
position.
He did got his legs and rear naked choke.
I remember saying telling people before they banned those strikes to the back of
the head.
I remember saying rear naked choke are so not important.
All the,
what's important is getting the back control,
putting your leg hooks and getting good at writing and not get slipping up and
just throwing fucking elbows.
Rear naked choke is,
is like if you want to be nice to the guy,
you don't even need it.
It's totally optional.
The the game is getting a guy's back and battering him with your elbows in the
back of the head.
That's how fights were ending instantly,
instantly.
If those back of the elbow strikes were legal today,
man,
UFC so it'd be a lot shorter.
They would be bringing in them prelims,
they would have fucking 17 prelims,
you know what I'm saying?
Because if you factor in all the time someone had someone's back and the fight
didn't end because they weren't allowed to strike,
there'd be short ass fights everywhere.
It's true because like I guess like medically it's really dangerous I guess.
Isn't that kick to the back of the head?
The same thing.
No one's jumping up and down to that,
but also like how much more dangerous is it then getting your eye socket blown
in.
Exactly.
Saw in that Barboza fight or that um,
Pettis fight with Charles Olivera.
God Damn Damn Maya's,
but you know what I'm saying?
This is what we always wanted from Hixson.
Yeah.
We wanted a guy who could do like the kind of Jujitsu that we knew existed out
there in the world.
We wanted to see it in MMA.
Whereas the MMA Jujitsu,
you'd see like great flashes.
Occasionally you get a guy like a chocolate ray or someone who is like real high
levels fighting in MMA.
But the highest level expression of it is this guy right now in MMA.
I mean,
who the fuck has got like tighter,
better,
more worldclass,
Jujitsu and MMA right now than Damien Maia.
It's,
it's hard to argue her rise right up though.
He's right up.
Shocker.
Right.
Could do that.
Yeah.
So could hodge her.
Right.
I mean,
isn't Jack Right?
One seven years.
The one 85.
He's one 85.
Okay,
so that's a different way class.
Yeah,
but you know,
that level is just so,
it's so intense and so extreme.
It was a lawsuit for Damon MCAS in the beginning.
He,
uh,
he knew he came from a solid,
you get to background was a world champion.
I think it was in Abu Dhabi.
He was a elite,
uh,
do Jitsu player who got into MMA and right away,
like most Jujitsu guys and most wrestlers,
they get into MMA there thinking,
fuck,
the worst nightmare is getting taken out in a stretcher.
Bye.
[inaudible] like a head kicked.
That's the worst slammer.
So let me take care of my striking.
They get involved in a striking,
and Damien Maia,
he got his foot to work together fairly soon and he,
he was like up there with,
uh,
when he's fighting with Anderson Silva,
you know,
but he obviously wasn't complete as a striker,
but you can tell he made a lot of improvements,
but he was still at,
not a lot of work to do.
Now what is it?
Seven years later he stuck with it.
He didn't quit.
He stuck with it.
A lot of guys,
you know,
and,
and I'm not knocking them.
I understand a lot of guides.
How did you get to guys?
They peep into MMA.
They fuck with it for a year or two,
three and then like there's way too much.
I got to walk through too much fire to get where Damien Maia is.
So it's a lot of top Jiu Jitsu guys would dip in and they'll go,
you know what,
this is,
what do I need to do all this shit for?
I'm already known as a digital guy.
I'm just going to teach Jujitsu.
Fuck this MMA shit with Damien Maia did is what only a handful of these world
class you get to play as you're doing.
They're gonna fucking walking through the fire that keep going and keep going.
They just fucking don't quit and eventually they become legit strikers.
Like they got eight years of striking 10 years of striking under their belt.
You're a legit striker now you're not just a BJJ world champion.
Very few stick it out,
Damian,
my stuck it out and now man,
he's got to the point now it's all,
it's almost like based on his model,
it's almost like you take a worldclass Jujitsu player and you're taking me wants
to do,
I'm a mania asks you,
what do you think you'd say,
dude,
if you could hang in there for eight solid years,
no matter how many times you lose,
you just keep going forward.
No,
that you're going to get shut off a couple of times.
Try to eliminate that as much as possible and just keep going.
No matter what happens.
Just get to the eight year mark and as long as you spent those last eight years,
B always remaining a student.
Always learning,
training your motherfucking ass off in all aspects of the fighting game.
Remaining open minded.
I constantly adding weapons right down to the weapon.
If you as long,
no matter what happens,
win or lose,
as long as you're in the mix at the round,
the eight,
nine,
10 year mark,
you're going to be fucking Damian.
You're going to be in that Damien Maia realm right there.
He figured it out.
He kept going and now we're talking about Damon minds like that.
One of the scariest guys out there.
We weren't doing that as much four or five years ago.
He stuck it out.
He wasn't worried about the wins and losses.
He just kept his down,
kept grinding bull and look what happened.
He also completed
well,
he devoted himself to fighting Jujitsu.
Like you didn't try to be a kickboxer anymore,
just trying to enforce it.
Jujitsu on guys.
He,
he did have that phase where he was trying to but a,
but if you look at it as a learning,
that was a perfect thing for him to do and they're like,
maybe like maybe in 200 years we're going to look back and based on all these
guys like Damien Meyer,
we're going to go,
okay,
we need three or four fights where you just stand no matter what.
You're just standing.
You have to know that you could stand in there if you had to.
We we got to go to,
you can't be trying to take a guy down every God damn fight.
You got to walk through the fire winner lose.
You're going to get caught.
Hopefully you don't get caught.
Hopefully you'd end up being one of those guys that crushes.
People were like,
oh shit,
stay stand.
But you got to walk through that.
There's an win or lose.
You got to walk through that.
You got to stand with everybody.
You can't be afraid and you got to have,
I think that's what Georgia Gel was going to cause.
Georgia's hell was one of those guys who's a Jujitsu black belt.
He comes in and he fucking doesn't want to go to the ground and he's out there
in the cage fucking thrown down in these epic wars.
He wants some,
he lost some.
But you know what?
One thing about Georgia Shell is he,
he's just a fucking furious.
He was just,
he didn't give a shit.
He had a black belt in Jujitsu and was willing to stand with anybody.
Some people think that wasn't the best decision.
So,
but he had good kickboxing too though,
regardless wasn't standing because he wasn't good at Georgia jail is one of
those guys,
I think if he would've just kept going at this point,
you imagine if he would've just kept going,
Georgia's,
oh,
could have been like a Damien Maia.
He could've been just like that.
But you got to have a man the,
you've got to have the vision to see that shit.
Cause a lot of guys,
it's way too much goddamn work.
Brain damage.
And I got to kick box fuck kit,
but I want to get knocked.
I got shot.
Maybe there's been Brazilian Jiu Jitsu world champions that have tried to do MMA
and do the first five fights or like three shut offs and they're just getting
crushed.
I don't want to name any names.
That's a good reason to just say,
you know what,
let me stick with Jujitsu.
You know what I mean?
There's some all time greats.
Yeah.
You,
you know,
the small time grades who got into Jew from Jujitsu and got an MMA only had one
or two fights.
So it was like,
we were like,
fuck yeah.
And,
and you know what?
I don't blame them.
I mean,
there's really good look at me.
I never fucking did.
MMM.
I,
I was like,
what we were talking about
came to,
we were talking about women's volleyball.
Like it's weird what sports become a hexagon.
It's weird what sports become,
uh,
like a sport where you can make money and which ones don't,
you know,
like it would be wonderful if just submission grappling by itself,
became a sport where there was a real obvious transition between like amateur
level to like be in a professional,
you know?
Well,
again,
I may like getting a demo or Matt or it had been even wrestling.
Wrestling.
How is it that golf is like this super gigantic,
oh,
sports.
The media.
I understand people enjoy it.
Don't get me wrong.
Who controls,
I'm not
kidding.
I'm not a distinct golf.
I know people love that shit,
but how is that a professional sport but not wrestling like actual wrestling?
Like can you watch like how difficult it is for actual wrestling?
Didn't,
sorry,
it didn't make it didn't make it.
What about basketball?
Basketball made it.
Basketball guys have mansions and they live in,
but we're both in the Olympics.
Yeah.
But um,
nobody wants to see you.
You're only here because we're nice to you.
I bet if someone got behind Z,
right.
I bet if someone got behind female wrestling,
I bet.
Well,
they tried it for a while.
They had an actual wrestling event with wrestling rules.
You remember that?
It was a professional,
I think they called it real pro wrestling or something like that,
but it was actual,
goddammit,
see if you can find out.
It was fairly recently,
like within the last decade or so.
That's the problem with,
with wrestling.
I see crossing over to the mainstream is the glaring problems in wrestling when
transitioning and the May in wrestling,
it's totally okay to give your back.
It's like you give your back to win fights and to prevent losses.
You give your backs up when you see that and you see two guys wrestling and the
guys flat on his back or flat on his face and then the guy's on his back.
We know too,
we've seen too many UFC is too.
We just know that is not right.
But I think if they made,
uh,
like a hybrid of wrestling and judo,
you could call it Gnocchi Judah because,
um,
although wrestling is closer to MMA because it's no gay,
you know,
and there's no grabbing clothes and shit that's closer,
but you aren't given the back.
So that's fucked up in judo.
Yes.
It's further away from Mna in the sense that there's a g and a plan tug of war
with the callers and the sleeves and all that.
But when they get a takedown in judo,
they're allowed like 30 seconds on the ground to go for submissions.
So some guys get really good at arm bars.
You don't have to,
it's like extra.
If you do judo and you never work on arm bars,
you're fine.
The most important thing is that front line.
What's going to happen in that front line?
The in judo submissions are like gravy.
You could be good at some guys or get really good at Amr,
like Shinya Aoki for instance in judo and when he wrestled a nationally in
Japan,
he was known as not as the takedown guy.
All of those take downs are really good obviously because he's a black belt in
judo,
but he was known for flying armbars in judo.
Totally unnecessary.
That's the rule in judo.
Like how,
how quickly do you have to go to a submission once you're scrambling on the
ground?
I don't know it specifically or technically,
all I know is they give you time for submissions than they allow submissions and
in wrestling they don't.
But if you combined for the sake of MMA for the sake of creating the ultimate
takedown system geared directly for him and me,
I think you would have to go with a no guid judo style.
Like it's part wrestling part Judah.
Like you take the rules with oil,
those pants yet and we got the sport and you allow grabbing of the shaft because
that's more realistic.
You know what in the fuck is this Jamie?
What are you showing us?
What are you showing us sites are over on Fox.
They price which over overdose
animal video.
Just put up,
what is this like?
Oh it's a ferret or something running around this lawn.
It picked up an egg,
right?
Take a quick best.
Yeah,
go ahead.
I was like,
what is Jamie showing me?
Is this like breaking news?
There's a date that gets Zika virus written ferret.
I was thinking when you're talking about the high paid athletes,
they weren't,
oh had they haven't always been high paid though.
It wasn't like,
it's a good question.
I mean it's a good point there.
Last 30 years there's been big revenue sharing.
I don't know when sports became huge though.
I know the Yankees were huge back in the day.
You know the the old time days,
TV money I think is where a lot of it came from.
Right.
When did,
when did football become like the biggest thing in the world was in the fifties
that's when it really hurts.
Bloom started in the 50s he's not amazing like 50 years ago.
That's amazing that the super bowl is only that.
I mean we would just say 50 years I think.
Think 51 or 50 that's incredible.
55 they're not,
they're not that deep into it.
That's really incredible when you think about it cause it seems like inexorable,
it seemed like he couldn't pull it out of America.
Like if you tried to pull football out of America,
people were like you are in even Mercan it's only been around for like a
fraction of American baseball is dying,
but it's making just as much money as it ever has.
But the problem would flip ball is now we know if Fox your head up,
and I'm sure the case is the same or similar with MMA and I'm sure it's the same
or similar with a lot of different high impact combat sports,
boxing,
kickboxing.
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to do it,
but the,
the fact that that's our number one sport.
It's a sport.
We know you're getting lit up all the time.
Bong dudes or crash into each other.
Bong.
Last time we talked about this,
some people will send us some videos of like people playing football.
Hi.
Looked like high level football without pads.
Yeah.
Cuts going on now,
right?
Yeah.
You can drink,
you will allow him to dress.
He could drink.
Um,
so yeah,
that's interesting man.
Because I wonder like at what point in time they say,
look,
it is,
you know,
it is just a fact of the game.
People are going to get hurt.
Let's just accept the fact.
Thank you.
Sure.
Don't want to watch it.
Yeah.
Let's just accept the fact and uh,
these gentlemen should get paid a significant amount of money.
You know?
I mean,
I guess,
I mean it's just the revenue sharing theirs.
I just look something up real quick.
Just really quick.
Baseball,
MLB and NFL both are getting over over $3 billion a year that they're sharing
with their players.
Who knows how much it is in fighting,
but,
well,
baseball's totally different,
right?
Because baseball,
you're not getting hurt.
Like the football thing is a total,
I mean you obviously have the potential to get hurt.
You definitely get hit by a pitch.
When I was a kid,
man,
that was that.
Uh,
what's his name?
Tony.
See that guy that died,
he got hit by a pitch,
I believe was a,
I'm a Boston red sox player and he got hit with a pitch and got really badly,
badly hurt by the pitch.
Tony Conigliaro.
Is that it clinically Ari or oh or,
oh yeah.
That was a big thing when I was a kid.
Like I remember thinking,
Whoa,
you could,
you can get that fucked up by a pitch that you're never the same again,
guys getting hit by fast balls.
It was no joke.
And you have to think what kind of helmets did they have at the beginning and
they have no helmets at all.
You know,
what kind of helmets did they have in baseball?
Like a regular,
uh,
like they're almost like football helmets now.
They do.
But when did they come up with those?
Not until they made little league baseball players wear them all the time.
But uh,
I don't,
I guess they always made professionals wear helmets.
I got a pizza.
You guys talked this up?
No,
because then like hockey,
there's not,
there was a,
when I was younger there were players that didn't have to wear helmets and
there's even guys who wear a face mask.
I remember that in hockey you had wearing a helmet mount and you are a pussy or
something.
Right.
In hockey.
But then little by little,
the grandfathered in thing like,
God,
there's got to be a movie about that guy.
The first guy that wore the helmet and all the persecution he got,
he must've fucking,
he must've had a good excuse.
He probably had some kind of head trauma were like,
dude,
I gotta wear a helmet.
One more hit and I'm a vegetable or I'm from in Ohio.
I think it was the first place in a NHL game that someone died in the crowd
because the puck came flying into the crowd.
A little girl died.
She got hit by a puck.
Oh my God,
that's up all around the outside so it doesn't,
it doesn't happen anymore.
But did it happen every now and then?
Catching a puck at a game used to be a thing.
So we're like a foul ball flying in and keep your eyes open because you fucked
up from foul balls.
I always wondered that like line drives and showed people,
I've seen him come flying at people had serious like head trauma.
Broken bats have come flying into the crowd too.
Shit flying.
Anybody get stabbed in the eye with the bat?
I'll look up a bat.
That's definitely happened.
How many,
how often do people get fucked up at baseball games?
Like in the audience like foul ball,
foul balls and shit hurt man.
Cause some of them get hurt them.
The line drive foul balls.
No,
right through someone's fucking forehead.
Oh yeah.
And how about bats?
They get hit with bats.
Bats are real scary.
Don't blame.
Don't try to fucking put that evil on me.
Jamie Barner videos.
It's just a picture of it,
but
I don't want to see it.
Man.
A baseball is a hard fucking rock.
It's a rock with a piece of fucking leather over it.
They're all dangerous.
It's just sort of what ads some of the risks and excitement to it that there's
something bad that can't happen.
You wouldn't want to get hit
the head with a soft ball.
Fuck a baseball.
I wouldn't want to get hit in the head with a basketball.
Yeah,
around those flying.
They've jumped into the crowd and land on you and fuck up.
Not only to your clothes are,
but like they could break
your leg or hurt a person.
People could.
One,
we get hit because I'm not stupid and I'm a pussy.
Okay,
you happy?
I don't want to get hit by a fucking baseball.
If I went to a baseball game,
I'd be like an armored knight out of a shield and shit.
I'd be looking through the shield.
You walked down when I said it and Columbus where I'm from.
One of the,
I think it was one of the first times it happened to a hockey puck when flying
into the crowd and it killed a little girl,
so they had to start putting nets up around,
I think it started happening when they've extended in baseball.
Now they're extending the nets where people,
Jeremy,
Joe doesn't want me to have that.
Bums me out,
man.
You put that,
you put that evil on me,
Jamie.
Mom.
That's a,
that's cried during movies and stuff.
Yeah.
I'm up close.
See anytime there's,
if it's a good
movie,
I'm just,
I've always been a very emotional,
both up and down.
Passionate.
Yeah.
I'm a big crier.
Kidding.
I remember being 16 and I got pulled over by the cops.
Fuck.
We were leaving a party.
Me and my friend Willy were leaving a party.
He smoked weed.
I didn't.
I was against weed.
I'm 16 we're at a fucking high school.
Part of it gets broken up by,
the cops were fucking drunk,
were hammered and I'm driving.
I didn't give a shit drunk driving drunk driving.
I should be dead right now.
I should be told this is all fiction.
None of this actually happened.
So,
so I'm,
I'm sitting in,
I turn on the car mean willing.
As soon as I turn on the car,
fucking cop right here,
just waiting for me comes up like,
Oh shit,
I'm fucked up.
I was drunk.
He,
I rolled down the window,
he pulled us out of the car.
I'm already crying and shaking and like buy the car crying and check Willie's.
I kind of cool like that and I'm crying and shaking and then the cop pulls out,
he searches my car and I just tell them the truth.
I just,
they said,
what's this cooler back here?
And I said,
it's a,
it's a wine coolers.
Cause I,
I drank wine coolers.
I was a big pussy.
Everyone drank beer.
But I was the pussy that drank wine coolers.
I didn't care.
I'm drinking so much out of cool to filters,
wine coolers.
And he goes,
what's,
what's in that?
And I said,
wine coolers.
I just admitted to him like,
I been drinking,
I got admitted,
I'm drunk.
I started crying.
I was just crying like a fucking little bitch.
And then he pulls out my ashtray and there's this all this brown ashy stuff that
to this day I don't know what it is.
And he pulls out and goes,
what is this?
I looked at it,
it's weed,
it's marijuana.
And it wasn't,
but I didn't even know what weed and marijuana look like.
I didn't even know.
But he goes,
that's read and marijuana go.
Yeah,
it's weed and marijuana.
It's his.
I'm crying,
throwing my friend under the bus.
And it was obviously not weed and there's the,
I don't know,
I don't know.
Some kind of some kind of ash.
I was so stupid.
I'm crying in the meeting.
Even the cops,
guests,
I've been drinking.
I'm drunk,
man.
That's marijuana.
And he's sitting there thinking,
that's not marijuana.
But he's saying it's marijuana.
They were confused.
You know what they did?
They said getting your car and go home.
They didn't arrest me or anything.
I said,
getting your car.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I confessed everything.
I confess too much.
They didn't know what to do with it.
I told them I was drinking and drunk and they let me go.
You told them that something wasn't pot or it was pot when it was a pot and they
knew it wasn't pot and I'm like crying.
It's crazy.
It's weed.
And they go,
well,
we just saw you and saw just a gang of paperwork.
Yes,
this is too much work.
Let me drive,
dude.
They let me drive.
They were so confused.
I told them I was drunk and they let a 16 year old boy drive home.
Did they follow you?
That was the coolest cop ever.
I don't know.
I was fucking drove home.
That's that Peter Parker Spiderman thing though.
Like what if a cop lets you go and you kill somebody?
You know and you know that story.
It's like,
it's really fascinating because I'm sure Joseph Campbell would say that it's in
one of those heroes journeys that,
uh,
he,
he talks about,
but in Spiderman,
Peter Parker,
who's this scientist kid gets bitten by this radioactive spider and he gains the
superpowers and he sort of realized that he gains these superpowers and he's
headed towards his,
uh,
w was his grandparents that he lived with,
or his aunt and his uncle was his aunt and his uncle.
And they took,
they were taking care of them.
And uh,
along the way he ran into some robber and he let the Robert go cause he's like,
this is a story of Spiderman.
Yes.
He's like,
this is not my business.
Right.
The robber kills his uncle.
So he had the opportunity to stop the Robert and he didn't do anything and his
uncle died.
And so now he takes care of his aunt and he's fucking Spiderman.
He's pissed.
So he puts a mask on.
He uses his powers now and stops crime all around golf.
And that makes sense.
So that's why he's obsessed with New York.
Yeah.
He says,
my fault,
all my fault.
If I had only stopped him when I could have,
but I didn't.
And now my uncle Ben is dead and I didn't know the backstory.
I hate,
you know me.
I've said it several times.
I hate super hero movies.
I can't fucking stand him.
But guess what?
I'm addicted to Gotham.
Fucking love the backstory of that man.
Really?
You kidding me?
Have you seen it?
No,
it was at a show.
Is it a Netflix show?
Yes.
I'm scared dude.
It's the backstory of Batman.
Batman as a kid.
I don't have that time.
Oh it's so good.
Okay,
I'll watch it and I,
I hate superheroes,
but I'm of all of a sudden knowing the backstory of all the villains,
the joker,
the writ,
you get all their backstory,
how it all happened,
how it all went down.
It's so God,
I fucking love it.
It's like the mob runs Gotham city.
The mob just fucking runs the police.
Everybody.
It's,
it's the most corrupt
city ever in the entire world.
That's the most corrupt city cop.
Stoney.
There's just some motherfuckers you just don't investigate.
Cause that you'll die.
It's so corrupted,
saw mob and,
and uh,
it's basically about him as a kid,
but mostly about,
uh,
Gordon Commissioner Gordon,
how he some,
he's a,
you know,
Batman's a Katie's like 12,
but he's a super genius and his parents got killed.
He's like a super billionaire as well.
His,
his parents that got killed right in front of them.
He spends his whole life trying to find the people that killed his parents.
And that's how it becomes Batman is trying to in Gotham it's fucking good.
You know,
I was thinking,
you were telling me this.
Imagine if you lived in a world that looked like those fucking Batman movies
look like all gray and gloomy and they're trying to make it super realistic.
They're trying to like,
like how are these guys,
how do they end up in these fucking tights and these outfits,
they're showing how it's happening in the in crime and the show.
But what I'm saying is when you watch those movies,
they're trying to make it believable.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's always like gloomy and dark and black.
Like if you lived in that world.
Whoa.
What?
What kind of happiness do you think you,
what level of happiness do you think people would find it?
A world where it never got sunny.
It's all shot like that too.
It's all like real.
It's like game of Thrones production.
The lighting is,
every shot is magical.
It isn't like when you watch like the office and shit about the shot,
you know?
But the shot,
everything,
the lighting,
not like game of Thrones style,
like they're trying to make it look,
I don't have,
everything's,
epic's not as much of a feature that's epic.
Like every shot,
they spend a lot of time on the,
on the lighting.
It's re shot.
Amazing.
It's,
it's a great story.
It makes a guy who hates superheroes.
Fuck,
I'm addicted.
I love that man.
Now I'm in the Batman.
If we all lived in a world where it was that dark and gloomy,
I bet we'd be miserable as fuck.
I had it.
We super hard.
It was super hard for people to feel good.
We're so tuned into wanting that light on our face.
It's amazing,
man.
It's amazing.
You know,
I started watching,
I would have never started watching,
but I have a friend who's like conspiracy theorists,
dude who uh,
his name is ride Dawson is like his,
his,
he lives in Japan.
Some American guy who just all is a con JFK and nine 11,
uh,
expert.
He spends his whole life on those two things as well.
And one was in Dune hanging around with at parties and he goes,
he goes,
you want to know how shit really is?
Run as watch Gotham if you watch Gotham,
that's how it's run.
Exactly.
And I said,
really?
He goes,
that's how it's run.
So I'm watching it going,
Shit.
Um,
it,
uh,
it's all based on money.
Everything is based on money.
You could just follow the money when you follow the money.
Oh,
you need a circle.
Well,
anyways,
you know what,
uh,
um,
what do you think of Mitch?
You Michio Kaku xe is he,
uh,
he's a brilliant physicist.
Totally right.
Interesting guy.
He's got some interesting things to say about a lot
of different things.
Well,
what I would say is on your show.
No,
no,
I've been with him on the opiate.
Anthony showed those.
Asks him about mushrooms.
You been on a show with him?
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I was calling in man and I just bombed him with some mushrooms questions.
So what did he sound when he called in?
Maybe he called in and I was there,
I forget how it worked.
I forget what you think.
Michio Kaku smokes.
Wade negative.
Negative sir.
Negative does not do any drugs.
Cause I said to him,
you asked him about psychedelics?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I asked him about mushrooms.
He said well,
we're not trying to uh,
give ourselves brain damage.
We're trying to get smarter.
It was one of those like,
look man,
that guy is like a paid science educator.
Right,
okay.
What he does is try to spread science all over the world and when you're in that
realm you need funding for stuff.
You need people to greenlight your TV projects.
You've got to avoid criticism at all costs and any,
anytime your saying that it's probably a good idea to do certain drugs.
That's,
that's just,
you can't,
that you can't say yes if you do mushrooms.
It's,
it's very possible that you might be in contact with entities from other
dimensions for which to be dead.
If he did do me probably wouldn't said,
oh,
he's probably what?
Almost anybody who's really smart who does like a dose of DMT comes back and
goes,
okay,
what the fuck is that all about?
He did.
He was in this amazing documentary,
just a fucking life changing documentary called the principal.
Have you seen that?
No,
I have not.
Fuck.
And Kokkos in it,
a bunch of physicists,
like professors from Mit.
It's just a bunch of dudes and like route,
like religious scientists too.
They have like two or three of that.
And the reason it's 10,
it's called the principal.
Is it recent?
Two years.
And uh,
it's,
uh,
it's just like 10 dude's like a navigation expert,
physicist Michio Kaku.
And then I'll just go on back and forth,
you know,
all these astrophysicists and cosmologists and she'd gone back and forth,
uh,
discussing,
um,
space and they give you a timeline.
It's an awesome high end document.
They give you a timeline of why we believe what we believe about space and shit.
Fuck it is,
it will melt your fucking brain.
Do the craziest shit.
Have you ever heard of the cosmic microwave background?
You know what that is the noise that they indicate that they,
it indicates the Big Bang.
It's the afterglow of the big bang.
So I don't know,
Dude.
I don't know if this is what we called the afterglow radiation.
It's like the big bang.
It's like the radiation rounds left over after the big bank.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Do you know?
But when you start going on about that,
I get lost in the mix.
But the crazy thing about it though,
this is the crazy thing about,
I don't know shit about that.
All I do is just watch them space documentaries were fed.
I used to be addicted at space
documentaries.
And then when you watch this documentary,
you're fine and you find out why we believe what we believe and the,
you know,
the timeline of,
uh,
a taller may to Copernicus,
to Kepler,
to Galileo and all that,
that,
that timeline of what people thought and believe in everywhere.
It was always a battle of all of these astronomers study and the,
the lights in the sky,
that's all they saw was the lights in the sky.
Stunning goes,
everything goes this way,
except those wandering stars.
And then they figured out those wandering stars were planets.
And then from there I'll go,
okay,
those are the plants,
because they're the only ones that are on their own course.
So they're all trying to figure out,
is the universe spinning around us or are we spin around universe?
That's always the fucking at,
it's always been,
we think like,
like I always thought,
oh,
they're dumb.
Back then they thought they thought the world was the center of the universe and
all that shit.
And you look back at that,
you don't really look into,
unless you know the actual timeline.
It's crazy.
Hearing all these scientists going back to the and you hear them explaining
what,
how it all went down.
You,
once you go through that whole,
the whole story of what we think about space and all that,
they tell you,
they tell you we don't know shit.
We're looking at a bunch of lights and the Goddamn sky.
You're going to tell me that that light and that light that's 200 and 5,000
trillion light years away.
How the fuck did you figure that out and you learn?
Don't they have an explanation for that shit?
No,
exactly.
That's what every what you just said right now.
Now's what everyone's natural reaction because anytime someone says anything
about space,
you automatically think someone figured it out.
You don't know the guy's name.
You don't know the name of the experiment.
You didn't look into it yourself.
You just think when someone tells you how far is the earth from the sun?
Oh,
say Oh,
93 million miles away.
Like you just,
you,
everybody relies on someone figured that out and someone double checked it.
Dude,
it's math.
It's science.
It's math.
But no one really knows you're going on what you read and whatever hits you for
me.
No one like that.
We're talking to you.
I'm going to buy.
Yeah,
if I told you if I told you right now,
logical method of measurement.
Yeah.
Like yeah.
Like you figured someone figured that out.
Well,
no,
I just assumed that if there's a bunch of guys that are trying to figure out how
to get to the moon and back Marza back,
and I said of these rovers around that are shooting video back.
They know how many miles it is.
Yeah.
They've got it figured out.
I just don't know what the method they use.
Someone figured it out.
You don't know the guy's name.
There's names of experiments like you could actually look in and you look at,
there was an experiment called the Michelson Morley experiment.
They tried to prove that the earth was moving.
So the,
so they,
uh,
they,
they assumed that the space is filled with an ether.
Like that's what dark matter maybe is dark energy.
There's an ether.
So it's like measure,
uh,
the light waves going through the ether as it hits the Earth.
And then we'll measure it back and we'll be able to tell if there's an ether
based on the light going against the ether.
And with the code,
it's like you're swimming relative to the ground.
You know,
they're swimming against the current,
you go one way and you're going a certain speed,
but if you go along the court or the other way,
you're going away faster.
It's like that,
but they couldn't measure shit.
When you look in,
when you look in the Michelson Morley experiment,
the results were,
we couldn't measure that we're moving at all.
So it's always been a debate.
Are we moving?
Even with Einstein,
it was a debate did like in the fucking 20s and 30s,
they still didn't know.
You assume.
Yeah,
it's moving.
It says right here at thousand miles an hour.
It's rotating.
But they,
the people at the top don't even know.
They don't even know.
But we assumed because we read it somewhere that they know.
But it's all guesswork.
When you,
when you watch this documentary,
I'm just repeating shit dude.
You,
when you watch this,
they're all sand.
It's we're studying.
This is what they found.
What they found in the cosmic background.
They took one reading in 2006 and one in 2013 and the one in 2006 this is what
the documentary is about.
All the signs were talking about it is they took a picture.
It's called the cosmic microwave background.
It's a picture of all the galaxies through all the way around you and they took
a picture.
They did it in 2006 it's not a conspiracy.
This is a science documentary that I'm talking about.
I'm not talking about conspiracy theory.
Documentary is a science doc and there aren't.
Michio Kaku was talking about the principle,
the principle.
It's called the Copernicus principal and what they found,
this is what they found and in the first reading,
and they thought there must be a mistake.
There must be a space until 2013 the European Space Ng,
they found the same thing and this,
this is what right now cosmology it.
They don't know what the fuck to do.
You know what they found out that cosmic microwave background shows?
Did all of the galaxies are on shelves lined up to us that we are this,
we're at the fucking center.
They don't know what to think about.
That's what the documentary is about.
This is a rate,
pull this down.
So this is a recent documentary.
There's a lot of controversy going on about it,
but who is it?
The thinks that the universe is in shelves.
That's what they're analyzing.
They're going,
they're looking at heat in space.
That's what they're looking to.
Just heat and all the heat.
All the heat is all lined up like in shelves and it's all surround.
They don't know what to think.
That's what this documentary is about is in 2006 they go,
okay,
but that must be a mistake.
That must be a mistake.
So they didn't do it again until 2013 European space agency in Paris.
They had fucking press conference about it.
They,
it was the exact same thing.
So they don't know what to think right now.
Right now cosmology is like,
if that's true,
if we are the center of the universe,
that means everything that we've ever taught her ever,
ever,
ever new is all wrong.
So that's where they're at,
right?
That's what the documentary is about.
I don't know if it's true that cosmic microwave background could be total
bullshit.
That could easily be like a mind game in itself.
Like they don't know what the fuck that is.
What you find out
got assumed that the top astronomers know what the fuck.
Yes.
So either way,
either way,
it's crazy.
Constantly updating what they know to be true.
So it's not like something that's rigid.
Like astronomy is one of those things.
It's like they all,
they all release.
See every time they find out something new,
every time they find out something new about a planet,
like it's important to release that information.
It's not like they have like a strict narrative that they have to hold on to.
So if someone comes around and says,
it turns out that our measurement was inaccurate and the moon is,
you know,
x amount of miles further and weighs x amount of tons less than we thought it
did or more,
you don't really think that would be a bad thing for science.
Right.
That was new.
Just a new discovery with better equipment.
But the new discovery,
wonder what,
go ahead.
Interviewed on the,
according to the Wikipedia for this documentary claimed that they weren't told
what they were being interviewed for and meet you.
A caucus said that this was likely clever editing and that whole shipments
bordered on fresh honesty.
George Ellis has said that I was interviewed for it,
but they did not disclose this agenda,
which of course is nonsense.
I don't think it was worth responding to and he goes on to talk more about it.
There was counter claims just that this is all little false hope.
Yeah.
There's controversy going on man.
So the guy who produced it,
the guy who produced it,
he put put out interview.
Like there's people
that are getting pressured.
I don't know.
This is what they're saying.
This could all be bullshit.
Yeah,
but then also be bullshit.
Those,
those documentaries case so juiced up.
They're so,
they're so juicy.
They seem so good.
They seem so real.
You get fired up and then once you get fired up,
it's tough to get unfired up.
Cosmic microwave background could be total bullshit.
You don't want to be total bullshit.
I've read really recently.
Okay.
You believe that there's been some debate as to whether or not it's an eternal
process,
that there was no beginning or end to the universe in that what you're seeing
when you're seeing a big bang is not the beginning.
It's just that beginning.
It's all theories.
When you watch this documentary,
you're like,
they don't know shit.
Well,
they know a lot,
but they definitely don't know everything.
Lights,
that's all they're looking at.
They're not looking at mass or anything.
Well,
there's some things.
They're measuring the galaxy because the red light is elongated.
They,
that's a galaxy and it's 700 trillion light years away.
How the fuck it sounds,
it sounds like there's a lotta bullshit with cosmology.
They're telling you this.
They're telling you who is day though as scientists and Mitchell Kako,
he'll tell us,
uh,
um,
the Kapernick is principal.
The one that we live by is the,
were insignificant.
We mean nothing.
We're a speck in the universe and then there's a geocentric model.
That's the heliocentric model that we go around the sun.
The geocentric model means that everything goes around us.
That's what this says in the Bible.
That's what the first astronomers were saying.
Uh,
um,
taller may was the first one said,
yeah,
we are the center.
You can tell based on his own observations,
everything is revolving around us.
And then other people came by.
Copernicus said,
HAH,
no,
based on these observations,
this could also work.
The Sun's going around.
Oh,
we're going around the sun.
And,
and then there was a third one where we're the center of the sun's going around
us,
but the planets are going around the sun.
There was three models and they were all based on observations.
Like dude's just looking at lights,
they're looking at light,
sort of figure out,
okay,
are we going around the sun or the sun going around us?
You know?
And um,
even like Einstein's times he has a quote saying that we don't have the
technology to even prove that the earth is even spinning.
They can't even,
there's still a debate.
Are we even moving?
Are we still,
do we have to move?
Because apparently the moon doesn't spend it.
It's still,
why wouldn't,
why is it so hard to believe that we're still,
because they haven't even improve even at it since Einstein.
Oh No,
maybe they did prove it.
Earth is the center of the universe and we stand still and the universe spins
around us 24 hours a day.
Wouldn't,
wouldn't that be not to think they're measuring that though.
And I think that's what they're saying.
The copper,
I feel them emailing me right now and tell her to go fuck myself.
This is a disrespectful conversation that files that could be totally bullshit,
but we need to get near the grass.
Tyson,
Eddie Bravo.
Yeah,
that's what they're saying.
Yeah.
I don't know who the fuck is they and I don't know what this,
I have to watch this documentary.
Michio Kaku news all about it.
He's in it,
he's in it,
and then there are the fuckers,
the conspiracy,
but everything,
if that's true,
all the Shit we've learned about scientists,
trash,
everything.
Even Einstein's theory of relativity,
if this is true,
that goes down,
that Copernicus principle goes down,
everything goes down about space.
Everything hazard comes back or the rebel flag on the roof of the car.
The world is up and down.
Cats and dogs living together.
Don't you think?
It's weird that we spin and the water doesn't fall off the plant somehow
magically it gravity.
It's just that we dealing with mass on it.
It's such a grand scale that even though it's circular,
like what we think of as being flat is just our inability to grasp the
perspective of a 24,000 miles circumference.
Oh,
okay.
You don't believe that?
I don't know.
I mean,
I haven't done experiments on it.
You don't have to know other people did it?
Yeah.
Read what the scientists believe Shit other people done.
I don't believe any of the loving people you two videos that are not.
I believe that.
I believe people talking when I,
when I see their video as they're talking like it's a physicist and he's
talking,
I like,
I liked that kind of shit.
Anything that's written,
like anybody could have wrote whatever I want,
I need to see interviews.
I understand.
Watch the principal,
your fucking mind will melt.
This is not a conspiracy theory of video.
This is a sudden be a bullshit video.
Because what Jamie was saying was these people that were in it were saying they
were edited out of context and they didn't know the true intention of the movie.
I don't know.
You know,
cause you seed it.
I'm just parroting when he's just talking,
we're just talking about [inaudible].
What do you think about Dick?
I'm not really into it.
Cut To,
what do you think about space?
I'm not really into it.
It's not my thing.
It's not your thing.
Well,
how'd you get this job?
It's probably,
well,
I went to school at the University of Arizona.
You know what I mean?
They have this like yeah,
it's probably bullshit.
But what you learned from that,
whether it's true or not about the cosmic microwave background,
whether we're rolling,
whether the universe is rotating around us,
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean shit.
What you learn is there so many different points of views and everything is just
a theory and you learned that they still haven't figured a lot of shit out that
we think people will figure it out,
but they actually didn't figure out.
They still haven't figured out.
They're like,
yeah,
the earth spins.
We have a pendulum that fucking approves.
If you see a pendulum,
you prove that it proves that it spins like really a fucking Pendleton.
He don't.
You think this is something that you should probably really know what you're
talking about before you go on these long rants?
Cause I don't know what I'm talking about.
The show stone or tile.
I know.
I don't know what I'm talking about,
but what scientists we're funding.
It doesn't take an idiot to fit.
Oh my God.
No,
no,
no.
It's just this,
this,
this is not something we should,
this is like some really dumb dudes who have head injuries talking about jet Lee
movies.
Turn it Hollywood,
use that shit.
Turn it off.
That's how they use that shot on the street.
You don't mean that's fascinating.
If it's real,
it's fascinating,
right?
It's real.
It's life changing.
Yeah.
If it's rules,
guys who were in it and say they were tricked a lot of things,
I have to watch it.
You got to watch why they said they were trick.
There's a reason.
There's reasons.
I don't want to admit they changes.
Everything did it crushes it crushes their careers,
but why does it even have to be conspiracy?
Like if you just look at what,
what is absolute about space?
Forget about all the measurements.
Like forget about all the numbers because we don't really,
I don't know and you don't know.
Just forget about that.
Just just like what they're figuring out right now about Mars.
I mean that they're sending back these images from this rovers and these
scientists are debating what this is,
what that is.
If this is actual running water at one point in time,
if this is some sort of a strange,
all that for sure is really happening 100% that's all bullshit.
You don't think they're really unmarked?
They're faking everything.
I think they're faking everything.
I think all that's fake.
You don't think they,
they landed on Mars with a rover fake.
How come?
It's just too hard.
It's too hard to do.
They got to,
you know what?
They've lied so much.
NASA slides so goddamn much that I don't believe she,
I see.
I believe.
I believe for sure they have shot rockets into space because we can watch it
happen and also for sure people died when they've launched those rockets into
space.
But they definitely have a way to move rovers around on Mars now.
It's not a,
it's not a biological impediment.
It's not like they have to keep people,
like they're saying if they're going to fly people out there,
it's going to take six months and you know they have to have enough food to stay
alive and air and whatever the fuck it,
they have to make sure they don't get hit by micro meteors and they going to put
them on the surface of Mars.
But that's not a person though.
You're talking about like a rover and it looks like fucking Arizona with like a
red tent.
We rally cause mom shops like Arizona,
but we were ready.
Shit,
come on.
I think it's all bull.
I don't believe anything.
Well you know,
there's nothing on Mars that doesn't exist on earth.
That's what they say.
All the mean,
isn't that,
isn't that correct?
As far as like the minerals that they're finding in the soil or the kind of dirt
that they're experiencing.
I mean,
I think it's different in its appearance and its imagery,
but it could just be that that's what is without water look like.
When you see a real picture of Mars,
you CEO's A.
Dot.
A light.
Right?
I understand.
But that's what we see.
But like when you're looking at Mars,
right?
Or you're looking at the,
the desert like in Arizona,
like that crazy desert,
the Utah,
Arizona,
you know those rocks and shit,
all that crazy desert.
Oh,
that looks,
that might as well be Mars.
That could be anything.
If you thought Maurice was completely different from Earth,
think again that could be Pomona
are warm.
Blue Planet is more similar in some ways.
I the desolate red planathon,
you know,
and we have comparison images to prove it at,
find out about the actual,
uh,
minerals in it and see if you can find like if the soil is significantly
different.
I mean the soil varies all over the place on earth,
right?
I mean,
soils everywhere.
You don't think there's a little tiny chance,
small little percentage that they can be faking and then,
no,
I don't,
I don't think it's hard to do.
I mean,
I think it's hard to do,
but they've done it.
Look,
they've already got all these crazy satellite images of earth.
They got satellite images all the way out to,
um,
Jupiter's moons.
They've got that satellite image of a,
that frozen moon.
What's that?
Frozen Moon.
Oh,
let me see if that's CGI.
Find that Bro.
We got a picture of a frozen fucking moon.
I guarantee you it's CGI.
The frozen,
the water moon.
What is it called?
No way they can take a picture of a second man.
What does Mars made of comparison to Planet Mars?
Marsh and soil is the fine,
blah,
blah on differ,
uh,
properties can differ significantly from those on terrestrial,
those of terrestrial soil,
the term Martian soil typically refers to the fine fraction of re.
What does that,
what does that word recall?
Regolith.
Regolith on earth.
The term soil usually includes organic content.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So because everything's dead,
it's dirt.
It's not soil.
Huh?
That's interesting.
Right?
Like soil is a fucking life form.
That's what people don't
think about.
Have you ever seen one of those documentaries where they show,
um,
the,
uh,
interaction between the mycelium and the,
the roots of the trees and even rocks themselves?
Like how they have this sort of crazy relationship?
Radio lab did this amazing podcast on it.
Man,
you know,
we think of a tree as being like,
this is a tree.
It's in the ground,
it's by itself and there's another tree over there.
Now they're all connected like it's some crazy super highway of give and take.
They give each other sugars and minerals and the,
the mycelium actually cleans to rocks and pulls minerals out of the rocks and
they all exist together in this crazy ecosystem.
It's an amazing podcast,
man.
If you listen to it,
it's a mind blower.
It's a,
it's just how they look and all that out.
They actually have seen these things under the microscope.
They were showing these things that these things exist in a just a small area.
You'll find miles and miles of this like sort of fungus growth and fungus.
Apparently the week's explained to me it like when you see like mushrooms,
mushrooms aren't like a plant.
They're closer to a person and the to plant mushrooms,
breathe air.
Wait a minute,
you just said mushrooms are closer to a person than a plant than they are a
plant.
They're more like a life form.
They're more like they're,
they're weird man.
You believe that mushrooms are weird,
so weird growth.
It's some sort of a living thing that doesn't move but they interconnect and
some strange way with all the plants around them and become like a highway
system.
They even this,
this,
this in this,
um,
this podcast they were talking about how they find a tree that's like
specifically needy and they channel resources to that tree.
Like there's like some sort of a way that these plants are communicating with
each other.
They're just struggling to understand right now they really don't know what the
fuck they're doing.
They just know that something is happening and that we may have looked at plants
as being these inanimate things or these things that lie that they live,
but they don't have any awareness whatsoever of their surroundings.
Now they know that they can play the sound of caterpillars.
Chewing leaves around plants and these plants were,
was release a toxin that makes their leaves,
tastes like shit to discourage predation.
Like Karen's the eight,
they can get any spray on them.
They ran out of spray.
What do you mean?
The ones that the bugs delete is probably the ones that pay probably they don't
spray the old one.
This is not a re they don't use real bugs for this.
They take the sound,
this is where it's fucked up.
They take a recording of caterpillar eating leaves and they make the recording
go off next to the tree and the tree starts releasing those chemicals.
Somehow or another.
It's taking in the sound waves cause that's all they are of a caterpillar eating
leaves and it's causing the leaves to become more bitter.
Eventually there's going to be one plant that knows its trick and then I'm breed
and evolve.
And then you've got to change the systems.
Well,
yeah.
All the animals are gonna Starve to death.
Like they,
they've had problems where animals will eat up stream from other animals.
So if a bunch of animals are eating the sound of the animals eating,
that plant gets into the system and all the,
the leaves go bitter and the animals won't eat the leaves and then they wind up
getting sick and dying.
Uh,
here's where it gets Chepe.
What,
what,
what gets where clappy though the animals,
they get sick and die because they don't eat.
They starve to death because the plants tastes like she's a plants.
Tastes like shit.
Damn.
There's a war going on that were right under our nose and we didn't know.
Here's where it gets really weird.
That plant that they're talking about that does all this.
That's the acacia plant.
That's the plant that those Jerusalem scholars think might be DMT.
It might be what Moses saw when Moses saw the burning Bush that became God like
that was God.
It was communicating with them.
They think it might be the Acacia tree cause he,
Acacia tree is rich in dimethyltryptamine and the acacia trees.
The tree that when animals are eating it upstream,
the ones downstream,
they changed their taste.
They smell it or they hear it or somehow or another they become aware of through
the ground that the ones up hill or getting eaten so they all taste like shit
and animals start starving to death.
By the way,
monitor.
Some of that may not be true,
but I believe it is according to that Radiolab podcast.
I believe it's true.
Hey,
you never know.
Pay trans-am dime,
dime piece after a cage fight.
It's worth a lot of cash.
Dan White,
that's,
that's a,
that's an easily sell to America.
And she,
uh,
she fucked up a tattooed chick from another country that's strong,
you know,
and she fucked her up with a jumping roundhouse kick to the face,
dancing with the stars.
Food style revenge of the hotties.
Look at this.
Boom.
She did one to the body there.
Oh,
look at that combination.
There it is.
Woo.
Paige vanzant number 10 now what do you think she is now for this gotta be like
number seven,
right?
She gets the big jump.
That's a scary division.
The top,
the tops got that motherfucker.
She's probably gonna start acting.
Does that make a page?
Van Zandt?
She certainly could.
She could quit right now after that fight on Fox.
That's a big deal to have that fight on Fox poffle Paige vanzant
super marketable.
Real nice girl too.
That's a good opening line for like a hot chicken.
Excuse me.
You're very marketable.
She's super marketable.
Tell a girl,
girls in this sport,
you mock marketable a girl or a guy in the sport.
You're in the sport for two reasons,
right?
You want to be competitive for sure.
But two is you want to make a fuck
load of money and get out while you can.
And she was even saying when she realized what she was doing,
dancing with the stars,
didn't an interview recently where she was talking about,
she realized how much money other athletes make in comparison to fighters.
And she wasn't complaining.
She was just saying like,
I'm still blessed,
but you know,
I'm a,
this is the UFC pays you more than any job I've ever had in my life.
But man,
you find out what some athletes make another sports,
but that's just the way it goes.
That's just the way this sport is in this particular period of development.
And eventually the money will be there.
But you know,
for people to say that it's just the way it is,
it's going to be there for her though.
Dude.
Yeah,
it's for sure going to be there for her.
She's laughing.
She's laughing at missing her own kick.
But what's funny is right after that,
she's like,
what?
Ooh,
this is a crazy kick man.
This is like some Liotta Machida type shit.
That's a highlight reel kid.
His brother,
the ultimate cheat.
His brother fought and Bella.
Yeah.
How did he do?
He's got some serious striking,
nasty karate duty.
Throw an uppercut clipped.
The guy won one opera cut any fights just like him.
That crime stands where they're jumping up and down in there.
You know,
it's like fencing,
like a fencing stance.
He looks legit.
He's been hurt over the last few years.
He was,
you know,
he's been working on is a MMA career for awhile,
but he's like 36 right?
38 38 mm is striking his left.
I watched him fight in something else.
Might've been the RFA.
What did he find him before this RFI.
Rfi?
Yeah.
I saw him fight.
Nah,
he looked real good and he does look a lot like Liotta.
Like a lot of the way he moves and see,
you know,
it was thinking to me,
man.
Uh,
it was um,
something,
uh,
I was thinking when I was watching them fight in the early days,
I was like,
man,
what a grind it is to get into MMA.
You know,
you've got these guys that are really good at a sport and they get to a level,
is this him here?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
wait a minute.
I saw some highlights of this online.
Yeah.
It's exactly like Liotta well,
you know,
confidence and he throws bombs.
Did they both learn from their dad?
What is hard?
See that little combo.
Yeah.
He did that a another time and really I think he put,
put the guy on his butt with it.
Damn Chins.
Oh,
looks good.
Yeah.
I wonder why the UFC didn't sign them.
Seems like that would be a good signing.
You know,
sign this Guy Bella tour looked really good,
but you know what,
a guy like this,
you know,
have a few fights and Bella tour and then maybe a the UFC,
we'll bring them over just like a,
okay.
They did a with,
um,
what's his name?
Will.
Okay.
Uh,
Eddie Alvarez?
No.
Whoa.
Of course Eddie Alvarez for sure,
but recently.
Goddammit.
Why am I blanking on his name?
He just won.
He just beat some money.
I didn't,
I didn't call the fight though.
He Bella tours champion at one point in time.
Yes.
Thank you,
sir.
Thank you sir.
We'll Brooks.
Yeah,
we'll Brooks just came over from bell tower.
It's like,
you know,
they're going to probably exchange stuff back and forth now.
Rory is over there.
Roy McDonald just signed to Bella tour.
Dude.
Roy McDonald versus Michael Page Ho Lee.
Shit.
I'm in.
I want to see that fight.
That's an interesting fight.
I think that good competition is good and I think that a good competition like,
uh,
like Bella [inaudible].
I think it's good for MMA.
It's good for the UFC.
It's good for business.
It's good for business,
isn't it?
I agree.
We need a bunch of organizations.
You know,
there's,
um,
there's an a large potential for growth in this sport.
Bella tours,
probably number two,
right?
Oh,
for sure.
Who's number three?
Probably one IFC.
I mean,
I don't know.
It would have to be a,
well,
you know,
uh,
world series of fighting does have some really good fighters but doesn't get
another enough love for some reason.
That's kind of interesting,
right?
It's on NBC.
Yeah.
But like world series of fighting has Fitch.
They had Paul Horace until they kicked him out.
Take Shield.
They have Jake shields.
Um,
they got Marlin Mris.
Who's a bad motherfucker.
They got just engage you.
They got some good for,
they had Tyrone Spong.
I don't know if Taiwan spawn is still doing MMA though.
I think Taiwan spawn might have decided to go to straight boxing.
He's doing really well and straight boxing.
It's got nasty hands man.
You know.
And he got Alan Jobe on pot.
No,
no,
no.
He's much larger.
He's a,
uh,
Weiss,
I guess.
Essentially he's a light heavyweight.
If he was an MMA fighter,
but he could fight heavyweight too.
He's fought,
he's fun.
It's a pretty big boys.
I would like to know what he,
what Wade he fights at.
And I would,
I would imagine it would be in the two twenties or something like that.
What's the latest with Mark Hunt?
You know,
he's out.
He been protested about that.
Brock Lesnar's test Zuma.
That's Obama.
And he's really a bummer for him.
Yeah.
It's a bummer for him,
you know,
because,
uh,
that's stuff that Brock tested for.
I mean,
it's not a,
it's not really a steroid.
It's something that helps you,
uh,
bring your body back after your endocrine system shuts down.
Obviously,
I'm not a doctor.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't take my word for those.
Cj.
Um,
it's Clomiphene,
I believe it's called.
I think that's what they released.
What that stuff is an estrogen blocker and it helps your body produce
testosterone.
And it could,
uh,
you know,
you could be taking it for a legit reason or he could be taking it because you
need your body to really kickstart it's testosterone after you,
uh,
overdosed it,
you know,
shut the balls down.
So that's the,
that's the real concern.
When people hear that someone was taking an estrogen blocker,
like,
okay,
why?
Apparently the Jon Jones story,
which red band predicted hilariously is a boner pills.
What did predict that boner pills?
Because red pen is taking those boner pills a bunch of times.
He said,
dude,
there's definitely steroids in them.
They make you like crazy.
He's like,
there,
there's a bunch of shit in there.
Who knows what's in there?
Like he just buy these gas station boner pills and that's what Brian said.
And I said,
well,
it makes you think that.
And he was like,
well,
because he,
he likes to party,
right?
Like John Jones tested positive for coke.
He was like,
people that like to do coke,
they want to take like boner pills to get their dick hard.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he nailed it.
I'm like,
He nailed it.
Good CSI shit.
You should be an investigative reporter.
Crop the case.
And he was right.
It was bro.
Gonna Forgive John John's like,
ah,
those are just boner pills.
I think that's okay.
Right?
Well the,
there was even talk about about how long the suspension would be for Brock
Lesnar.
It's all weird man.
It's real weird.
And here's another thing about like things like Bella Tura.
Somebody brought this up online on Twitter,
whether Bella tour,
uh,
gets tested by Usada and I don't know the answer to that.
I don't know what they,
how they test or what they test.
I know people have tested positive for some shit before it Bella tour,
but I don't know when,
and not to know what commission,
but I do not imagine in any way that it's as stringent as the test of the UFC
does.
Right.
There's no way peers,
the peers that like Bobby Lashley yeah.
Does not pass the smell test.
No,
no,
no offense.
Bobby,
you literally a hell of an athlete,
but that looks like your job.
Or one 58 they were tested by the Mohegan Department of Athletic Regulation
testing.
Okay.
So that's more Mohegan Sun.
That must be where the casino is.
They probably have their own athletic commission and a,
you know,
who knows what methods they use and who knows whether it's a,
just a post fight test like they used to do in the UFC and a lot of guys had
figured out how to crack the system.
I Dunno,
it's a good question.
Who knows.
It'd be an interesting choice for people that,
um,
wanted to,
uh,
wanted to get some help.
You know,
didn't want to completely jump into this new school of constant testing.
I feel like.
How would you just test me after the fight and just,
we'll just work this out in camp.
How about Nate Diaz pulling out that vape pen and his press conference that took
balls,
Huh?
Shit against,
well,
I didn't even think he thought he was doing anything wrong.
It's a CBD oil pen.
He probably didn't realize.
Most people just can't,
they can't make the distinction between CBD oil and pot.
You know,
that CBD oils,
just some shit that you do.
I take that every day just as a antioxidant,
antiinflammatory.
Well,
CBD oils natural.
If people aren't taking that and there's been lots of reports of success taking,
uh,
this CBD oil when you have any kind of cancer,
you know,
they've been,
they've been good studies.
One,
why not just take it before just maybe as a preventative,
you know,
can't hurt.
Yeah,
that's what I do.
Um,
a lot of people report good results with it,
you know,
and it's,
it's supposed to be really good for pain.
People have crazy.
Is it that,
you know,
we have a state like Colorado and there's other states too,
like Washington and Oregon now,
but there's states where it's,
it's like,
it's like a,
it's like going to Amsterdam.
Colorado is like Amsterdam,
but then we got another Amsterdam,
we got to Washington,
Amsterdam,
we've got an Oregon Amsterdam.
But Colorado is,
that's probably the most famous state for legalizing recreational use.
How crazy is it that we're living in a world like that do to change their whole
economy chaser economy?
Denver is booming.
It's,
it's like a gold rush.
It's like they found gold,
it's green,
and they just like skyscrapers everywhere.
Is it like that?
Well,
the real estate has gone up by a significant amount.
Last time I heard it was like 14 or 16%,
like the real estate prices have gone up.
Um,
drunk driving is the lowest it's been in decades.
Violent crimes,
Lowe's has been in a long time.
It's crazy,
man.
It's weird.
People will run instances of teenage drunk.
Yeah.
Drunk driving,
getting pulled over with booze lot.
A lot of less instances of teenagers getting families from all over the world
uprooting and taking their kids that have seizures.
20 a day.
They've taken them in and starting a new life in Colorado and the kids are
having,
they're down to one seizure a week or maybe even less,
maybe even the last.
Yeah,
that's a big point.
And one of them off,
you know,
my friend Johnny,
Johnny rotten.
You remember Johnny Johnny's a kid.
Um,
he had uh,
some,
some real issues and um,
the cannabis oil and eating hash and like,
like you saw that documentary where they had that kid or that a news report
rather where they had that kid who was,
um,
he was having some seizures.
And a,
they didn't know what to do and they were like at their last rope and they tried
cannabis,
they started giving this kid a Charlotte's web was in like a mango.
They would give it to them and like pieces of fruit or a melon or something like
that.
I mean this kid is completely stopped all the seizures,
but it's apparently really,
really,
really effective for that.
Yeah.
So anybody out there that if you know anybody with kids that have seizures and
they're,
they're on the medications,
there's a whole shit load of them out there.
There is hope for them.
You got to move to Colorado or you know,
you'd just get a,
you just get it,
stay where you're at and just get it anyway you can,
you know,
to save your kid's life.
Or You could move,
but there's a place you can go,
Colorado,
Washington,
Oregon,
you can take your,
your kids seizures are the kids that,
you know,
relatives,
whatever.
You could take them to once a week,
maybe once every two weeks.
That those are the results I'm hearing.
Yeah.
And there's also other parts of the same country that we live in right now where
if you took that same medics and and you got caught with it,
you go to jail,
a guaranteed go to jail.
There's a bunch of stupid spots in this country,
but they're not bad people.
They're just operating on bad old ideas and they think of themselves as being
good people.
And I bet in your head you are a good person.
But if you're enforcing marijuana laws in 2016 you're on the wrong side.
You were on the wrong side.
It helps a lot of people with a lot of shit.
And if somebody is trying to get their kid some medicine and,
and you are trying to stop them and lock them in a cage,
and this is a medicine that grew out of the ground.
You're out of your fucking mind.
You're,
you're operating on some old voodoo schedule,
one drug,
they wouldn't change it.
They wouldn't change the classification.
Maybe a Hillary's going to do it when she gets in.
Maybe they made a deal.
Let's make the big change when we get it.
And let's hold on to her cards.
Okay.
We're going to get in
this country is in some serious trouble.
Jesus Christ.
We get to make a new system.
Jesus fucking,
they don't want to,
they don't want to do it.
System so obvious that it's rigged.
I mean,
when you got Hillary and Trump,
that's rig fucking,
they're clawing at it,
man.
They trying to hold onto it as long as they can.
So red,
it's going to be interesting to see how much longer we can continue to,
I mean,
how about country that operates like this,
but that election fraud shit that happened in California with Hillary and Bernie
Sanders.
It's,
it's like viral.
As soon as that happens,
boom.
Orlando.
Pam,
what if,
well,
there's always speculation.
What's been proven about voter fraud?
Is there anything you've been proven or no,
I didn't.
I,
it's not something,
it's not something that uh,
um,
that shocked where I need them to evidence.
I'm like,
it's like telling me that some horror fucks.
Some other dude,
I'm not going to,
oh,
I need to fucking video.
I'm like,
it would just be nice.
Just be nice.
Make sense?
It would just be nice if you couldn't get rich running the government.
It'd be nice if you could just,
you know,
there's no way you could do this to get rich.
You just can't do it.
I think that,
I mean,
Jesus,
there's this no hope.
There's no,
there are too many,
too many people are just there with it.
They just got him on that media.
They're addicted to that media.
There's just no way around it.
I mean there's a,
there's a quote that I posted on Instagram from Jim Morrison,
um,
at him.
I'm sure he didn't make it up,
but it says those who control the media control the mind is that says Jim
Morris.
That got a bunch of it was,
I'm sure it was,
but that,
that isn't,
I mean that's,
that's everything right there.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
But the thing is today isn't the media.
I like,
boy,
what a slippery grip they have on it.
It seems so slippery than me.
They got it.
They got it all under control.
Cause there's a lot.
But I feel like there's everybody's the media now,
like there's so many different accesses,
so many points of access to trick them.
They still took them all day,
still tricking them all day.
Look,
we got Hillary on Jimmy saying,
wouldn't this be,
this could be someone's main source of entertainment.
Slash,
news and this we would be at their media and how would we be tricking them?
But what we're trying to do is we're actually trying to tell the truth,
like we're trying to get to the truth.
Uh,
usually what you see in the media,
it has an agenda behind it.
Keep talking this through.
I don't have an agenda.
I'm not making money off conspiracy
theory money.
You know what I mean?
There's no agenda here.
So conspiracy theorist,
no matter how,
and by the way,
the CIA created the word conspiracy theorist to demonize like people that are
against the establishment.
So that's not a conspiracy theory.
Can the word conspiracy theories to make people seem like tin hat foil,
tin foil,
hat wearing Wackos.
But anyways,
um,
you know,
when you look at the motive,
like what's the motive behind being a conspiracy theorist?
No matter how paranoid you are,
the most power,
noise,
worst case scenario type people when you,
you know,
some people are more paranoid than others and they jumped a more conclusions
than others.
But all conspiracy theorists,
they have one thing in common.
They're not trying to,
uh,
they're worried about their family,
their health,
you know,
even if it is paranoia,
maybe they go too far.
It's,
it's what's,
it's,
it's what's in the heart.
We're concerned about the people and what's going on and how we're being fooled
and where we're headed and where we're led and all this bullshit that's going on
in the world.
We're concerned with that.
The people on the other side,
they're not concerned with that at all.
The people in power are not concerned with the right thing.
They're concerned about one thing and one thing only.
Keeping as much power as they can for as long as possible.
And no matter what you see conspiracy.
I love it.
What are we talking about?
We're talking about like,
you know,
like I was,
I was at,
I was having a conversation,
I was having a conversation about Alex Jones with my,
my buddy,
right?
Dawson who thinks like,
he's like,
he's just too paranoid.
He just,
he just,
he's just too crazy.
Just says the craziest things out.
I'm like,
yes he does.
I know him personally.
Yes.
He may be a little more um,
concerned slash paranoid,
you know,
he may be,
but that's why he's Alex Jones is he,
he show paranoid about shit that he dedicated his life to try and to get
information out.
And some of it's wrong.
Some of it's right.
You know,
no conspiracy theorists Ha.
It's all theories based on mostly circumstantial evidence.
It's not like raw real evidence.
We're just saying,
wait a minute,
you've got you guys done this before and you've done this for forever and it
seems like it's happening again based on that.
And based on that and based on this,
uh,
yeah,
you guys are probably still doing this shit.
You know,
it's still the same criminals are look,
oh,
it's all good now.
Oh,
they used to do it after 50 years.
It's easy to prove a conspiracy theory.
What are we talking about exactly though?
We're talking about,
um,
we were talking about,
Oh,
Alex Jones,
Alex.
But it doesn't matter that he's so paranoid.
He doesn't have to be right about everything.
He's sometimes he's too paranoid,
but I'm talking about Alex Jones is his heart's in it.
I know one thing about Alex Jones is he's not a shill.
He's for real.
He maybe he stays away from certain subjects getting all,
maybe,
maybe he does,
but overall the message is,
uh,
is,
well,
he sir,
don't,
don't buy
into this game,
this game show that,
that were being fed.
Don't buy into that.
Yes.
And that's what's going on.
So I mean,
unless,
unless you're sitting me sitting here telling me,
you believe what you see when you see someone speaking and CNN,
do you think he would?
Do you think he believes everything he's saying?
W what does it match?
There's people on ESPN that there's no way they believe everything they show.
They used to be on ESPN,
I should say.
No Way.
They believe everything they're saying cause it's contradicts itself.
When looked at what do you mean guys in slack,
CNN broadcast on Espn,
just guys talking about sports will say something very salacious and two days
later say something that contradicts itself,
but they're just doing it because that's their job and they're paid to talk all
day long.
Of course.
And that turned into other people that like that are also paid.
The Alex Jones,
John Jones is completely independent.
Like I've known Alex literally for,
I hate literally,
but I've only known him since 99 and he's always been like this and he's been
doing it himself,
doing his radio show and do it now.
Is Internet show he's getting paid to do.
Yeah.
Honestly,
if that dude had a fucking insurance job,
he'd spill it.
Still be talking about this stuff.
He talks about this stuff.
You could be at a honky tonk bar to clock in the morning and it was the black
helicopters and the cattle mutilations are connected.
You can't have one without the guard that at all.
When you listen to him talk.
He did.
He's very,
he knows his shit.
He's not.
Sometimes he exaggerates on some shit like a y two k exaggerate on that.
A lot of people thought she was coming to an end.
We got a real one example.
Here's one example.
There was a problem though.
When you have a business of doom,
you're always looking for doom.
Like that's your business,
will they've,
you're selling doom,
you gotta look for doom.
It's not these not right a lot.
He's right about a lot of things.
Like he was right about a bunch of shit that no one ever thought about that.
Now we think of as,
because of Edward Snowden,
we think of just as a part of the problem that he was,
uh,
he was talking about worldwide surveillance of emails,
emails and text messages and he was talking about that all the Lori time actions
on the inside.
He's got sources did,
he won't reveal their name.
He's getting a lot of information.
It's proven right.
He knows that we're living in the goddamn matrix to,
if you believe the thing that Burns me the most is super smart people,
really smart,
and they just,
they know the people running shit are,
are controlling us.
They know this.
But when,
when it comes down to any topic they side with,
there were the criminals were that,
that burns me more than anything is you know that criminals,
you know they are,
but you're going to side with them.
You're going to believe them.
You don't criminals.
They have to prove everything.
Maybe some things they're saying are true,
but I'm not going to believe you.
And I'm like,
I don't believe Shit.
You say just like
some fucking liar that you know some dude at the comedy store,
some duty just lies about fucking everything.
You're not going to believe,
even though some shit he's telling you it might be true.
You're like,
you're going to have to prove all that shit cause you fucking lie about
everything you lie about where you're from.
You were never a wrestling champion.
You didn't fucking Oh no,
God Damn Harley,
you're a fucking liar.
Why am I going to believe anything you say?
That's what's going on.
So I think we should,
when it comes to conspiracy theories,
we should,
we should always be at least skeptical of the official story that may be true or
maybe not,
but I mean
was here right now and I'll put a tie on him and a bat Mr. Official story.
Now you guys can Duke it out.
Yeah.
We don't need to do that.
I just,
I sat enough just like come on.
People are done.
Question everything.
Yeah.
At a certain point in time we can't keep talking about this.
Uh,
what'd you think about um,
some other fights that were happening?
How bout trying steer this UFC fights.
Try to steer this away in this fucking conspiracy swamp that we keep falling
into.
Non nonproductive.
The problem with that is not opening people's minds.
It's not always right.
There's a lot of stuff that's getting,
trying to get everything right.
Yeah.
But it's a giant quagmire.
Like if you start chasing down whether or not the CA created Jim Morrison,
like that shit takes a lot of time and hours and hours of speculation and
thinking it's not worth it.
Just like very inner smoke,
a joint,
enjoy the music.
It's very entertaining.
You feel like it's like,
it's almost like an open ended puzzle that your plan
people are in the game of Thrones.
Totally.
It's not real at all.
It's a made up that story with all,
they get loud.
They wa I want some made up,
but they don't want to watch like a documentary,
like a conspiracy documentary.
They maybe,
maybe not true.
Maybe exaggerated,
but God damn,
it's really bit,
it's close to the truth and maybe it is true,
but no,
we ain't gonna Watch that.
We want to watch total fake shit.
I just want to make sure it's all thanks.
The
total fake shit.
At least like I don't feel stupid because I know that it's fake.
I'm enjoying something.
I'm not being watched conspiracy theories as it's it.
It's probably fake,
but who knows.
There may be.
There's a little too tight man.
Some of them are fun too.
You know.
My favorite one though was the one where the dude thought that there was rod's
flying around.
Oh,
turned out just the way camera's view can move faster.
Close that conspiracy theory didn't last at all.
That's,
that's proof.
The conspiracy.
There's what was rotten motherfuckers a little drop one.
Drop it hot dude.
It was drop.
No,
cause they're stuck with that.
It was a weird thing we saw there was nobody wasn't dropped.
That guy came to one of my fucking Q and A's and they believe that.
See people still believe that his,
the guy who made the documentary,
I think his name is Jose Escamia.
No gentlemen is a fine gentleman.
This is not a bad man at all.
But he came to one of the UFT,
see things and he waited in line to ask me a question and he yelled it out.
The products that
I have done,
documentaries,
you have city of
that monster quest show is what fucked him up.
Did you know that?
Yeah.
It was that monster quest show that show that they were doing for the history
channel with the monsters?
No,
this is what happened.
Monster Quest did an experiment on one side,
they used a high speed camera that does like like very high rates of frame a
frame rates and he could film like slow motion shit.
So you see like every pixel it looks perfect.
You know they do that with those slow mo cameras.
They could film at a very high rate of speed,
like really calm kin next to it and then next to it was a shitty camera and the
shitty camera couldn't capture a quick enough so everything got elongated.
So the image got blurred and elongated and it looks like tubes.
We're flying through the sky,
but two cameras side by side captured completely different things.
One of them captured super obvious bugs.
He gets slowed down in slow motion.
You can see there are bugs and then it would literally cross over into the other
camera and turn into this tube because it was just moving too quick.
So it's an artifact.
It's what's called a,
that was a conspiracy theory that lasts.
That was hot for about maybe three years,
and then we even we even,
we were in debt.
I didn't really get high
shit.
There's fucking aliens flying around everywhere.
We thought those were aliens.
They were alive.
They were like,
if these things,
they're invisible snakes.
I remember we were convinced that God,
there was no Twitter back then.
They would've,
they would've kept bringing that shit up.
So that's proof that if we get debunked proof,
they were not like married to it.
I'm not married to that,
but
dude,
you can't see with your eyes it and you need a video cam to see,
whoa.
We were thinking that like science hadn't discovered and then the web,
but then you don't want one time we were like,
where are the dead ones?
Where's all the dead ones?
Lion Fish live forever.
What if it's real?
I'm going to go,
I'm going to live rods.
Maybe.
Maybe that monstrous thing was bullshit.
I don't think so.
I'm pretty sure it's going to be a rod guy.
But you imagine if you're the poor dude who made that documentary and you've got
all this money invested in those rods.
I never hear anybody talking about raw.
No,
they're done.
Someone did come up to me and say,
Hey,
uh,
if you heard that conspiracy theory where there's no forests,
have you heard about this?
There's a conspiracy theory where there's no chorus.
Look into it.
No,
no forest.
I bet you love these things.
I'm like,
I don't know what that is.
Really.
I didn't even look,
I watched 30 seconds cause someone in class told me Ziggy came across hip.
You're at that conspiracy theory about Noah.
I go,
what?
Cause I went home and I put no forest and I was 13 seconds.
I just stopped it.
Have you seen the one with this due to the dinosaurs aren't real and we've seen
that one that I don't,
that I don't know.
I don't know.
That's like some other shit where I'm like,
I don't believe any science.
I don't believe in the early science.
I believe it is.
You Rub two sticks together.
There's fire.
Other than that,
you've got to prove that shit.
I'm going to ignore that shit.
All you gotta just tobacco science.
What about that,
that you think that Shit's gone?
You think tobacco science has gone stronger than ever?
That's the one of the weirdest thing was tobacco science.
Things that politicians don't talk about.
If you really stop and think about all the threats they talk about to this
country and the people in our health,
and they'll even discuss drugs,
but how alcohol kills way more people than illegal drugs and for sure cigarettes
kill way more people than alcohol.
And so you'll occasionally hear a politician discuss underage drinking or
drinking and driving,
but will they ever discuss abstinence like [inaudible] and professing their hope
for abstinence?
No fucking way.
You mean one alcohol from alcohol.
Okay.
If they never got to propose that right there.
Definitely never going to talk about cigarettes.
Cigarettes is their dirty friend that murders the giant elephant in the fucking
sky.
They got a dirty friend that kills 500,000 people.
A clear example of why you should be a conspiracy theory.
That is absolutely fascinating conspiracy.
That's a fascinating space and no one says shit in your face.
No one,
no one even talks about it.
Nobody talks about it.
You know what?
Anytime I'm on board with know there's gotta be some money in there.
So
Miss,
this is me guessing.
I know this.
I know that sometimes greed,
greed will actually result in something beneficial to mankind.
Sometimes it does.
In one instance,
a seatbelt laws,
seatbelt laws.
It looks like government was trying to take care of us and they really were
concerned with our health.
But when you looked into the seat belt law and the helmet law for motorcycles in
California,
it was the insurance company's paying for all that,
uh,
the bill because they thought it was cheaper.
You know what if you didn't have,
if you got an accident and you weren't wearing your seatbelt,
you,
if you'd turned into a vegetable,
you're expensive.
All those accidents with no seat belts were costing these insurance companies
Kazillions.
So it was better to make them wear seat belts then it wasn't as expensive to pay
for these bills.
They don't wait.
They don't have as many as many vegetable bills and shit.
Overall,
it makes sense so that when you find that out,
I'm just guessing here,
when you see those tobacco commercials where the,
I've seen the latest tobacco commercial with some,
some African American girl who's like,
she's wrapping poetry,
no music,
and it's all like being super ultra street.
She's in an alley.
She's like,
you know,
I don't,
all I do is just go out there and do my thing.
I ain't going to smoke.
I'm going to do that.
Dang.
You know,
just talk stupid rat.
Not Stupid rap,
but just,
I picked that back.
It was amazing rap.
It was amazing work,
but it was all about not smoking.
I'm cool.
I'm not going to smoke.
I'm a,
I'm in the street.
Yo.
I'm just guessing.
I bet if you look into that,
it's the same thing.
I bet the insurance companies have figured out that uh,
uh,
diseases from smoking are expensive as fuck.
We got to stop this.
This is crushing us.
That's me guessing.
I don't know.
But do they really care if we smoke pot?
No.
Why is this on and must be some,
you must be able to follow the money.
That's me guessing,
but of course I'm wrong.
Well,
there's definitely,
yeah,
billions of dollars in cigarettes.
I think about people,
they buy so many cigarettes over the world to shut that business down.
You've got a real problem.
I mean,
there's a lot of people invested in that business is distribution companies.
There's people that make those things.
There's people that like those things and he'd get to get them the dark market.
They're going to figure out a way how to get them the dark market,
the black market,
but you can't make things illegal because you can't tell people what they can
and can't do.
If somebody wants to smoke cigarettes,
they should be allowed to,
but it's just real weird that the government professes to care about us,
but doesn't bring up this one thing that kills a half a million people every
year in this country alone.
Millions,
millions worldwide.
One cool thing that that was another law,
the cigarette law where you couldn't smoke inside.
That was one of those fucking laws.
It was beneficial for humanity.
Right.
But was rooted in mining.
Somehow it just,
it just turned out that it was actually a good thing for us.
Helmets are good thing.
Seatbelts are great thing.
You don't want people like,
ah,
people who,
people that say,
I don't want the government telling me I have to put a seatbelt on.
If I didn't want to wear a seatbelt,
I go,
dude,
if you don't wear a seatbelt,
you get an accident.
He turned into a vegetable,
you're fucking,
you're going to have people that you love that I'd have to wipe your ass.
You want to put them,
put a fucking seatbelt on so then I have to wipe your ass dude.
You know what I mean?
Take care of yourself.
Yeah.
You know what I'm talking about?
No,
definitely.
So safer to wear a seatbelt for sure.
It's safer to have a very big sturdy car.
There's a lot of safers most likely.
But uh,
yeah,
it's,
um,
it's weird
because I'm a believer that people should have personal freedom.
You should be able to do whatever you want.
But I think that when it comes to like young kids,
they're too likely to do stupid shit if you allow them to and cars.
It's a,
it's a one mistake,
stupid shit and you're fucked up for life.
It's not worth it.
We should enforce it in any way we can,
but that's sort of the same way I feel about cigarettes.
Like we should kind of figure out how to enforce that.
Like that's not a smart thing to get involved with.
Would you be opposed to a law that made it illegal?
Seriously illegal?
No,
no,
no.
There's something else,
uh,
illegal to be paid to paint all day to go out and,
and,
uh,
us,
spew propaganda on a certain subject.
You,
would you vote on a law?
Would you pass a law to make that illegal?
I'm confused.
To be illegal,
to pay someone to get
to lie on it should be,
I should be illegal.
Right.
Especially if it's a government that save a lot of things.
Anybody.
If it was a serious crime to get paid to get online and spew propaganda,
I think everybody would say,
yeah,
that would,
that should be really illegal.
It should be really illegal for a company to pay someone,
so if you were going to do that,
that'd be some underground black market shit.
We're going to give you an envelope with fucking $2,000 we need to get shit in
the fucking,
here's the online,
you've got to Ip address,
you got to run.
You know what I mean?
That's gotta be super illegal to do that.
Right.
Okay.
I think it's too easy because everyone's talking about,
oh,
the internet,
there's so much information out there.
We can find the truth,
but also it works against you.
Yes,
you can find the truth,
but you could also get strategically flooded with misinformation strategically,
and that's a companies are doing,
they will strategically hire people to sway opinion and then and then and then
put it under science daily.com or science,
whatever.com
that's been confirmed that that's been done with climate climate change.
You seen that documentary?
Merchants of doubt.
It's really interesting.
It's about a bunch of guys who get paid and it coincidentally,
this two subjects are actually connected.
They used to get paid for going on.
These talk shows and disputing the fact that cigarettes are addictive and that
cigarettes caused health problems.
He would dispute these things.
How many shows that they were doing it in like the seventies and the eighties
tobacco science.
Yeah,
and so then these guys from then then went to climate change later in life.
The same people are trying to debunk climate change and they have these,
these things where they'll,
they'll show the same people that were involved in trying to debunk cigarettes
causing cancer and being addictive.
The same exact people were trying to say climate change is just a cycle.
It just the way it is.
It's always going to be this way.
Do you,
do you,
do you think that is a,
a sign that something fishy is going on?
Oh,
for sure.
Of course.
What?
That's like basic detective shit.
Well,
and they're using these,
what's going on,
Jamie?
You guys are talking about this.
I just Google it.
Put the propaganda ban being lifted.
Oh,
I thought you were talking about Mickey Rourke.
No,
no,
no.
Make your work plan on two screens here.
And he's screaming at people and they keep showing me who wrote this article.
That's Mickey Rourke.
Have you seen him lately?
Oh Shit.
He's uh,
he's gotten very weird congressman seek to lift propaganda ban happened in the
NDA,
but Michael Hastings is the one that was right.
Oh my God.
Propaganda was supposed to target.
Foreigners can now be aimed at Americans reversing a longstanding,
something,
something.
Can you scroll up?
It's okay.
What you said about it.
Oh my God.
It's called the Smith modernization.
The new,
what would give the new law would give sweeping powers to State Department and
Pentagon is pushed television,
radio,
newspaper,
and social media onto the US public.
It removes the protection for Americans.
Has a Pentagon official,
uh,
who is concerned about the law.
It removes oversight from the people who want to put out this information.
There no checks and balances.
No one knows if the information is accurate or partially accurate or entirely
false.
That's so crazy.
That is so fucking crazy that they just try to make bills where they will out
and out lie about things.
So that's your strategy for dealing with terror is to create a feeling of total
imbalance in this country.
Like whether or not it's effective or not.
Like as far as a long term strategy for freedom,
it's one of the worst ideas ever to say.
We as your elders,
your daddy and mommy of the government.
We're going to look over you and we're going to tell you about Santa Claus and
the Easter bunny and we're going to just,
we're just gonna make shit up.
We're going to make shit up for it all up and we think we should be able to
because we know better than you because,
uh,
we were elected allegedly.
That's what's gone well,
we have the information that he brought up.
Science daily.com.
Shit.
If you look at that,
they got the truth there.
That's it's right there.
It's a science.
Did you see what happened with um,
that fucking doctor drew show?
Dr Drew talked the other day about Hillary Clinton having a brain injury.
He talked about it on TV and what her brain injury was and how dangerous it was,
what she was taking.
And he didn't agree with her treatment and they canceled his fucking show.
Canceled his fucking show.
Doctor drew.
So canceled days after host gives negative speculation about Hillary Clinton's
health.
Are you shocked or something?
Dude,
I'm dying all the time.
Did you know insane?
Like this is some wide open.
Yeah.
Did you know how many astronauts died in 1968.
Two,
eight
and then two more in 69.
What happened when they are doing fine in this space?
Accidents.
Did you imagine again guys,
these are guys that were going,
Whoa,
what?
What did we practice?
They're like taking them through the drills going,
wait a minute.
Do you think,
remember the guy hung the lemon?
You know all about that shit.
Yeah.
Eight fucking died in 1968.
Eight 11 total.
11 as astronauts dead three in the fire that uh,
that happened in the capsule during testing and then a car racks up a random
plane.
Accidents.
All guys that were saying,
we are not going to the God damn moon.
I,
I understand what you're saying,
but uh,
as a voice of reason or as a skeptical voice,
um,
I would like to know,
I'm not saying one way or the other,
but I would like to know what the numbers for astronauts normally are and dying
and test pilot and rockets and shit.
That's a good question.
I mean,
I'm not saying that they didn't,
that dude's family still believes they whacked him.
That dude from the guy who will hung the loo,
the lemon on there,
the
lamb,
what the fuck was that name?
One inspector,
the NASA inspector that was going to tell the,
testified in front of a,
some congress and said,
listen,
this is,
we're not going anywhere.
He got suicidal.
He parked his train on a track with his family or parked his car and a train
track with his family on it.
Not that that guy's,
that doesn't seem fishy.
Do Push.
I can push.
It does,
I think fishing to everybody.
Like,
wait a minute.
I pushed a lot of that stuff just out of my head.
I'm like,
I don't even want to deal with it anymore because it was so frustrating.
Yeah.
The uh,
a lot of the,
uh,
that's what's going on right now.
Jeff K stuff go over the jail
k stuff and it makes you a real life game.
The game of Thrones that's makes your head,
there's so many characters and JFK,
there's so many holy shit.
It's like all the mob guys that were involved and all of the government,
the way it was all went down and all the,
there's so much shit.
What's that takes forever.
Can I find this eight astronauts dying in 1968?
I didn't look it up.
We're just real quick from the,
the man.
Three of the three of them died in a fire and [inaudible] 67 who was the guy who
hung the lunar limb on the lunar module?
Grissom.
Yeah.
Gus Grissom.
You hang on.
No,
they all knew.
They were,
remember the name of the inspectors.
They knew they weren't going,
I don't remember the name of the inspector.
I'm surprised about my,
I used to be able to recite that shit,
but look into him too.
They killed him.
He was,
he was testifying.
He goes,
what are we doing here and get home and it caught,
I think it costs $30 billion or something to adjust it.
I think that's adjusted to American dollars.
Yeah,
like the fence.
Like here's another example.
Like the fence,
the fence,
they,
congressmen lobbied for it.
I don't know exactly how it got passed,
but they got paid,
uh,
like $3 billion to build that fence.
The fence that separates Mexico from the United States all the way across the
south west.
They never finished it.
They got paid for everything.
It's so not finished.
It's like half finished.
It's abandoned it.
You know what that was?
It was a money grab.
It's simple political.
We,
we create all this funding for something and then fucking Skimm pay for some of
it,
but then if it falls apart,
no one even keeps track of it.
There's a documentary called the fence will blow your fucking mind.
They never finished that.
They abandoned it.
It's deserted.
Mexican dudes are going,
what are these Americans doing?
They're interviewing Mexicans that are just like,
this is easy.
It's,
it's ridiculous.
But that's what it is.
Like anytime they put a satellite into space,
fucking $35 million,
they go,
we need a sound.
Like the more telecommunications,
they fucking launched some shit.
Who knows what that satellites doing?
They got paid.
They do it all the Goddamn time.
It's a scam.
It's a mom with you Alex
again.
I lose you when we went from Mexicans getting into the cross the border,
no fun.
You're talking about Scott in the satellites.
It's all a scam.
Okay,
but the,
the Mexican one?
Yeah.
Why didn't they finish that?
How much money do they need to finish that fence?
But the problem and they dig holes,
even if you finish the fence,
they never,
they could have,
but they never even finished.
They just go around them.
They fill areas that the documentary is like,
they show Mexico around the fence.
How much,
how much fences left.
They leave behind.
I don't know enough not to have enough until I've made what they put up a
complete waste.
Alright,
well that's when Trump gets into office to fence is going to get 10 yeah,
10 foot higher.
Did you see that?
Uh,
the New York Times thing through P,
they're coming after him today.
They're talking about racial bias and like renting houses and stuff,
renting property.
Pretty
crazy.
He's so close to being the president of United States.
You don't think so.
Hundred percent.
And he's like,
what if he does he know when it's so,
it's so obvious it's Hillary's going to win,
dude.
100% I think so 100% it's so obvious what Trump,
Trump's just there to say whatever.
He's super smart and he just says whatever he says,
whatever it takes to win a certain debate.
And he just goes up.
They're letting them go off.
They're just like,
they said,
go off.
Get crazy.
So now the former head of the CIA,
there's a,
there's a video where it says a c had a CIA denounced as Hillary and Trump.
Really?
He's denouncing Trump.
He's crucified Trump.
And when they ask about Hillary,
he says,
uh,
you know,
I got a lot of issues with Hillary,
but you know,
she,
she was better than Trump.
And in a lot of ways she's better than Obama too,
but I got my issues with Hillary.
But Trump,
that dude,
so really,
he's the head of the CIA is bearing Trump.
They want Hillary to win really,
really mad.
And if they want Hillary to win,
trust me,
Hillary's going to win.
That's all
devil's advocate and conspiracy theorists at the same time,
if he did win,
they should be fucking terrified because if Donald Trump actually does win and
gets into office and actually gets to explode,
he's a loose cannon.
He's not playing by their fucking rules.
If they pull him aside and tell him him some crazy shit about Afghanistan or
Rwanda or Africa,
well,
whatever it is about the world,
who knows what protocol he's going to follow this as far as how he decides to
react to that information.
Who knows what government organizations,
he's going to try to disband who?
He's a wild man.
He might slash and burn
the way Hillary won California.
This is just me,
just,
I don't know shit,
but this is my guest.
The way she won,
uh,
in California and the way,
remember George W.
Bush won in Florida.
I remember that one going the way they did whatever was involved in that shit is
going to be involved in the main shit this year and Hillary's going to win.
That's my opinion.
That's what that thought was right.
Well,
you might be right.
You know what,
man,
it's just weird that this is all the Republicans have and it's weird that this
is all the demo,
right?
Grads hat.
I think it's just,
it's just the way I think that's the way they planned it.
No,
I don't though.
I don't think there's very many people who,
um,
want to be a president anyway.
I think Trump is on their side and he's playing along.
He's doing that.
He's just being obnoxious and being crazy and then no one's going to be sad when
he loads.
It was,
no one's going to be sad.
The worst theory in the world.
Yeah.
Crooked Hillary.
I love it.
How he comes up with names to them like Lion Ted,
letting them go off cause he seems legit cause they know it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
He's going down there and there's no way he's going win.
Jamie,
call this transy sports.
It's just the fuck
out of me.
These gentlemen are getting into trouble and they're causing ruckuses and it's
uh,
they,
they know how to like keep you paying attention to that shit.
Those TMZ sports shows,
it's just smashed.
Got Smashed Gut.
Why is she crying?
Limb.
Okay.
Door open,
black and white.
Well,
TMJ
girls grabbing hand the recipe.
I need to pick a shot of a girl throwing a drink in a guy's face.
It's like hypnosis though,
man.
Like you get stuck.
Like I'm talking and I'm watching all this go on in the background.
I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What's happening back there?
It's funny how you
get a,
like you were talking,
you were the one who explained that to me once the first time about music videos
that music videos have to be like smash cuts.
You've got to go from one scene to the next scene.
The next scene to the next split second,
fourth.
You can't have anything play on for a long time.
People just stop paying attention.
Yeah.
And the more,
the less continuity,
the better.
The only reason they,
they keep going back to certain sets because they only could afford seven sets.
But really the ultimate video would be you never go,
you use every set,
just one shot.
That would be the ultimate,
but you've got to have seven.
And he threw it to three minute video shit.
We got to hit that set like maybe six times each.
You know what I mean?
So,
uh,
that's how the videos are just uh,
just we got to bombard you with shit to,
and it goes,
everything's cut to the music nice and fast.
And there was a lot of bands got cars,
real visual.
Dude's driving in cars.
You got to have a video and you somewhat disagree or driving.
You know what I mean?
DMX has a video of him driving the ultimate video of him driving it.
It's like some weird sin city type special effects.
I forget what song it is.
Fuck what?
It's so good.
God down.
Do you ever seen the one where uh,
the best,
uh,
one of the best gifs animated gifs of all time is um,
um,
50 cent sitting in a,
a drop top Bentley and uh,
he like throws his head back and laughed and drives off.
He's in this like super dope.
Probably like how much does it drop top Bentley like $400,000 or something
crazy.
It must be something crazy,
right?
You would not,
I would say 158,
he pulls up,
this guy's like a dope car and here 57 pulls up to him and looks at him.
Oh,
it's the dude from,
it's the turtle guy from entourage.
It looks,
so
I pulled up next to 50 cent once he had a driver behind them,
like trying to cut me off to make sure to protect them.
He was dropped by the convertible just like that while I was filming the DVD,
mastering the rubber car.
Why would,
this is like 10 years ago,
why were we were driving around and dude's filming me as I'm driving and I'm
talking about Jujitsu and we pull up and we're like,
there's 50 cents.
It was crazy.
Cars are so crazy.
Remember when you saw them like I was on the front of the front of the comedy
store ones and a Bugatti VA.
Ron drove up and I was,
are you ever seen one of those?
It's worth though.
It's more than a million dollars.
Only in that video I,
I woke up in
a new boo,
got a pull him.
I woke up in a new move out.
That's a great song by the way.
Ace Hood and he's Hood Shit.
That's a great,
that's the only time I've ever seen a Bugatti.
How much do they cost?
It's over 1 million bucks.
Oh Shit.
How much it costs and woke up in a boot Gotti.
That's the name of the,
that's the chorus.
It's the craziest car ever.
It's like,
you know what it's like the inside of it.
It's the inside of it is like some sort of a time machine.
Some Fewster of sick time machine.
It doesn't even seem like a real car when you're inside it.
When you see like the interior and the way it's all constructed,
it's all handmade with these crazy gauges and just beautiful leathers,
but it doesn't look like any other modern car.
It looks like something like someone from the Hg wells days who was trying to
draw like a future supercar.
You would draw some weird,
we've got Eva Ron type spaceship thing.
It's very interesting.
It's very much its own kind of car,
but it's stupid expensive and insanely fast.
I think it has more than a thousand horsepower,
which is just as faster than a motorcycle and 1200 horsepower.
What's the in sand right now with the motorcycle?
Zero to 60 and what?
They just disappear.
They just vanish.
Travel through time.
Record two seconds.
It's probably less than that.
Once.
Zero to 60 in one second.
Yeah.
Dude,
they have these cars now that are doing it in less than three like regular cars.
You can go and buy at the store.
No.
Well,
I think the Tesla does it very quickly.
What's the lettuce with that?
They've got some new shit coming up fast as a Tesla goes zero to 60 I was
thinking about the,
uh,
I heard about the Porsche nine 11 turbo s I think it does it in 2.8 seconds.
Zero to six.
Does it ever get to one?
Does that happen?
Yeah.
If it got as far as it got,
he's going to get to that.
It's going to get to one,
but there's gotta be a lot of g force in that jets.
That's not,
that's not an easy thing to model.
S can do it in 2.5 Jesus,
that's a nine 11 not Tesla.
Oh,
Tesla s 2.5 2.5 is that faster than a motorcycle?
I don't think so.
I think a motorcycle could still do it and the tuition range if I had entirely
an electric car.
That looks cool.
How about the drives itself?
How does that work?
It's,
it has the cameras.
It's reading the ground and the,
the,
the distance around it.
That's faster than a lot of motorcycles on this list.
Is it really?
What about later high Bussa perilla is on.
Hi Bruce is a motorcycle
was shit.
I thought that was just a great uh,
NMA apparel.
It is great MMA apparel,
but it's also a bird.
A very fast bird gets fast.
What's the fastest bird ever?
I think it's the pair of Jean Falcon.
I think there's a falcon that goes like 200 miles an hour.
I did a commercial for them once where I was,
I was like for the Falcons for Hyatt Bussa.
Oh,
what do you got here Jamie?
Is that it?
The fastest bird in the world.
242 miles an hour.
Which of course down fast risperidone
or what it does is it looks for a critter to Jack and when it's flying around it
finds one that who wants to fuck with and then it died dive bombs and just
achieves insane speed.
I guess it like just flaps its wings willy quick.
It's hard to the perspective,
it's like you'd see a video on it,
but it's hard to like grasp how fast it's actually moving.
It doesn't seem to make sense when you're looking at it.
It just looks like it's going fast.
You don't have any perspective,
not on the ground,
but if like flew by you when you're on the ground,
you're probably like,
what the fuck?
It's a rod.
Like that's faster than any car I've ever seen.
Like what's a fast car?
250 miles an hour.
It's got to be like what those Nascar guys do,
right?
I don't even think there you go that fast.
That's like a formula one speed.
Right?
How fast is Nascar go?
One 80 Eddie Bravo.
Hate standards.
That's one thing me and Eddie Brown would just not have in common.
Oh,
standard manual stick shift cars.
It's 2016 st the Flintstones.
I love them.
I buy certain cars that are older just because they have stick shifts.
I like that they're there.
It's engaging but you you like associated with man,
I want to have to shift these fuckers.
I just want to tell her,
listen to music.
I don't have to fucking shift gears the same to forget it.
You must be
nothing wrong with thinking that way,
man.
For me.
You should get an engine with the fucking front crank.
No,
that would be the coolest shit out when I like,
I like to start my booking engine man manually.
There's a zen
state that you achieve when you shifting through the gears yourself and you're,
you're revving the engine up to a certain point and you're all tuned in to the
action of the car.
Whereas a lot of people and those kinds of cars,
they don't even listen to music.
The music becomes like them.
The mechanics of the vehicle,
the engineering,
the way the tires grip the road,
you feel it in your ass.
He shifted gears and you lift up the clutch and he give it the gas.
Then you hear the Warhol Wall and you become an tuned with the machine and you
start feeling where the machines going.
And it becomes more of like a,
an exercise and stimulation than it does just drive it.
But I like driving too.
Like I like driving in a fucking a big suburban.
Like I rented a suburban this past weekend.
Dude,
you ever drive one of them big cushy ass fucking boats?
No,
but I saw like this bro is driving.
Did it have its own builtin vacuum?
Like I saw minivan,
the new fucking luminaire or something has its own that what a great idea.
Right?
Kids.
Shit.
Super Smart.
That's actually wicked smart.
Yeah,
no,
they um,
this uh,
those suburbans they're like a,
they have that Cadillac escalades Cadillac escalades suspension,
but it's just cheaper.
Trim doesn't look as fancy,
but it's a nice car or renting one of those man,
they drive so comfortable.
They're so relaxed.
Just like the way it go over bumps.
Shit I cars of today are so God damn good.
Like if you had like I was thinking when I was driving this suburban,
it's like a 2016 suburban.
I was like,
if you got an a 1950s Mercedes and you'll like,
this is the shit right now,
this is as good as it gets.
And you've gotten a senior like wow,
leather seats.
Oh real would handle.
You know,
you'd be driving this thing around.
Thinking is incredible.
I got the top of the line Mercedes man.
And then someone shoots you to 2016 and puts you in a regular family truck,
like a suburban,
which is just this big huge ass hunk of metal and dude,
it floats over the road.
It has this feeling when he hit the brakes,
like it's just engineered to stop quickly for this big fucking tank.
He was gigantic.
It handles good for big,
gigantic thing.
It's like comfortable to drive.
Yet it doesn't look that different than the cars from the 60s like if the cut
the shape,
they got tires.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Generally it the biggest thing a guy would trip on that's he got jumped on a
time machine from the sixties to now wouldn't be the car so much as I still
fucking tires.
You guys aren't flying yet.
It's still round that the four tires you go,
you still have four.
They would trip out on the phones more than the cars.
The phones.
It'd be like,
what the fuck?
We're connected with the world.
This is our connection to everybody.
It's fine.
There's some shit that's just too risky.
Like air balloons.
They never fucking got that shit perfected.
Nobody to hill when he was ever going,
hey,
he here.
You know with air balloons,
there's no fresh shower.
Bob,
he just started the fire,
fill up the balloon,
fly home.
It's no big deal.
They're like,
well,
it's not that accurate today,
but hey,
you use the exercise,
you walk a few miles from your home,
you,
you land your balloon as close as you can to your home and then you were hung
just floating through the sky and the air.
No Way.
People like,
fuck man,
you got to get that down.
But there's no funding to get it down because nobody's buying any fucking hot
air balloons.
And every now and then,
like there's a big accident in Texas,
like really recently in Texas in an air balloon.
Yeah.
It caught fire and everybody died and it was a quite a few people,
I don't remember what the,
what the actual number was,
but I want to say it was something like,
it might've been like seven people or something.
Died wouldn't for more.
Jamie wouldn't,
the core team was at 1416 Google.
Oh my God,
that's awful.
Wouldn't the coolest thing to do really as a huge,
don't you put up a video,
Jamie?
Don't you put that fucking evil?
I mean,
he's reaching for the video button.
Don't fucking do it,
man.
I want to watch that flaming ball fall to the ground.
What?
What would be cooler than hand gliding as a hobby?
I think about that.
Hang gliding to me.
US,
Gracie.
Super dangerous bowls,
right holes.
Gracie.
The time.
The time is that yet you did it and you didn't die.
How cool would that be?
It kill coolest shit ever,
right?
You're flying through the fucking air.
No engine.
You're gliding.
Some guys stay up forever and they find these little hot Tom.
I mean,
it's so dangerous,
but is it cooler than those wingsuits I the wingsuits might be
doper.
I think you fly more when you're gliding.
You feel like you're flying in the wind current.
Yeah,
you're,
you're dipping down.
It seems like you're fine falling and you're falling,
but your la,
it takes a long time to fall as opposed to staying up and actually flying and
blessed mother fucker.
He's got a jet.
What's that?
You're attached to one.
Let's see that shit pack flying wing suit available done by your bed.
By herself.
Yeah.
Jet Packs.
Jet Pack will soon be available to buy one for yourself anytime you want jetpack
flying suit.
People are going to fucking suicide bomb right into airplane.
[inaudible] girlfriend's going to be flying across the country.
Go flux
flight patterns right out of Burbank Police Shit.
They're gonna get dropped out of a plane and then just going to fly right into
13 c they've got to time it perfectly.
Look at this shit.
She's gonna get an aisle seat.
You Bitch,
dude.
It's going to be in his foot.
He's on a foam glider and next to her the plane.
God Damn,
I think they just flew.
A plane went real slow,
but I went all the way around the world on solar power.
It's like 12 miles an hour.
It was Whoa,
super,
super slow.
Took like a month,
but that must have sucked.
How'd they get food?
They just slowly stayed up there with food.
How much shit do you think you left up there?
How many times do you shit if you're,
if you're going,
it's being done.
If you're,
if you're going all the way around the world like that and you don't have time
to land to take a shit,
how much shit do actually drop off in that airport?
This shit hole in your and your outfit.
Here's the thing,
you don't have to worry about the plane getting heavier because it's not like
you're eating the food and then you're shedding.
The weight stays consistent.
Like Mass on an airplane is in a static state,
like mass on an airplane never decreases or increases unless they drop shit out
of the plane.
Solar mplus impulse to approaches.
Abu Dhabi.
Huh?
Wow.
So he really did.
So he had stages.
Okay.
Which makes sense.
Last stop.
So he's doing it like stop at a top domains had solar panels.
Is that what it was?
Powered by solar power.
You're saying you're going to get solar panels now?
Yeah.
When you,
when you do a,
when you put solar panels on your house,
do you get off the grid and now you can get off the grid can?
Yes,
but most people,
most people don't know g to the city.
Most people the most,
the easiest way for you to do it is you don't,
you're not independent.
You're still connected to the grid.
Like you can develop your own power.
Yeah.
Not only that,
you've got to talk to Brian,
count about this.
Cause Brian Cowen,
it was the first of us to do it and he experienced a lot of bullshit,
a lot of paperwork.
Do you have to go through a lot of red tape?
They make it very difficult for you to get off the grid.
It's really interesting.
Can just put solar panels.
No,
no.
And very,
uh,
yeah,
he,
he had to go through a long process before they let his equipment go live.
It's all really interesting man.
But in their defense,
here's,
here's like,
I gotta do this.
I hate do this people,
but I got
to do this.
Oh Shit.
Um,
I don't know who's installing this electrical stuff and we live in fucking
California where fires happen all the God damn time.
So I don't necessarily think it's totally reasonable that someone doesn't look
at the wiring.
And make sure if you're doing something completely radical,
like getting off the grid and starting a,
an independent power source,
you've got to connect to this house.
Let's just make sure that you have your credentials in place.
Let's just make sure that everything was done according to Code says fucking
houses and blow up and you don't burn to death in your sleep.
You know,
cause like these fires that people are having,
they're not controlling these goddamn things too good.
There's no water man.
Everyone,
we'll where we live when we look around and you look around at the hills,
like go drive up Topanga Canyon and look at all those hills.
Go drive,
you know,
over,
I'll pass the one 18 and stall.
Hey,
so when that crazy shit like have like if you talk to Michael Jai White,
nope.
You know he lives out there where a that bit last big fire hit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That was uh,
I was concerned.
I need to get ahold of that dude.
He was at Bella tour.
Not Concerned that he's hurt,
but concerned that maybe he,
his house was one of the many houses.
I guess he'd probably would have heard about it in the news,
but a lot of people lost houses up there,
man.
A lot of people lost houses.
And then San Bernardino out where a hobbyists and that area,
they had a gigantic fire up there.
Huge one.
They had one up near Lake Arrowhead,
like up away from Lake Arrowhead.
They had one,
they've had a few of these fucking things.
The giant one in,
um,
uh,
San Bernardino or not a Santa Barbara Rather.
Did you see that one?
But why would you get solar panels when you give the,
why would you get solar panels to give the power to?
Because it's more because it's more expensive to set up an independent system.
So most people get to a point where they realize,
oh,
this is good,
so I don't have to pay for power anymore.
Eventually my solar power will pay for itself.
And you,
if you have excess power,
you could sell that power back to the city.
But this is the question.
Hmm,
why would the city give a fuck?
Oh my God,
this guy has a house with solar panels.
You know,
let's try to get some of his power that he's collecting.
Don't get old.
He's that central power.
I don't know if it's that simple.
Why would that even come up?
Like because solar panels to give you the power,
that doesn't make any sense.
How would that come up?
Well,
let me explain.
As far as I think I know it,
the way the grid works,
you know the,
these power stations,
they contribute to the grid.
Um,
there's,
there are instances sometimes where there's not enough power,
right?
Like in the summertime where everybody's fucking acs going on and things below.
Remember those brownouts that went out where they shut off the power for
different places.
You remember that?
I think what happens is the way the grid is set up,
and I'm fucking completely guessing here,
but I would guess that if all the power is connected,
if there is a grid,
that there's more than one contributing factor,
there's more than one contributing factor in powering the grid.
There's probably a power plant.
It was probably more than one thing.
It's probably,
it's probably a system of different power plants that that power the grid and
it's possible.
This is total guessing,
but if you figure out how to make what's essentially a solar powered generator,
I mean you're,
you're,
someone's connecting a solar,
extracting a device that's generating electricity and you have an excess of it.
They could probably use it.
It's not,
I don't,
I don't know if it's that difficult.
I don't know.
How come they're not interested in any of the power produced by a gas generators
that people have in their house.
They don't give a shit about that.
Well,
gas generators,
first of all,
they have to constantly be restocked with gas.
Solar is relying on constant power that's around all the time.
And gas generators are used are a lot of rural people for backups.
Like I know a lady who lives in the mountains and she's got a set up where if
our power goes out,
there's a little switch that goes off in instantaneously.
She has a propane tank,
a giant ass propane tank that's like as big as this fucking room and it kicks
in.
And that starts powering the her heat cause she lives in the,
in the,
in the mountains.
I wonder why city cause this a conspiracy again.
No,
I'm,
I'm just,
I'd never heard of any,
well the solar,
is there a solar panel conspiracy?
I don't know.
It just,
it does vary work batteries.
It's just very strange that
that would even come up solar panels for your house to give the energy to only
give what you're not using.
It's like,
yeah,
absolutely.
Like you're not doing it like you're farming electricity specifically for the
city and your people attending.
I think that is the way it is.
Well you're using the power and some of it you sell back to the city,
but you're using the power.
Okay.
That's going to be your source of power.
Positive.
Cause I,
I pretty sure wrong,
I could be wrong,
but it could be that somebody could make it as a follower.
They're going to give you the power of the all hooked up with w we're going to
give you the three electricity and then we're going to pay you a little extra,
collect us shit.
Boom.
We want that solar shit and we'll give you whatever for this process.
Don't you think there's going to be solar farms if it's profitable for you?
Because then you could just keep your plugs.
You don't have to replug everything.
Just give us all that.
If you don't replug anything,
you don't change anything.
What does it say?
The Sun shines on solar panels generated by DC electricity.
The DC electricity is fed into a solar inverter converts at 240 volts.
50 Hertz,
a 240 volt ac electricity is used to power the appliances in your home.
Certain posts,
electricity is fed back into the main grid.
There you go.
Trample because this is like,
it's like a renewable resource.
It's a constant resource.
So that house right there has a solar panel energy from the solar panels back to
the grid?
No.
Okay.
It's trends surplus.
See the bottom part,
the last.it says surplus electricity is fed into the back,
into the main grid.
Would that means is whatever they don't need.
So if they generate a ton of electricity and they don't need all the
electricity,
like say if they have a lot of solar panels but they only have a two bedroom
house or a one bedroom house and it's just,
you know,
a small comfortable place.
They don't need all
that power.
They have too much of it is choosing.
Man Did they want that power man,
you got that.
You got an extra power.
There's not what it is,
man.
You got to get rid of it.
Sounds crazy.
I think it's like too much and solar panels have too much power.
Yeah,
I think you can generate too much for what you could store.
That makes sense.
Then if you could,
and it's a problem like shit,
we got to,
we can't do this because then we collect too much and then it becomes a hazard
towing the city goes,
okay,
you could,
you could give us the extra,
you know,
as long as we care about the people and we want to go solar,
we want to go solar.
So we'll take that extra shit you got and we'll give you a little bit.
We'll get a couple of dollars for it too.
But don't,
don't stop.
Don't stop the cause.
It's all about
Eddie's having a conspiracy conversation with some imaginary executive is like a
dude selling weed.
It's like a dude settle.
We'd Yo yo Yo Yo,
I know you situation man.
Right?
You can't pay for Nate.
What'd you want a name?
So I'm gonna give you an a and this is what I'm going to do and I'm going to
give you three days and instead of the eighth being 50 bucks,
it's going to be 65 bucks.
Dog.
What are you going to get it right now?
I want you to buy a Mama House.
Do you gotta get into this?
We gained,
we gained is amazing dog.
It's amazing.
Why don't we in the weed game,
we should have our own want to stay out of jail.
Bravo.
We need to waste point.
We could have our own dispensary,
man.
Well,
I think honestly it's too much work,
Joe and Eddie's.
It's too much work they can't use.
Here's the other thing.
He can't use credit cards and a lot of these places still isn't not the case or
the transfer and large amounts of cash or hiring a ex military guys [inaudible]
guide to or or multimillionaire guy to use our face would beg for more than one
picture.
They want that one money shot tipped the hang in the front of me and you like
smoking a joint or something.
Well I'll do that.
But that's a Cheech and Chong do,
right?
They'll do like some sell some fucking rolling stone here.
We need that.
We'd have to remember when Tommy Chong got put in the pokey.
Yeah.
I think those things are gongs,
bro.
I hope so.
But you know what?
I was really worried,
man.
I was really worried of Ted Cruz got in.
I was like the nuttiness could like rise to a whole new level.
Like if you give people a bar,
and this is what I've been saying that I like about Obama,
whatever he did that people don't like,
I understand.
I get it.
I'm with Ya.
I'm not even saying that.
I'm not talking about his performance as far as like what he's done,
foreign policy was talking about like what he represents.
Like when you seen him on television,
he's well spoken,
he's articulate,
he went to Harvard,
he's a bright guy.
He seems like a guy that you would think would be like one of the smartest
people that you're ever going to come across.
Makes sense that he's running shit.
You know,
if a guy like Ted Cruz or a lot of these other people that wanted to be
president,
especially people with Wacky fucking religious ideas that just don't jive with
anything that we know.
If it fills,
people get into a position where they have massive amounts of influence.
People start getting really confused.
And I didn't used to think that until the,
obviously I've learned cause I'm older but I didn't think that that much until
the Bush,
the Bush administration and then the,
the nine 11 attacks maybe go whoa.
Like our consciousness is so much more fragile than I thought it was because I
thought what we were like as Americans in the nineties before the a nine 11
attacks during the Clinton thing.
I thought we were ridiculous in some ways because of the whole Clinton Monica
Lewinsky thing and then there was definitely some fuckery going on in other
countries but it didn't seem like the world was unsafe.
Like it seemed like the world,
the world felt like we got over that Cold War shit with the Russians were going
to be okay.
The world felt safe.
Like you had this guy,
even if he's full of shit and he's getting his dick sucked,
listen to him talk.
He's obviously smart as fuck.
You know,
like maybe some,
you know,
maybe some people that are crazy get to the point where their president,
some whip your dick out type dudes.
Maybe people get crazy and they still get to the point where the president,
but obviously a very,
very smart guy,
very well spoken.
And then the Bush presidency came along and it was so transparent.
All of it was so transparent and then the the chain have,
Cheney was essentially run the show and he was always in a bunker and everyone,
Cheney was always in the bunker.
He was always in a bunker.
There was always talking about Cheney's hidden away somewhere in a fucking
bunker.
And there was that Wolfowitz dude hanging around and all these other fucking
Donald Rumsfeld type characters,
all these merchants,
all these like war merchants there were all swarming around.
And then we're at war like all of a sudden were constantly at war for like this
massive,
massive amount of time and it's still hasn't let up all these years later,
dude,
nine 11 was 15 years ago.
People jumping off buildings and just smashing into the streets.
That just happened.
It was 2001 right?
2001 that's 15 years ago.
That's crazy.
Like we've been in a perpetual state of war for a sophomore's entire life.
Yup.
Sophomore in high school.
Some kid who's kids that are,
I think freshman this year are learning about it through history books.
They didn't experience it in one second of their life or so.
Of course.
Yeah for sure.
Well that most people that are even,
you know,
10 and above their parents would probably going to shield them from it for the
most part when it's happening 16 years ago.
So anybody younger than 26 barely understands what happened.
Barely.
That's fucking crazy.
What a change of the world.
So I get real nervous now.
I get real nervous cause I just don't think that the way we're doing it right
now is appealing to anybody that we really want to run us.
There's a few people like Gary Johnson makes sense.
That libertarian guy that we had in here,
he's,
he seems like a real person and he has real experience like running New Mexico.
I don't know enough.
I just don't know enough about politics.
I don't know enough to really mean.
I think you have to
know what the way you know Jujitsu.
I think you have to really know it.
Like if some dude who's like a blue belt in Japanese Jujitsu starts talking to
you about Russ locks human be like pitch,
you know that's,
that's what I am.
Really what I'm talking about politics.
I have like a skeletal understanding of the way the system works,
but I'm a for stripe white belt.
Exactly.
When to get my blue.
I would have had it already,
but I might have a yell about if we're ignoring karate.
I might've just gotten my belt after I got my yellow stripe and I was super
pumped filing my belt wasn't just playing white,
but that's where it ends.
That's where it ends and so like if I'm talking to some yellow belt,
they're trying to talk to them about effective striking techniques.
I get real irritable.
I'm sure.
Listen,
when you ask someone's rank and Jujitsu and they go,
I'm going to get my blue.
I'm going,
I'm going to test
bastard.
I'm going to test for my purple blue it.
Jiu Jitsu might be one of the only things that you really cannot possibly
understand what's happening if you don't do it.
If you've never done it,
you just are not going to know what's going on.
You're just not going to know.
You could have like a little bit of an understanding like here's an Armbar.
I've seen this transition to triangle before.
Oh,
I've heard it said that if you commit to hard on that Kamora and you don't have
control of the legs,
the guy can counter with the far side arm bar.
There's a lot of people like have these things in their head that they know to
be true,
but they don't know what the way you know it,
they're not going to know it the way you know it.
Just there's just no way.
They're not going to see things that you're seeing your,
when you watch and Damien Maia Choco choke out Carlos condit tonight.
You're going through the path with them,
right?
Like when you're seeing it.
Yeah.
You know the path.
A lot of other people are watching it and they're like,
they're in the middle of it.
He's on top.
Yeah.
Smashed Him.
He's getting all on him.
He's on.
Um,
so think about,
think about how few people can watch Damien Maia.
Choke out Carlos condit and see the path,
see the path he's going to take.
Watch him executed flawlessly.
See this Jujitsu,
not just in like,
oh my God,
what is he doing?
But see every single step of the way.
Well,
I think that there's just like Jujitsu,
that's just the case with every fucking thing that exists in this goddamn world
somewhere.
Someone is probably studied all their life to try to figure out how microphones
work.
You were.
I have put virtually no thought into it whatsoever,
but luckily somebody did.
So we have this microphone.
That's how I feel about everything.
That's how I feel about astronomy.
That's how I feel about the,
the Lunar Rover on the moon.
That's how I feel about all these things.
Like there's gotta be somewhere out there that's gotta be mad as fuck that two
dumps.
Donors are talking about whether or not the rover is legit and these fucking
guys been working out of their whole life.
They get scientific papers.
They like pulling their hair out in the middle of the night doing an Adderall,
trying to figure out how to make the calculations perfectly.
So this giant inflatable ball encompass or,
and what'd they do with zinc and cover what happens?
I think there's a giant inflatable ball.
I don't know if they did it this way,
that encases the entire machine.
I saw that cartoon.
Is that what it was supposed to be?
It was a cartoon,
but it's not real.
Of course they should definitely send back some video.
They don't have any video
of that dude.
It's people listening right now,
mad at us.
It's just proving people.
Your wife,
too many lies that you're like,
Yo bro,
that UFC bro,
bro,
that shit's fake as fuck dude.
That's just like WWE.
It's WWE.
But they've got some other tricks up their sleeve and I mean occasionally they
hit each other,
but dude,
trust me,
it's all fake.
So this is what it was.
If someone said that,
so parachutes came down thin ass atmosphere,
right?
There's almost no atmosphere.
They're actual footage right here.
So it drops and then explodes into these big inflates into these big bouncing
balls.
If that was in a movie,
you'd be pissed.
And then it has these things that try to slow it down.
These jets that shoot down and then it hits the ground.
It bounces.
This looks like the shittiest fucking place to move to of all time.
That's what Maurice looks like.
It looks like the desert.
It looks way worse than the desert.
Cause you can go to the desert,
get gas as a fucking highway going through it and he'd stop swearing,
taking shit.
[inaudible]
humans and you know,
very few spots.
If you land on earth,
you'd land on this probably more than a city.
A city is.
Fuck,
there's hardly no cities on this planet,
Dude.
I was camping in Nevada high country just a week ago.
Get on a plane and look down.
You don't see that many cities.
It's a,
it was way more barren wasteland than anything.
Well when you're in the Nevada high country,
you realize there's a reason why nobody fucking build houses out of here.
Like it's a hard scrabble world.
We were there in August and it's like a hundred degrees during the day.
It gets hot as fuck.
You got to bring a lot of water with you and then at night it gets down to the
30s it was freezing,
freezing at night.
I mean you freeze your fucking Dick off and there ain't shit up there.
Just a bunch of deer and some rabbits,
some occasional streams.
The sage bushes terminator right there.
Are you looking at the video right now because people are listening.
They don't know what we're talking about.
We're looking at the Mars rover landing on when you bravo doesn't believe in it.
Well,
this is not real.
This is a CGI.
Well,
this is CGI.
It's they have to explain where they are spending all their money.
I like it.
They're making this little robot arm come up.
This is a switch for sure.
If I was going to build a little robot arm,
I'd make it bounced all over the fucking surface of the desert.
That's how he imagined your iPhone was stuck in the middle of that ball and it
bounced for sure it wouldn't work.
This thing is robust strong wiring.
Imagine somebody fucked up one little wire and they sh they landed on the moon.
That's happened before,
hasn't it?
Haven't they shot things all the way to the moon and forgot they turned them on
or a all the way to Mars and it didn't work.
They don't always work.
Where's the
pops back on?
Yup.
Oh
well the youtube video is the most important piece of evidence.
Any kind of weekend we should cherish.
She could be on Vimeo as as well.
My space,
it doesn't.
USTREAM is good.
I like a Geo cities websites.
This is my favorite.
They have the best info.
Angel Fire.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you look at all the different websites today,
like how many websites are there?
If you had to guess how many,
like different places could you go on the Internet today?
Right now?
Hmm.
What makes sense?
I bet that's right.
Be Higher.
I was thinking just I think last night there was a time on the Internet,
not that long ago where you take,
you'd have seen most stuff that has come through like,
Oh yeah,
I've seen that.
I've seen that picture like you'd need to see a boobs.
You'd be like,
I know there's boots.
Those are,
but now there's just so much shit coming through.
Literally every single day.
You can't even,
you couldn't catch up if you want to make it up
point.
It's great for making like homemade documentaries too.
It's be like if you have a speech,
you got any speech,
you just want to just pour out all your thoughts and blogs or whatever.
You can actually,
anything that you're saying.
You could punch it in Google and just like have like a,
like a a low budget documentary.
Everybody's doing those.
You just collect all the pictures of what you're saying.
You listen to someone speak or you or whoever and just listen to it once and
write notes.
I need a picture of that in a picture of that.
You haven't,
you get all those pictures,
line them up,
boom,
and you have a goddamn documentary.
Yeah,
and that's on Youtube and then you change the world.
the fucker's let bitches know about rods.
You can do that shit on your phone now too,
which is even more interesting.
The whole movie on video shop.
I'm a whole movie on your phone.
You could just make a movie.
You and your buddies here hold the phone now and then and then you do your
scene.
Then he does his scene.
You edited it all together.
It's fairly does that a lot.
Is Carla Esparza that she,
she's always making these films.
Little tiny one minute.
Uh,
sketches.
Good for her.
She's very animated.
Nice.
Yeah.
Women's fucking strawweight division.
He ended up tonight.
Hell,
age van Zandt jumping roundhouse kick to the face.
That was crazy.
Okay,
so who soon Joe Hannah is the champion and then who else is right there?
Who's is there?
That Valentina Chick?
Yeah.
Volunteering.
Shevchenko she's a and also Valentina ship tank.
I'm sorry.
She's a Bantam weight.
One 30 thinking of a,
yeah,
cause Valentino shift.
Chenko just beat Holly Holm.
Remember we go
woo.
Yeah,
man.
Jessica Andraj she dropped down.
Okay.
Those are the top checks.
How come I don't recognize any of those girls down?
I don't know.
Shit.
I know Joanne called the Wood Cortney Casey
chambers.
Heather.
Joe Clark.
Okay.
These current rankings,
I can't because those top girls,
I didn't,
I've never heard of them,
but I've heard it all these Amanda Cooper.
I look at it.
Oh,
how dare you Jamie.
How dare you.
How right.
So it's a random listing.
Yeah,
it's just random.
I have a bet.
Um,
let's see.
They have rankings.
There we go.
Okay.
That's weird that they have it.
Okay,
here we go.
Women's strawweight.
What do we got here?
Blow that bitch shop.
Oh yeah.
Rose [inaudible].
Carolina callous to else.
Kvetch.
Kvl.
Kovich I have to say that right.
I always fuck it up.
Carolina Kl Kovich
ages waiting 10 young shit.
Kovacevich is the one who just beat rose.
That was a great fight.
Rose just lost.
Yeah,
she just lost it.
Cave all cubit.
Damn,
I missed that one.
And this Teesha Torres.
She's bad ass.
So Carolina,
Pete rose.
How does she beat her?
Just a decision.
Really good fight.
Was that a five round fight vision?
Why do I say,
why don't I think that was a five round fight.
You think Ron does coming back?
Fuck yeah.
Much money she make.
Do you know how big it will be when Ronda comes back now?
It could just be Rhonda and Cyborg right off the bat.
Right off the bat and that would be the biggest fight ever.
Just even right now.
Even though she just lost.
Do you think she would do that?
What do you think she would do?
That would be the most gangster move right there.
Who just say fuck it.
That that would be the ultimate gangster.
Rhonda just said,
I'm coming back and it's me and Cyborg.
We're gonna do one 40 let's fucking do this shit for a super bowl fight of all
time.
Let's do it.
That would be the gangster shit.
There would be the gangster shit or you got to get home home right now.
Homes like on a down swing.
It's a perfect time for Rhonda to cause for sure.
Homing going to turn down.
Rhonda.
Rhonda is in control of that fight.
She can get redemption right off the bat.
Do you think she does that?
Are you think she goes straight to a title shot?
All three cyborg would be the biggest title shot would be big there.
I'll be big.
I think cyber would be the biggest and people would understand that she's not
getting a title shot right away to the Amanda Nunes.
Genesis.
God Damn terrified.
She's terrified.
But her against sidewalk will be bigger.
Yes.
Even even with that top percent will be bigger than her and home.
Amanda Nunez is legit as fuck.
Obviously after she beat me she would take,
but she's going to have to have some more fights where people know about her
more to get the big money fights.
I think,
you know,
to get people like to get a Rhonda to want a fighter.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to see the Cyborg fight home and Rhonda would be fucking Mega.
You just base it all on the revenge.
But home did lose her last two fights.
So that kind of could,
doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter.
Busler Shirky roar Micky ward and um,
homeboy the fuck you to a Turo Gotti like that trilogy.
Nobody cared.
They weren't the best in the world.
No one gave a fuck.
No one can see.
That's what I think about this whole law and not that this isn't,
that is not one of the best in the world because he definitely is.
And so it was Nate.
Um,
but like they fight for the title at one 17.
They didn't matter.
Dana.
Yeah.
Dana,
thanks for some reason that that fight doesn't make sense to do it again.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
are you crazy?
Like please do it again,
please.
Like if they want to do it or they both saying they want to do it,
who the fuck doesn't want to see that fight again?
And if he's got to give up the featherweight fight or the featherweight title to
have that fight again,
can you just give up the title?
Give up the title?
Yeah,
put that fight on again.
Definitely.
You don't want to see that again.
Yes.
But it'll happen regardless of Connor wins or loses his upcoming matches.
It wouldn't even affect it.
Like if he,
if he decided to fight,
uh,
Matt,
it doesn't matter.
Even if it loses,
That's tonight.
That third fight is always going to be there because if you put Connor against
anybody at 55 right now,
haven't relinquished that title.
Give it back to Aldo.
Do 55 to anybody.
Do Magnum met off?
That would be huge.
Or Tony Ferguson would be huge.
That'd be a lot of press on that.
Tony Ferguson deserves that.
And then also you could just finish that.
Rafael dos Anjos let's make that happen.
Those are fine.
It's at 55.
It's already been stated.
This is going to fight for the title.
So he would go right to Alvarez.
He would fight Eddie Alvarez
be beautiful too.
Beautiful.
Holy Shit would be beautiful.
That would be crazy.
So many epic.
Matt did.
I'm telling you,
dude,
Connor's going to buy a fucking island and shit.
Yeah,
probably couple islands probably have a UFO.
He's like,
now he's going to have,
he's going to have a um,
uh,
what the,
what are those fucking hyenas?
Hyenas.
He's going to have rain is instead of bowls.
Pet Wolverine.
Drive a tank instead of a fucking any car.
What do you see?
A corner and covered tank.
A tank in front of a castle with hyenas?
Yeah.
Gold bars
all around us better in the private jet,
like Trump's private jet,
which is like a seven 57 just like a whole,
not just the little jet.
A whole Goddamn jumbo jet for yourself.
Do you know how know there's something wrong?
Trump.
Do you know how I know something wrong with Trump?
Because he was eating Kentucky Fried Chicken on his airplane with a fork and a
knife.
Was it okay when I tell him,
man,
that ain't good.
Tell me,
tell me what the fuck's going on there.
Can you hang with the dude who eat Kentucky Fried Chicken when the fork and
knife look at what's going on here.
What's going on here?
He got his class maybe.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
I'm a skunk.
I'm a scam.
How do you feel about fork and knife conducted fried chicken.
I feel like it's dudes who wear sneakers or don't have any socks on.
Listen,
you stinky bitch come back to America.
There's no proof.
It doesn't that seem like a very product placement type.
Little human right?
It does.
Do you think he got paid by KFC?
How dare you all bucket to himself.
He might,
what happened on,
uh,
go off shit.
Was it David Letterman or,
I don't know.
He was on some talk show where they were calling them out on bringing out
clothes from companies that he owned.
Like where did you,
you're talking about the China trade or where'd you make this isn't shirt shirt
is a shirt company.
Didn't cause that talk.
Meyer show that Seth Meyers busted them out.
It must have been old cause I'm thinking it's David Letterman and that must have
been at least two years old or something.
I Dunno.
But it gets called out on the show.
He's bringing out clothing the Donald Trump is owns.
Yeah.
Make America great again by hiring Chinese people to make your shirt.
But you know what man,
ever,
he's saying whatever it takes to have a friend.
I have a friend who has some sort of a marketing business,
um,
where a or a manufacturing business rather,
where they make,
uh,
clothes.
They make,
um,
like outdoor clothes,
like hiking and mountaineering clothes and,
uh,
they say that they can't
find a sew house in America that is up to the same standards as the Sohouse as
they find in China because they do so much manufacturing.
They're like,
look,
we would like to do this in America,
but in order to have the very best quality of clothing,
like you literally can't do what he's doing in America right now.
That's pretty fucking weird.
Like that's one of the scariest things that happened when they started shipping
manufacturing overseas.
It's like other places got way more manufacturing jobs.
Right?
But they also were working for insanely low wages and living in the factories.
You know,
like that's one of the weirder things about buying products.
Like,
if you buy something from China,
like if you buy an iPhone,
we all know it in our dirty little heart of hearts that there's nets all around
those buildings to keep those people from jumping to their death.
And they live there and have somebody actually like was arguing.
Well,
you know,
the statistic likelihood of someone committing suicide,
uh,
at one of those factories is not that different than the statistical likelihood
of people in the area committing suicide and since they live and work in that
factory gives you a deceptive number of how many people who work in the factory
committing suicide nuts.
Yeah.
So what's the problem?
I was like,
yeah,
but the problem is they're killing themselves where they work.
How many people kill themselves when they work like worldwide?
Like the numbers pretty fucking low.
That's why it's weird when people jump to their death rather than go to work
again.
That's fucking weird,
man.
That's weird.
Or were they smoking cigarettes when they jumped?
Yes.
Even weirder to work as slaves to buy cigarettes to jumped to their death while
they're making iPhones and people stare at them on by Agra.
Yeah,
they get Viagra and random boner pills.
Foxconn replaces 60,000 factory workers with robots.
Good News.
Not really for those people that needed that money.
I don't know man.
That's the weird,
slippery argument.
I know these people that had a factory down and uh,
somewhere in South America,
it makes some clothes for this big company.
And they were talking about how,
uh,
how much money it saves him.
I go,
yeah,
but does it didn't feel weird that these people are so poor and that they work
all day in the factory?
Like I'm not trying to be mean or anything.
She's like,
well then they didn't have that.
They would starve to death.
And I was like,
well,
would they really like how'd they get there in the first place?
Because this is the only option.
The only option is they have to work and sane hours for shit money so that they
can make clothes so they could barely get by.
Like that's the only option.
That sounds so close to slavery.
It sounds so close that it's just like an economic slaves that freelance st
slavery.
Yeah.
It's like they found that you don't have to,
a wild slavery evolved into,
you wouldn't have the fucking house them.
We just paid them so they don't think their slaves and then let them,
how's themselves have barely going to be at afford anything.
So they got to work all day.
Perfect.
Now we came up with,
for our fucking animals,
if they came up with basic income here in America,
like if they,
they they instituted like a living wage,
you know,
like whatever the,
whatever it would be.
And then uh,
then we started not doing that and like not doing that to other parts of the
world.
Like if America got to a point,
whatever the point is like 25 bucks an hour,
20 bucks an hour,
whatever it needs to be,
where you can totally survive off a war.
You can't pay anybody less than that because they can't survive.
Like it's been determined like this is like a reasonable amount you could pay
someone with their time.
The difference between that money and how much money you can spend in a third
world country,
hiring people to make your shit.
It's staggering.
The amount more money that you make is staggering.
It's a,
it's,
it's just weird that we allow it.
It's weird that we think it's okay.
Like it's over there.
It's over there.
It's just like,
if it was like,
fuck it,
this is my company.
I don't give a shit.
Well,
it's where we have like
boundaries.
Like we're okay if it's across the dirt or if it's across the water,
it's okay,
but if it's inside of us,
we would never allow it.
Right.
Like think of the United States of America.
It was nice.
He's from America,
from New York to Los Angeles has big open,
there's a lot of crazy shit in there.
There's a lot of places where there's no people living.
If somehow or another they establish some sort of manufacturing in the middle of
the country out there and paid people a dollar a day and had them working like
slaves and living in these buildings and jumping off the roof,
we would never tolerate it because it's inside of our dirt patch.
But if it goes across the water to the other dirt patch,
like outrageous.
Meanwhile for sure with us buying these things were directly responsible for
them being able to have such a factory in the first place.
And everybody's like,
well,
everybody else is doing it and we just keep doing it.
Factories learned,
uh,
how to use the Internet,
man.
They're fucking,
they bombard everybody in the Jiu Jitsu world about geese and rash guards and
special call man,
I get these emails every day,
multiple ones all over China,
Pakistan,
everywhere.
They're trying to,
they're going to come and after people now,
it used to be that,
uh,
only certain people had connections and he had to go there and find the
connections and your crazy stories about these guys in Jujitsu,
like Scotty Nelson from Otm.
Lynn,
you had to go to China deep in China findings factories and make these deals.
And Scott,
he's,
yeah,
he's got some nightmare stories.
Dude.
And Pakistan can imagine crazy shit taking is going to die.
I believe that he's got some stories.
He told them my podcast and we're fucking nuts.
I believe it,
man.
I believe it.
Fuck that.
Yeah,
there's,
there's parts of the world that you're just not safe.
And that's why when people come from those parts and they come back,
they go,
dude,
like we've got to keep this going.
Whatever we got going on here and we've got to keep this going.
We can't let this thing or a road like,
it's not perfect.
The United States isn't perfect,
but the whole world is in a fucking turmoil right now.
It's a sustainable,
currently sort of sustainable turmoil,
but it's in a turmoil,
you know?
I mean,
this is a weird time to be a person.
I think everybody realizes
we're in some strange transitionary stage of being a human being or human beings
are aware of like infinitely more now than they were just a few decades ago.
And we're evaluating everything about everything and putting it through this
filter and trying to figure it out and going,
whoa,
what kind of weird life where we live in this temporary existence,
trying to sort out this impossibly complicated,
fucked up world of political connections.
And one hand washing the other and the Clinton Foundation and all this word.
I'm gonna fucking,
Oh dude,
he says Gotham.
I don't know if it's true,
but I'd love,
I'd love some conspiracy theories.
And one of them that I've been dabbling in is all these people that crossed
Hillary,
that turned up dead
to business as usual.
Same Shit that's not so many,
so many
meme that uh,
you are statistically less likely to get bit by a shark than you are to get
killed by [inaudible]
Hillary.
She's a gangster.
Her and her husband,
those guys are fucking ghost.
Well,
do you think that they got done?
I would love to thank the doctor drew was on the way out anyway,
and then,
you know,
he got fired just coincidentally after he said that about Hillary.
I think,
uh,
I would like to thank that.
I think the corruption in politics,
uh,
borrows a lot from the mafia.
They work hand in hand most of the time and they bought,
they like to make statements cause there's show when you look into it,
he said people that are dying around Hillary,
dude,
there's people that are dying around,
uh,
Bill and Hillary from back in the day they get suicided.
If you got suicided of some guy who was about to do,
he was about to testify and then he gets suicide.
But it's obvious it's not suicide.
It's like he got,
he got shot in the back of his head.
It's,
it's a message.
It's a mess.
Just like the Mafia.
They are not going to just kill someone and make someone disappear.
That's a waste.
Why make them disappear?
Put them out or open,
cut out his tongue,
stuff,
his dick down his throat make,
give a message so that messages shut the fuck up.
We got to,
we obviously got the corner in our pocket,
so shut the fuck up.
They're all,
it's,
those kinds of murders are everywhere.
They're sewers.
They generally suicides.
That guy that got convicted a supreme,
who is that guy?
Hacer the got convicted of child molestation.
The only gave them 15 months.
She was defending Dennis Hastert.
He,
uh,
he's um,
I want to say
okay.
Oh,
he's with some serious judge.
The got convicted of child molestation,
pedophilia,
child pornography.
He's a house speaker.
This is a crazy story.
I just tweeted a study about it that uh,
they were doing an investigation of it.
Really scary stuff.
First paragraph.
Yeah.
Enormous amount of
tragedy surrounding revelations.
That former house speaker,
jade Dennis Hassard sexually abused a number of young men whom he coached during
his time as a high school teacher and wrestling instructor.
But there's also an enormous amount of hypocrisy as the public words of a Po.
Okay.
This is,
so,
this is him talking shit about Bill Clinton and Monica Lewinsky,
but he,
the thing is that he only went to jail for 15 months.
Like he,
uh,
he got an ax,
extraordinarily low sentence,
short sentence.
They give back.
We've just tried to find what the sentences,
because there was a,
there's a bunch of criticism about it and there's a bunch of 'em really
revealing aspects to it.
I don't know.
It's scary.
It's scary to think that someone could do that and only get 15 months because of
political connections.
But it makes sense.
Right?
Uh,
when I was looking up something,
uh,
I forget the exact name right now,
when I was looking through these a couple of weeks ago,
that the deaths and some of the people that were killed and some of the weird
things that were going on,
uh,
I'll try to find the guy's name,
but he was one of the,
uh,
pardons from Clinton before he got out of the office and he was indicted by
Giuliani for what was going to be the biggest us tax evasion.
And the history is something like 60 [inaudible] not showing 60,
$60 million.
He's a billionaire.
And he basically bought his way out of his conviction.
He had,
he had been,
I think he even was turned up dead after that.
He wasn't dead at all.
This guy just bought his way out of getting going to jail.
Okay,
you give money to this and that and then
you can do that.
No the right people and you got the right kind of cash.
You can't do it if you're Bob Wilson,
camera repairman,
you know you don't have the kind of cash to pay these fucking
people off.
Mark Rich was his name.
Yeah.
If you got cash you could,
if you have,
if there's enough money and power behind it,
you can get the people to believe anything.
As long as you can get it on commercials and like a on the news media,
you can get people to believe the most ridiculous shit.
You get people to believe the big Dick Pills or like actually work.
If you've got big pharma to market it and not like those late night commercials.
How do they do those late night commercials?
How do they get away with that?
Laws don't count at nine.
Can you imagine?
Imagine a big Pharma decided to take these big,
big pills.
Pay Off a couple of professors in Yale like they been doing and Harvard and just
say,
shit,
this really,
and then present it as a problem.
Or are you a victim of short Dixon drum or something like that.
You know what I mean?
But call it,
call it something,
call it something and can you imagine you get your pay off to do one dude,
one dude from Yale,
he,
you,
you have them on an the infomercial.
It's totally big.
Farm it out.
After a while you'd be considered a not
if you believe that shit didn't work right.
You understand?
It's totally all you need is a couple of Harvard scientist to say,
Oh,
you're going to,
you're going to gain the 20 to 30% in the first month.
Everybody would jump on that.
It's so easy.
You put it on fucking CNN news,
new report.
You can grow your male genital Talia up to three inches and four months been
disproven.
True here with the report.
All you need is one doctor.
That's awkward you.
That's how he get back on the mainstream.
Yeah.
Get him to do it.
Oh Shit.
That's how you get them back in.
And how would anybody ever get sued?
He has to kiss.
Can you imagine the amount of evidence you may need to sue the class?
Action suit all the pictures of Dicks that before and after pictures and the
class actions through the hundred and 50,000.
He wants you to see their little Derek and then still little Dick.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Eddie Bravo.
Let's wrap this bitch up.
We just did a four and a half hours or some shit.
Oh Shit.
And can I give a quick Ebi plugged?
Just smoke.
September 11th,
September 11th on UFC fight pass.
It's on a Sunday.
Um,
Ebi Eight,
the middleweights featuring uh,
Gordon Ryan,
Eduardo Tellis,
Matt Arroyo,
uh,
also you can get it on paper view if you just,
if you don't want to subscribe,
go to ufc.tv and I go to Ebi,
official.com to buy tickets to see it live.
We got $20 tickets.
We got the or $35 tickets and $85 tickets.
Tickets are on sale now.
Okay.
Yeah.